Ja, ich meine, wie viele Macintosh-Nachrichten hast du in deinem Leben schon wahrgenommen? Keine? In der Größenordnung, oder? Genau.
Bei diesen, wie hießen die? Die beiden Typen, die immer in WDR über Computer geredet haben.
Die beiden dicken heißen die.
Mach mal eure Zickezacke da aus hier irgendwie.
Meine Zickezacke ist aus. Ja. Die Klaus und Klaus oder wie hießen die?
Die beiden dicken.
Wolfgang und Wolfgang.
Oh Mann, das ist aber unfreundlich.
Das war tatsächlich, das war eben gerade echt. Die haben bestimmt schon mal über Max geredet. Und es gibt noch diesen CT, es gibt noch dieses CT-Fernsehen, die erzählen ständig über Max. Wirklich? Ja, die erzählen ziemlich oft darüber. Na, Adi? Im hessischen Rundfunk kommt das, glaube ich. Ich denke, da ist noch ein bisschen Nachhilfe zu leisten.
Ja, das wird ja auch mal Zeit. So, wir nehmen unseren Sendeauftrag jetzt auch mal ernst, nachdem wir eine Woche Verzögerungen eingebaut haben. Die Gründe sind wie immer vielfältig und gut. Vor allem, Pfingstwochenende, allgemeine Terminverplanung und du warst fast tot. Das kam noch dazu. Also auch verschiedene Ausweichtermine haben da nicht gegriffen. Aber dafür machen wir jetzt gleich die Ansage. Wir machen jetzt eine Sendung und wir machen nächste Woche auch gleich noch mal eine Sendung, weil es ist WC. Genau, so kann man das auch nennen. Oder Worldwide Developers Conference.
Aber das iPhone kommt doch erst am 18.
Wann das iPhone kommt, das wissen wir nicht. Aber ich glaube, dass wir das nächste Woche schon wissen, wann es kommt.
Ich lege mich mal fest auf den 18.06. Ich habe so eine gute Quelle. Was, Twitter?
Hab ich in dem Macintosh Informations-Divis Twitter gelesen.
Ne, bei Spiegel online.
Was macht dich so sicher?
Ich habe versprochen, es nicht zu sagen wo, aber es gibt einen deutlichen Hinweis darauf, dass es am 18.06. hier in Deutschland starten wird.
Okay, also du hast sozusagen eine geheime Quelle.
Streamen wir jetzt schon?
Wir nehmen sogar schlafen.
Das war schon der einen und das ist...
Ja, Dennis, ja, ja, ja, kannst langsam aufmachen.
Wir machen manchmal so einen Podcast.
Ja, hallo, schönen guten Tag, ich bin der Dennis. Und ich bin wie immer links, hoffe ich.
Ja, wirst du dann sein. Ja, jetzt sind wir gerade alle... Na ja, jetzt sind wir ja noch live. Also für diejenigen, die uns jetzt sozusagen hören, während wir sprechen, bist du genauso in der Mitte wie ich auch.
Ich rede jetzt zu zwei verschiedenen. Für die einen bin ich jetzt gerade links und für die anderen nicht, sehr raffiniert.
Du bist sozusagen Mitte links. Es ist ja auch kurz vor den Europawahlen, da ist es nötig, sich auch mal eindeutig zu positionieren, würde ich sagen.
Da sind einige noch relativ schwammlich.
Weißt du auch nicht, was du wählen sollst?
Ich weiß es auch noch nicht so genau.
Du warst noch nie so unentschlossen. Und das, obwohl das fast die einzige Wahl ist, wo du dich wählen darfst.
Ich bin wirklich kurz davor, die Piraten zu wählen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Bist du nicht dann ernst? Aber Pirate Bay will, dass wir Grün wählen.
Pirate Bay will, dass wir Grün wählen? Ach, die Grün, die brauchen doch erstmal Ansatz.
Also hat der Peter gesagt. Peter meint das. Peter meint, wir wählen Grün.
Eigentlich hat Peter ja verschissen.
Na ja, deswegen oder was?
Nein, weil eigentlich sollte er ja auf der SICK-Int die Keynote halten. Wollte er dann aber auch machen, aber dann hat er sich nicht mehr gemeldet, wie Sau.
SICK-Int, gutes Thema.
War er vielleicht gerade im Gefängnis?
Glaube ich nicht.
Aber du warst doch gar nicht da, warst du da?
Ich war in Köln, aber ich war nicht auf der SICK-Int. Ich bin nur durch Köln durchgefahren. Ich war gerade bei meiner Oma und dann war ich auf dem Weg nach Paderborn und mein Navi hat mich durch Köln geroutet.
Aha, verstehe.
Also an den Sonntag.
Also du hattest eigentlich keine Zeit.
Deswegen war ich auch weg.
Du auch nicht, Max.
Max war krank.
Ich war krank.
Zur SICK-Int.
Das war doch da.
Echt? Achso.
Also den Tag davor. Wir wollten am Montag eine Sendung machen, oder? Das stimmt. Und der Tag davor war doch noch SICK-Int.
Ja, aber am Montag habe ich deshalb abgesagt, weil du nicht konntest.
Ja, weil ich erst am Mittwoch zu Hause gekommen bin.
Ich war auch nicht auf der SICK-Int.
Ich war auf jeden Fall da. Ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel über die SICK-Int verlieren, nur so viel, dass es an sich eine ganz gelungene Veranstaltung war. Ich habe da in meinem Blog einen längeren Text abgelassen, was ich gut und nicht so gut fand. Wie das immer so ist mit Veranstaltungen, die das erste Mal stattfinden, da muss man noch mal dabei gehen. Aber was ganz gut war, war, dass da halt wirklich über Politik geredet wurde. Ist ja gerade ganz hip. Und ja, und was ich auch schon vorhin gesagt habe im Vorfeld, wir reißen jetzt das Thema Zensur nicht nochmal an, aber da hab ich mal wieder meinen Plagg. Letzte Chaos Radio Express Folge ist sozusagen zweieinhalb Stunden nur zu diesem Thema. Da hab ich mal so diese ganze Geschichte zusammengefasst mit Scusi.
Eine Hörerkritik, am Anfang großartig, zu Ende hin wird's leider ein bisschen schwammig irgendwie. Aber definitiv.
War das jetzt deine Hörerkritik?
Das war meine Hörerkritik.
Na ja, da gab's ja verschiedene Kritiken.
Da reden wir dann nochmal nach der Sendung.
Ja, also, was hat, wollen wir jetzt, nebenfragen machen wir am Ende. Tja, was ist passiert? Drei Wochen, mein Freund. Wir haben hier wirklich eine Menge, ist eine Menge an uns vorbei gerauscht. Ich war echt überrascht.
Ja, ewig passiert nichts, aber wir haben uns beschwert und jetzt passiert auch mal wieder was. Das ist auch ganz praktisch.
Aber vielleicht sollten wir damit gleich mal anfangen. Was mich ja wirklich total umgehauen hat, ist Google Wave. Das ist mal richtig mal was Cooles.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Was ist denn das? Ich bin mal wie immer, außerdem war ich ja auch im Urlaub, ich war überhaupt gar nicht online.
Du bist raus.
Ich bin raus. Jetzt musst du mir erklären, was es ist.
Gerne.
Du hast halt von Google, hast bestimmt irgendwie mit Datensammeln zu tun.
Jaja, natürlich.
Gott, Leute, entspannt euch. Naja, das kann man...
Nein, das kannst du auch runterladen, später als Server und dann auf deiner eigenen Installation.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal erklären, was es ist.
Erklär erstmal, genau.
Also, Google Wave ist jetzt mal ganz abstrakt gesagt ein neues Kommunikationstool. Und zwar so in der Kategorie von E-Mail und Instant Messaging angelegt.
Und Wikis.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht vielleicht auch Wikis. Es ist halt eigentlich nichts von dem so richtig. Vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von Instant Messaging. Ich würde sagen, es ist einfach die nächste Generation von Instant Messaging, was man allein schon daran festmachen kann, dass Google Wave eine Erweiterung von XMPP ist. Also Google Wave ist eine Erweiterung von dem Java-Produkt.
Jetzt vielleicht mal, also Sie haben es ein bisschen so eingeführt. Und jetzt vielleicht mal so, wie es aus Nutzer-Sicht aussieht. Also das hast du deine Inbox quasi in einer Webseite drin. Und dann sieht man Nachrichten und kann zum Beispiel so was wie eine Mail schreiben. Also eine Wave.
Das ist nicht in einer Webseite. Es ist in einem Wave-Server.
Naja, aber dieses User-Interface, was drauf ist, ist webbasiert.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit. Sie haben ja auch andere Möglichkeiten gezeigt. Es gab sogar ein Terminal-Interface und so weiter.
Wobei das eher ein Witz war.
Das war vielleicht ein Witz, aber das war halt gezielt gemacht worden, um einfach, ich glaube auch gar nicht mal, dass das ein Witz ist. Ich meine, es gibt auch Command-Line-Jobber-Client, und natürlich ist das auch ein Thema. Also, ein Wave-Server ist sozusagen ein aufgebohrter Jobber-Server. Und das heißt, du erbst erstmal alles, was du aus Jobber kennst, damit rein. Das heißt, du hast eine Kontaktliste, du hast deine Buddies, du hast sozusagen dieses Adress-Schema mit User at Host. Also, so wie bei E-Mail auch. Das heißt, du kannst auch deinen eigenen Server aufsetzen, so wie du heute einen Jobber-Server hast oder jobberccc.de benutzt. Du könntest halt genauso gut auch waveccc.de geben oder eben was auch immer. Es wird natürlich wave.google.com geben und wahrscheinlich wirst du einfach mit deiner, deinem Account at gmail.com oder googlemail.com, was auch immer, also deinem Google-Account arbeiten können. Und das Prinzip ist erst mal dieses. Du beginnst also Kommunikation, indem du eine Wave startest. Das ist sozusagen ihr Name. Ob der so glücklich gewählt ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber den haben sie zumindest durchgehend und konsistent benutzt. Und ich sehe halt auch schon so die Analogie mit, weißt du so, wo die Datenwellen trecken an den Strand, nicht wahr? Die Wellen kommen halt irgendwie so in Wellen eben.
Macht mal eine Welle.
Auf der Wikipedia steht, dass es aus der Serie Firefly geklaut ist, weil da ein Videocall immer Wave hieß.
Firefly. Nee.
Schon, kann mich aber jetzt nicht erinnern.
Ich hab nun mal, ich weiß, dass ich das irgendwann mal empfohlen bekommen habe, dass ich das mal gucken sollte, aber dazu kam es irgendwie nie.
Ist ganz cool.
Okay, gut, das kann sein. Auf jeden Fall sieht das halt so aus, ich starte halt eine Wave und das ist zunächst einmal irgendein Dokument. Also eine Wave setzt sich dann de facto aus mehreren Wave-Lets zusammen. Und so ein Wave-Let enthält halt ein Dokument. Das ist halt mal ganz simpel gesprochen eine E-Mail. Also etwas Text mit dem ich halt Hallo Dennis, la la la, wollen wir nicht mal ins Grüne fahren? Und dann füge ich dich zu dieser Wave hinzu. Das heißt, ich schicke nicht dieses Dokument an dich, sondern ich erstelle das Dokument und dann Und schickst mir, dass ich es mir holen kann. Und dann schicke ich, dass du hier volle Leser- und Schreiberechte hast. Das heißt, ich dragge dich dann in so einem idealen User-Interface, natürlich auch in dem, den sie da gezeigt haben. Sie haben so einen HTML5-basierten Web-Applikation gezeigt. Ich dragge dich dann halt da rein. Und dann wird sozusagen für dich eine neue Wave sichtbar. Und dein Wave-Server zeigt dir das halt an in seiner Inbox und sagt, hier neue Wave. Dann klickst du da an, machst halt auf und dann siehst du eben diese Nachricht, als wäre es halt eine E-Mail. Jetzt kannst du darauf antworten. Und das Antworten ist aber wieder nicht ein hin und her schicken von Daten, sondern es bleibt halt immer alles auf diesem Wave-Server. Jetzt erstmal nur davon ausgehend, dass wir jetzt auf einem einzigen Server arbeiten. Ich komme gleich zu dem, wenn mehrere Server beteiligt sind. Das heißt, deine Antwort wird quasi als Dokument, was sich als Antwort auf das andere Dokument bezieht, in derselben Wave gespeichert. Und so kann das halt hin und her gehen. Eine Besonderheit an der Stelle ist schon, dass du sowohl dem ganzen Dokument antworten kannst, als auch, dass du in bestimmte Teile dich hineinreferenzieren kannst. Also dieses Inline-Antworten, was wir so aus E-Mails kennen und hassen, weil es immer so messy ist. Das stellt dann eben, in dem Fall von dem Google Klein, also diese Beta-Version, die sie gezeigt haben, ist es so, du hast halt die originale Nachricht und da drin hast du Bubbles mit den Antworten. Sodass du eben wirklich die Konversation genauso grafisch abgebildet siehst, wie sie eben tatsächlich abläuft. Das heißt, du kannst da quasi Kommentare machen. Intern ist so eine Wave letzten Endes einfach ein Baum von Dateien, von Dokumenten. Und du kannst eben für jeden Subtree auch die Liste der Leute, die das eben sehen dürfen, auch wieder einschränken. Also du kannst zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, du unterhältst dich mit zehn Leuten über irgendein Projekt, willst aber dann so einen bestimmten Aspekt nur mit einem anderen sozusagen besprechen und dann sagst du halt hier einfach der Kommentar, aber den darf jetzt nur der eine sehen. Und das Schöne ist, dass du eben auch nachträglich Leute hinzufügen kannst. Wenn du also möchtest, dass dann, was weiß ich, es geht so hin und her, dann sagen wir, ach, lass uns doch mal Max auch noch fragen, so. Dann drängen wir halt Max auch noch mit in diese Wave mit rein. Der sieht dann wiederum in seiner Inbox hier neue Wave. Aber in dem Moment, wo er das aufmacht, sieht er im Prinzip die komplette Historie schon. Und nicht nur, also er sieht sozusagen nicht, er sieht nicht erstmal die Historie, sondern er sieht sozusagen den aktuellen Stand, aber eben als vollständige, vollständigen Ablauf der Ursprungsnachricht usw. Genau. Und er kann aber auch mit so einem Time Slider, du erinnerst dich vielleicht auch auf Time Slider, weil ZFS hat man ja auch schon mal drüber diskutiert, was halt einfach so ein Slider, und kannst im Prinzip die komplette Historie dieser Wave abfahren. Das heißt, du dragst so von links nach rechts und siehst so richtig, wie es so pappapappapapap von der ersten Nachricht, erste Antwort, nächste Antwort und so weiter sich entwickelt. Das geht dann so weit, dass du eben nicht nur immer wieder was Neues hinzufügen kannst, sondern du kannst auch Dokumente ändern. Das heißt, du kannst auch in die ursprüngliche Mail, also Mail jetzt wirklich in Anführungsstrichen, also in dieses Ursprungsdokument.
Weil die sind ja noch im Server, kann man immer noch nacheditieren.
Genau und das kannst du dann ändern. Du kannst auch mehrere Leute gleichzeitig erinnern. Das heißt, an der Stelle hast du auch die Funktionalität von SubAetaEdit. So, das heißt, wirklich mehrere Leute können live, und du siehst wirklich, wie sie gerade tippen mit so laufendem Cursor, wo an dem Cursor dein Name dran steht, gleichzeitig in diesem Dokument. Also du hast sozusagen auch diese Live-Wiki-Geschichte, wenn das sein muss. Ja, eigentlich ist das Standard. Was ist Standard?
Wenn du das Dokument gerade offen hast, dann siehst du, was die anderen Personen daran machen.
Ja klar, wenn alle gleichzeitig arbeiten. Das ist ein typischer Fall, du nimmst halt irgendwie eine Notiz während einer Veranstaltung auf. Also ich sehe schon, bei irgendwelchen Konferenzen, da werden einfach Leute Waves aufmachen und dann einfach gleichzeitig an dem Protokoll rumarbeiten.
Wobei das wäre mit Google Docs ja schon heute möglich.
Ja, bloß dass du diese History halt nicht hast. Dass es auch nicht so live ist, wie bei Google Docs, wie sie das bei Wave gezeigt haben. Also das war richtig so Zeichen für Zeichen. Really, really fast. Und...
Hast du schon live gesehen?
Na, es gibt halt dieses Video. Das ist nur eine Stunde 20 Minuten. Das ist von dieser Google IO. Konferenz, wo sie es halt vorgestellt haben. Die Typen, die das gehackt haben, sind diejenigen, die ursprünglich mal Google Maps verbrochen haben.
Ganz witziges Video fand ich. Weil auch eine Menge schiefgegangen ist. Ja, sind sehr locker.
Da merkt man wirklich den firmenkulturellen Unterschied zwischen Google und Apple. Den merkt man daran wirklich deutlich.
Also, wenn so eine Demo bei Apple gelaufen wäre, wären dafür einige Köpfe gerollt. Man hätte dafür das ganze Projekt eine stampfen müssen, glaube ich.
Okay, das ist jetzt aber erst mal nur so eine Art E-Mail, was halt ein bisschen direkter ist als die E-Mail, die wir schon haben.
Und mit Instant Messaging.
Ja, wo ist die Instant Messaging? Also, wo ist ja der Live-Chat sozusagen?
Die Tipps, indem du einfach reintippst. Du kannst, wenn du reply-klickst...
Ach so, weil man einfach, okay, okay.
Dieser ganze Thread, der sich da abzeichnet, kann halt auch wirklich total live sein. Du kannst irgendwie schreiben und jemand anderes kann ja auch schon wieder irgendwie schreiben.
Das heißt, ich könnte auch irgendwie dir eine E-Mail schicken, könnte dir schon gleich am Anfang dazu zufügen. Und wenn du auch am Rechner sitzt, dann kannst du schon sehen, während ich sozusagen die E-Mail für dich tippe, dann siehst du die schon.
Genau.
Kannst live-typing rein und ausschalten, das ist optional.
Dann könnte ich mir auch, wie das halt ist, manchmal, also Anrufbeantworter ist ja so ein bisschen, Anrufbeantworter wäre die E-Mail, aber wenn er rangeht, wäre das mit dem live-chatten. Manchmal kann man sich das lange Erklären ja sparen, wenn der andere dann schon gleich rangeht und er sagt, ja, ja, ich weiß schon Bescheid Folgendes. Und das wäre dann schon eine neue Art von Communication, spart man sich manchmal das ganze Rumgetippe.
Genau, das sah schon alles sehr schick aus. Das ist so, man sieht dann bei einer Inbox, also man sieht quasi, sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein normales E-Mail-Programm, so mit dreispaltig, wahrscheinlich links würde ein R-Ordner gewesen sein, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. In der Mitte dann hatten sie immer diese Inbox, wo man dann an jeder Nachricht auch sieht, so mit so einem kleinen Bildchen dran, wer ist denn das eigentlich? Eine Suchfunktion haben sie gezeigt, die war der totale Hammer. Also es war...
Die Suchfunktion und die Übersetzung, also es gab wirklich so ein paar Momente, wo ich wirklich dachte, so auf...
Also hast du halt eine Suche umgestartet, eine Live-Suche. Und der andere hat an dem Dokument rumgetippt und hat in dem Moment den Suchbegriff eingegeben. Also ich hab mit dir eine Konversation.
Der sucht nach Hund, du tippst Hund, und in dem Umblick, zack, ist es sofort gefunden.
Na so hört sich das. Nee, also nicht, dass ich selber tippe, sondern du, wenn du dann plötzlich in unsere Konversation das Wort Hund reintippst, erscheint das in meiner Suche. Mit Live drinnen.
Dann hat er auf Backspace gedrückt, und dann war das D wieder weg, sozusagen. Da stand dann nur Hund, und dann schnappst wieder raus. Also so wie man sich das bei Spotlight eigentlich immer wünscht. Und es manchmal auch so ist. Genau, aber das halt irgendwie übers Netz und alles gut. Ich mein, das war natürlich jetzt auch alles extrem latenzfrei. Das war jetzt ein Server, der wahrscheinlich in dem Moment auch nichts anderes gemacht hat, als wirklich nur diese eine Wave zu bedienen. Weil es in dem Sinne noch keine User gibt, außer denen, die da auf der Bühne standen.
Wobei XMPP ist ja auch so sehr, sehr stark.
Hört sich erstmal alles ganz cool an. Was gibt es noch für Features?
Da gibt es noch die Möglichkeiten. Das haben sie auch ganz gut dargestellt. Also man muss halt unterscheiden. Wave als Protokoll. So, das ist halt offen. Dann gibt es halt Wave, das Produkt Google Wave. Die Software, die sie da einsetzen, ist aber open source. Das heißt, das ist ihr erstes Produkt, was sie komplett open sourcen. Du kannst ja also dieses Google Wave HTML5 Kram auf deinen Server werfen und du musst nie mit Google irgendwas tun.
Ich habe auch mehrfach betont, dass deine Daten deinen Server nicht verlassen, sofern du nicht mit jemand kommunizierst, der auf Google Wave ist. Also wenn du mit einem anderen Google Wave-Jeser kommunizierst, klar, dann müssen die Daten zu Google, aber ansonsten.
Nämlich jedes Wavelet hat nämlich einen Ort. Also die Wave besteht aus mehreren Wavelets, aber so ein Wavelet hat einen Ort.
Also eine Art Zuhause, wo es gespeichert wird.
Genau, und den verlässt es dann auch nicht mehr.
Ist ja auch schon auch fast so eine Art Repository, oder?
Ja, kann man...
Wird ja auch verschiedene Versionen haben.
Ja, sie haben dann auch gezeigt, wie man Google Wave benutzt, als Interface für ein Bug-Tracker. So mit irgendwie da so reinschreiben. Also das ist so die Idee mit den Robotern, dass du User mit reinziehst, die gar keine User sind, sondern du hast halt solche Robots. Haben sie so verschiedene Robots gezeigt. Sie nannten es Robots, oder? Genau, zum Beispiel hatten sie einen, der hieß Bloggy.
Bloggy?
Bloggy hat quasi die komplette Wave, die du da machst, als Blog-Eintrag verstanden. Alle Anmerkungen sozusagen gleich als Kommentare. Und auch da war das wieder live. Das heißt, während du da irgendwie reingeschrieben hast, hat sich einfach die Webseite geändert, die halt so im Blogger.com-Style war.
Bloggy.
Und umgekehrt, auf der anderen Seite war es so, dass bei blogger.com, wenn du dann quasi, als Beispiel, wenn du da einen Kommentar ein gibst, dann kriegst du das wieder als Wave-Nachricht innerhalb deines Wave-Objekts zurückgelegt.
Jetzt gibt es wahrscheinlich schon den Robot Tweety.
Ja, den haben sie auch gezeigt.
Tweety haben sie auch gezeigt.
Der ist auch so.
Tweety.
Tweety mit Y. Also nicht Tweety EE, sondern Tweety mit Y. Das ist auch so ihre Naming-Convention für andere Sachen.
Das war aber ganz rough zurecht gemacht, dieses Tweety-Dingsbums.
Ja klar, das ist das, was einem so einfällt.
Naja, richtig geil waren, sie haben eben verschiedene Extensions gezeigt. Also einerseits gibt es halt diese Roboter. Dann gibt es eben verschiedene Extensions, die du sozusagen in dieses Produktiv-Nein installierst.
Roboter sind Programme. Roboter melden sich an beim System, als ob sie User wären. Das heißt, die können genau das machen, was auch ein User machen kann. Du könntest einen Roboter hinterpacken, der zum Beispiel...
Das ist eine Intelligenz, die auf den Content reagiert.
Naja, das ist zum Beispiel, die haben einen Rechtschreib-Kontroller. Das heißt, der liest einfach jemand mit, als ob er einen anderen benutzt.
Das ist halt einfach ein Wave-Client ohne User.
Und schlägt mir halt deine Rechtschreibkorrekturen vor.
Ja, schon logisch.
Genau, und diese Rechtschreibkorrektur war der Brüller. Weil das war jetzt nicht so Rechtschreibkorrektur, wie man das so kennt, mit ich schaue in so ein Diktionarium, dann schlage ich mal was vor. Sondern sie haben, wie drückte er sich aus, aus dem Web?
Bean-Bean-Test.
Also sie haben einfach mal so ihren Google-Index genommen, weißt du so, the Internet as a whole, und haben einfach jetzt eine Sprachkorrektur, also Rechtschreibkorrektur gemacht, kontextsensitiv. Das heißt, ein Wort wird anders replaced, je nachdem, wie der Satzkontext ist, den du gerade schreibst. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht mal das Beispiel, was sie genannt haben.
Mit Bien. Also sie haben, I have eaten some soup with Bien. Irgendwie oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau, dann war es E-A-N und dann I have been in Paris und dann ist es halt Bien mit E-E.
Und er hat tatsächlich einen Einfall, also wenn du sagst, ich hab was mit Boden gegessen, dann hat er das Bien, also ich bin gewesen, hat er tatsächlich als fehlerhaft angestrichen. Also war sich so sicher, da passt jetzt nicht rein.
Und das ist schon, das ist so ein Moment, das ist wieder so living the future, weißt du, so einfach so das kollektive Geschreibsel des gesamten Webs drückt sich in dein Dokument rein und sagt dir, wie du da das Wort zu schreiben hast. Also ich frage mich, ob das dann auch bedeutet, dass auch so Leadspeak dann auch automatisch irgendwie richtig gemacht wird.
Muss ja, das ist, wenn es halt ganz viele machen, denn...
Ja, da kannst du da so voll in Vortrennen...
Das ist halt schwierig, wenn sich was eingebürgert hat, was eigentlich falsch ist.
Dann ist es nicht mehr falsch. Dann hat sich diese Scheiße endlich mal erledigt, dass irgendwo eine Kommission rum sitzt, die sich an den Köpfen kratzt und uns erzählt, was richtig und was falsch ist. Das Thema ist dann auch endgültig mal gegessen.
Man muss das ja nicht benutzen.
Ja, grundsätzlich ist das natürlich cool.
Sie haben dann auch verschiedene andere Extensions gezeigt, natürlich irgendwie mit Google Maps und tralala. Also du hast halt im Prinzip auch diese Dokumenttypen, die du haben kannst, sehr weit. Und sie meinten auch, das ist jetzt so weit, wie sie es eben gezeigt haben, aber es würde nichts dagegen sprechen, dass du da genauso auch Spreadsheets nicht warst, wie sie es mit ihren Google Docs halt machen und so weiter. Und natürlich ist das relativ simpel gemacht.
Also diese Extensions, ich glaube, man kriegt wahrscheinlich einen View Area, in dem man sich total austoben kann. Und alles, was man machen muss, man muss dem Dokument oder Wave muss man immer einen XML-Zustand übergeben, sozusagen. Also einen XML-Datensatz, in dem ihr genau einen Zustand beschreibt. Und er übermittelt das dann automatisch an den anderen Rechner oder an den anderen User. Und die hat dann so ein Google Maps Beispiel. Und was braucht man für ein Google Maps Beispiel? Man muss wissen, was ist eingezoomt und wo ist vielleicht noch eine Linie gezeichnet und in welchem Modus befinde ich mich gerade.
Genau, da haben sie so eine Wave gezeigt und der eine ändert halt den Zoom und der Zoom ändert sich halt auch bei den anderen. Weil das halt der Zustand der Karte ist. Und jede Änderung am Zustand, die du machst, durch welche User-Interface es auch immer, wird in dieser Historie abgespeichert. Das heißt, wenn du danach auch wieder dieses Wave abspielst, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich denselben Zoom auch wieder nachvollziehen.
Ich finde, als Erstell wird übrigens ein Schwachpunkt von diesem Wave relativ deutlich rüber. Also dadurch, dass du jede Bearbeitung live machst, ich bin gespannt. Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Karte habe. Ich hab mit diesem Kartenbeispiel eine Einladung rum an Leute, weil ich eine Party mache. Dann bette ich da eine Karte ein, wo die Party stattfindet. Irgendjemand kommt dann auf die Idee, dann gucke ich doch mal, da ist doch gleich der S-Bahnhof in der Nähe. Zoomt drüber die Karte auf die falsche Position sozusagen. Macht sich aber natürlich nicht die Arbeit.
Aber wenn der Breitexcess hat.
Nehmen wir mal an, ich hab ihm Breitexcess gegeben.
Wenn du das versehentlich machst, dann kann er das natürlich machen.
Man kann unterschiedliche Rechte geben. Aber diese Unterscheidung zwischen... Darauf will ich eigentlich gar nicht hinaus. Ich möchte auf diese Unterscheidung hinaus, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal an, ich bekomme ein Excel-Dokument und ich will jetzt mal mit dem Excel-Dokument irgendwas rasch berechnen, dann möchte ich nicht alle Änderungen, die ich daran habe, sofort automatisch öffentlich haben. Auch wenn ich Schreibberechtigung habe, zwangsläufig. Ich möchte manchmal auch Awesline spielen, aber dann nur den Zustand drüber schicken.
Das hängt dann von dir selber ab.
Nee, das kann man dann nicht mehr einstellen.
Also dieses Beispiel mit Einladung schicken, jetzt sozusagen das komplette Ossering in Wave zu machen und dann dieselbe Wave dann als Einladung zu verschicken, um solche, was ja sozusagen dieses Sicherheitsloch würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen, aber diesen Hoppla, den du da jetzt meinst, zu erzeugen. Du kannst halt am Ende, das haben sie ja auch gezeigt, du kannst jederzeit den State eines Waves einfach kopieren in eine neue Wave und das dann sozusagen übernehmen. Hast recht, kann sein, aber ich meine, das ist Detail. Da haben wir stimmt mitgedacht. Das ist so wie mit irgendwie BCC und CC, also Fehler werden gemacht werden, das ist letzten Endes kein Problem.
Natürlich wäre, also das, naja, das... Also ich hab so ein, sind wir eigentlich durch mit dem, was es kann? Im Wesentlichen schon, oder?
Nein, noch lange nicht.
Noch lange nicht?
Ich wollte nochmal auf diese Sachen mit dem XML hinaus. Also es basiert ja auf XMPP und XMPP basiert komplett auf XML und auch alles in Wave basiert auf XML. Das heißt, alles lässt sich als XML machen. Das Protokoll selber funktioniert auch genau so, dass eigentlich immer jeder Schritt als diff reported wird. Das heißt...
Schon so eine Repositorie.
Genau, auch diese Roboter, nicht wahr? Die in so einer Wave einfach lauern, die kriegen einfach die ganze Zeit XML-Diffs zugespielt.
Das sind dann so wie Hooks bei Subversion, irgendwie so Post- und Pre-Hooks.
Genau, und sie erwarten halt, dass da einfach noch eine ganze Menge Anpassungen gemacht werden. Dass da Gateways gebaut werden, zu allen möglichen Diensten und E-Mail und so weiter dran gedockt wird, was sie offensichtlich nicht selber machen wollen. Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Das werden sie schon noch selber machen. Also ein Google Mail werden sie es garantiert anbieten.
Die werden was wahrscheinlich entwickeln, wo man möglichst viel noch mehr dranpappen kann. Also die eigentlich coolen Features, die kommen erst alle noch.
Naja, dann haben sie es irgendwie mit Safari. Also ich vermute mal Safari 4, Firefox. Da vermute ich Firefox 3.5. Und eben Chrome gezeigt. Also dieses Ding, was sie da ausgebracht haben, das setzt halt voll auf HTML5. Und da sind auch wirklich nette Sachen drin. Es gab ein einziges Feature, wo sie gleich dazu gesagt haben, das geht nur, wenn du Gears installiert hast. Aber wir wollen das auch noch in den HTML5 Standard rein. Das ist so, das so rein draggen vom Desktop von Bildern in deine Wave. Du kannst halt sozusagen auch, das ist übrigens auch eine echt powervolle Sache, dass du halt einfach so Bilder mit rein nimmst. Dann hast du da quasi so gleich deine Galerie in dieser Wave. Und da zeigt sich dann halt auch der Vorteil. Du hast nicht diesen Wahnsinn mit Bilder hin und her schicken, in Emails, riesige Teile und so weiter, die dann immer hin und her kopiert werden. Dann antwortet jemand und behält vielleicht die ganzen Bilder noch mit drin, dann gehen die alle wieder zurück. Sondern du hast halt das alles auf dem Server. Genau. Du kannst die dann auch umbenennen und alles irgendwie funktioniert mega live. Das ist schon wirklich beeindruckend.
Und der Sourcecode davon soll frei sein. Das heißt, da kommen für Linux, für FreeBSD, für Windows, Mac irgendwie lauter Server raus. Da setzt man sich seinen eigenen auf. Ich meine, die brauchen wahrscheinlich auch ganz schön viel Rechenpower. Also es ist wahrscheinlich nicht so, dass ein Rechner wie bei E-Mail mal irgendwie 10 oder 100.000 User haben kann, sondern es ist schon ein bisschen eingeschränkter.
Eigentlich braucht es ja nicht viel mehr, ab wie viel benutzt wird.
Naja, so wie es halt immer benutzt wird.
Ja, ist die Frage, wie das so benutzt wird, das wird sich dann zeigen.
Ich glaube, man braucht nicht so wahnsinnig viel mehr als ein bisschen XMPP-Server plus halt noch ein Web-Server.
Also wenn ich das jetzt schon so höre, wir haben ja auch irgendwie im Club einen Java-Server, glaube ich. Und da sind, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele User draußen, aber der hat auch schon immer ganz schön fett zu tun irgendwie. Weil immer wenn einer auch online und offline geht, da müssen die alle benachricht werden und das alleine sorgt für ganz schön viel Last auf der Kiste. Also ich denke mal, dieses Wave wird ganz schön...
Das lässt sich jetzt überhaupt nicht abschätzen. Aber grundsätzlich muss ich sagen, finde ich den Ansatz super. Ich hab dann auch mit Freude mir noch mal einen alten Vortrag von mir angehört, den ich mal auf dieser 9to5-Veranstaltung von der ZIA, der Zentralen Intelligenz Agentur, wie lange ist das jetzt eigentlich her?
Zwei Jahre, oder?
Genau, da hab ich mal so einen Vortrag gehalten über Kollaboration im Internet und den Tools und so weiter. Hab irgendwie da schon mal den Tod von E-Mail ausgerufen, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass sich E-Mail einfach nicht mehr fixen lässt. Und ja, ich war eigentlich schon immer der Meinung, dass das letzten Ende ist Java eigentlich so das Mittel der Wahl ist. Ich bin eigentlich echt beeindruckt, wie sehr Google das jetzt weitergedacht hat. Weil im Prinzip nimmt Google Wave alles auf, was derzeit an Kollaborationstools wirklich angesagt ist. Du hast das Element von E-Mail, du hast das Element von Instant Messaging, du hast das Element von Wiki bis hin zu solchen Sachen wie Sub-Ether-Edit, du hast Persistenz, du hast Notifizierung mit drin, du hast die Idee von Gateways in andere Systeme. Quasi ist da die Foundation dafür gelegt. Und was gibt es denn noch Wichtiges? Ich meine, das mit den Blogs, ob das nun wirklich jetzt so der Gateway ist, den man so benutzen möchte, das weiß ich nicht. Aber es war ein schönes Beispiel, wie das eben auch in neuere webbasierte Dienste, die zum Publizieren sind, auch ganz gut reininterfält. Also als generelles Authoring- und Kommunikationstool, insbesondere, wo es darum geht, dass mehrere Leute asynchron auf einen bestimmten Sachverhalt verwiesen werden sollen, auch als Archivierungstool, ist es einfach sagenhaft. Also ich will das haben.
Also ich will es auf jeden Fall auch haben. Ich finde die einzelnen Ideen da drinne grandios. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen overdone sein könnte. Also es hat mich so ein bisschen an Open Doc oder an dieses COM erinnert. Wie heißt das Microsoft COM, was die damals hatten, wo man so auch aus verschiedenen Dokumenten was ineinander einbinden könnte. Also irgendwie kommt es mir so ein bisschen vor wie das...
Ja, ist doch fast ganz anders.
Das Open Doc des Web, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen overdone ist. Einfach vom Bauchgefühl her.
Ja, aber überleg doch mal. Guck dir an, wie schlecht E-Mail funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, ich finde die einzelnen Bestandteile großartig. Ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, was man davon weglassen sollte.
Naja, eben. Das ist der Punkt. Mir erschien eigentlich kein Feature überflüssig, sondern ich habe eigentlich bei jedem Feature mir gedacht, ja danke, schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben.
Gimmie, gimmie, gimmie.
Endlich, her damit. Mir erschien, da ist zwar eine Menge drin, aber da ist deshalb eine Menge drin, weil es eigentlich erst dann Sinn ergibt, wenn das dann auch wirklich alles drin ist. Alles, was jetzt wirklich Sugar war, waren Extensions. Oder halt Roboter, die jetzt erstmal mit dem eigentlichen Core-Wave-Protokoll so nichts zu tun haben.
Das ist ja auch das Gute daran, anscheinend sehr modulast durch die ganzen Roboter.
Die erfinden vor allem das Rad nicht komplett neu. Sie bauen auf Java auf.
Sie bauen auf HTML5 auf, auf JavaScript, etc., pp.
Das ist einfach die Foundation. Also es ist... Hör damit.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es auch... Ich finde dieses Echtzeit geil, warum es das noch nicht vernünftig gibt, wundert mich seit Ewigkeiten. Ich finde diese schöne Kombination aus, ich kann mal eben in der Mail einen Satz ändern, die bereits geschrieben ist, ohne dass irgendwie...
Oder sie zurückziehen und hoffen, dass der andere sie noch nicht gesehen hat.
Ja, dann kannst du einen Typo halt auch nachträglich fixen.
Zurückziehen geht nicht mehr, oder?
Bestimmt. Also zumindest, wenn sie auf meinem Server liegt und der noch nicht zugeriffen hat, kann ich die auch da wieder runternehmen, dann kommt sie da nicht mehr ran, die wird ja nicht versendet. Die liegt ja anscheinend bei mir und der connectet sich zu mir, wer da noch nicht da war.
Also inwieweit ein Wave-Server als einem anbietet, die Historie zu löschen, das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Das ist mein Server, so ein notizierender Stecker. Also ich meine, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht rausgesendet.
Kann man durchaus vorsehen, dass ein bestimmter Schritt gelöscht wird oder zusammengefasst wird?
Aber das ist natürlich mal eine spannende Frage. Wie ist denn das überhaupt, wenn jetzt tatsächlich so ein Wave nur auf einem einzelnen Server liegt und dieser Server, nehmen wir mal an, ist zum Beispiel latent schlecht erreichbar, kann ich da nicht auf das Wave zugreifen? Oder habe ich nochmal eine lokale Kopie?
Das ist wie mit deinem E-Mail-Server.
Nee, es ist dann nicht mehr wie mit meinem E-Mail-Server, sondern plötzlich wie mit jedem E-Mail-Server, mit dem ich kommuniziere.
Guck mal, wenn du jetzt eine E-Mail versendest und der E-Mail-Server, wo du hinsendest, ist auch schlecht erreichbar, dann musst du dein E-Mail-Server halt andauernd immer wieder für dich probieren, dort eine Mail zu schicken.
Ja, aber wenn ich von dem eine Mail bekomme, dann habe ich die trotzdem.
Wenn du es geschafft hast, die rauszusenden, auch nur dann, du kriegst sozusagen gar nicht mit.
Nein, Moment mal, nehmen wir mal an, ich will jetzt nach zwei Wochen auf einen E-Mail zugreifen und der Mail-Server von der anderen Seite ist latent buggy, dann interessiert mich das nicht die Bohne, weil die auf meinem hoffentlich stabilen und schnellen Server liegt. Wenn es dagegen ein Wave-File ist, was nur und ausschließlich auf dem anderen Wave-Server liegt, habe ich unter Umständen ziemlich großes Problem, weil ich plötzlich eine Wave nicht mehr bekomme.
Du meinst du, das ist dann auch schon zu live und du kommst dann eventuell nicht mehr so gut ran? Ja, das ist richtig.
Also ich glaube, in der Regel wird eine Wave...
Das ist nicht mit Jabber halt, auch wenn der Jabber-Server langsam ist, ist der Jabber-Server langsam, ist halt nun mal live. Also live ist live. Da braucht man eine Kiste, die halt auch live ist.
Das ist halt so wie IMAP. Das ist wie der Unterschied zwischen Pop und IMAP.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, auch bei IMAP ist es auch mein eigener Server.
Du hast recht. Also es ist klar, wobei es ist halt auch ein Protokoll, was eben davon ausgeht, dass so das... dass das eben online verfügbar ist.
Deswegen ist Außen eine hohe Verfügbarkeit. Er könnte ja das Prinzip auch... Naja, aber was dann auch... Nehmen wir mal an, dass dann Obama im nächsten Wahlkampf plötzlich statt einer Mail einen Wave rausschickt und dann greifen da plötzlich 500 Millionen Leute gleichzeitig drauf zu. Dann sehe ich da beim Server schon mal relativ echt.
Aber es ist ja nun so, da du ja als Client sowieso die vollständige Information an einer Wave bekommst, anschließend der kompletten History, kannst du im Prinzip auch Replikations-Features implementieren.
Ja, aber ich sehe es so ein bisschen als... Ich halte es für eine großartige Sache, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, ich hab mir das angeguckt, hab es sehr sehr schön gefunden und hab gesagt, hab mir aber so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf gedacht, ob sie sich damit nicht doch vielleicht ein bisschen verhoben haben. Ob das nicht schon ein Schritt zu viel war. Weil es ist schon ein...
Aber was hätten sie denn sonst tun sollen?
Dass langsamer rausrollen sollen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht in welcher Form, es ist eigentlich relativ konsequent gedacht und so.
Langsamer? Sie haben doch gar nichts ausgerollt.
Ja, aber nicht alle Features auf Anhieb sozusagen drin haben wollen und diese Embedding-Features vielleicht erst mal nach hinten anstellen oder so was. Ich fand, es war...
Naja, ich denke, sie wollten da schon auch eine klare Vision geben, wie das so ist. Und gerade mit diesem Embedding, dass man eben diese ganzen Waves auch in Social-Network-Sites oder so abbilden kann, geben sie halt einfach auch ganz klar vor, wo sie hinwollen.
Ja, natürlich. Also wie gesagt, ich halte es alles für nicht verkehrt, aber erstens möchte ich gerne wissen, wie viel JavaScript wird dann oder wie viel muss dann vom Server nachgeladen werden, wenn du so eine Seite aufrufst? Das wird schon einiges sein, was da auf dich zukommt.
Wenn das deine einzigen Sorgen sind...
Das sind nicht meine einzigen Sorgen. Nein, nein. Es ist einfach, dass ich so das Gefühl habe, das könnte ein Problem sein, was Google so erstmal nicht so leicht in der Kontrolle kriegt, weil es einfach als Produkt erstmal zu dick ist.
Das ist mein Gefühl.
Es ist so ein Bauchgefühl. Ich hoffe, dass es ein falsches Gefühl ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, im Vergleich zu dem, was sie bisher sonst so ausgerollt haben, insbesondere ihrem Search-Kram, ist das einfach mal echt nicht das Problem. Weil sie wissen, also was sie gezeigt haben mit Google Wave ist, dass sie wirklich erstmal das Problem, die Problemdomäne, extrem gut verstanden haben. Also erstens, was das eigentliche Problem ist bei der Kommunikation. Im Prinzip fasst das ja auch all ihre Dienste zusammen, die sie derzeit haben. E-Mail, Instant Messaging, Gmail, Talk, weiß ich gar nicht, war da Audio eigentlich mit drin? Haben sie da irgendwas gezeigt?
Mit Audio war da noch nichts, oder?
Ist aber nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis sozusagen auch Audio dort voll mit abgebildet ist. Google Docs ist da im Prinzip mit drin. Also das kommt irgendwie alles ganz gut zusammen. Und natürlich auch ihre HTML.
Ganz kurz, schon durch, habt ihr bekommen, das US-Verteidigungsministerium hat versehentlich...
Du willst hier jetzt nicht ablenken.
Nee, nee, aber das ist einfach zu geil, um es nicht zu sagen... .autotune. Eine Liste aller amerikanischen Atom-Facilities versehentlich auf einen Webserver gestellt. Und Wikileaks ist gerade quasi komplett down, weil sich alle diese Liste runterladen.
Oder müssen wir jetzt das Internet kommentieren? Ähm, ja, wo wir gerade... Haben wir das Thema Google Wave? Dennis, hast du das Gefühl, du hast es verstanden? Ist gut. Was da jetzt ganz gut...
Wann gibt es die Software?
Im Sommer wollten sie...
Das war glaube ich so later this year mäßig.
Also noch dieses Jahr soll es als Open Source rauskommen und auf ihren eigenen Servern haben sie jetzt schon für die Developer, die auf Google IO waren, Sandbox-Accounts rausgegeben, damit die schon mal rumspielen können. Und ich glaube noch im Sommer quasi soll es auf ihren eigenen Servern, also dass man es als Google Mail...
Haben die jetzt schon gesagt, zu welcher Plattform das so rauskommen wird?
Web.
Das wird ein Python-Server sein?
Nicht das Interfere ist für die User, sondern auf welchem Server man es installieren kann.
Das ist ein Python.
Das?
Das wird ein Google App Engine sein.
Der Server.
In Python.
Was ist denn eine Google App Engine?
Vergiss es.
Nee, und nimmer ist das ein Python-Geschichte.
Wer formt nicht.
Wer formt nicht, auch nur im Ansatz die Bohne nicht.
Nee, Quatsch, sie haben doch gesagt, wo wir uns das entwickeln, in Java. Sie haben doch gesagt, dass es mit GWT und Google Web Toolkit...
Richtig, das haben sie sogar gesagt.
Also...
Java ist schnell mittlerweile.
Womit willst du sowas anschreiben?
Ich lobe dir ja nicht.
Na, bei Google ist das ohnehin die Sprache, mit der sie schnell Sachen machen.
Ich schreib so Zeug nicht.
Es ist Java und es ist schnell genug. Also...
Das muss mir ja bis heute noch jemand beweisen, dass Java schnell ist.
Das ist schnell. VMs sind einfach schnell. VMs sind derzeit überhaupt der Weg, wie du Sachen schnell kriegst. Das war lange Zeit... Also die Zeiten, wo eine VM so lahmarschiger Interpreter war und das irgendwie wirklich geschneischt hat, die sind mehr als vorbei. VMs sind derzeit der Weg, mit dem du Sachen schnell kriegst. Und zwar schneller als das sogenannte Native compiling, weil du ganz andere Optimierungsschritte zur Laufzeit machen kannst.
Da gab es auch mal so einen knuffigen Test von einer IX, wo sie C++ gegen Java haben antreten lassen. Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Und zu dem Ergebnis gekommen sind, dass Java damals bei nicht allen, also es gibt natürlich Bereiche, in denen es C++ unschlagbar schnell, aber spätestens wenn es dann so in die objektorientierte Ecke ging, hat Java einfach mal es wirklich runden um C++ gelaufen.
Ja, also da kann ich auch wieder mal Chaos Radio Express 122 empfehlen. Als ich mit Hannes zusammengesessen hab, war es zwar ein bisschen ein konfuser Podcast, aber da ging es so um Optimierungsgeschichten und so, aber wie auch immer.
Da gibt es ja demnächst auch einen Datengarten im Berliner Club.
Genau, Hannes erklärt das nochmal live.
23.06. oder 25.05. ist auf jeden Fall ein Donnerstag und da ist er mit einer 2 vorne.
Genau, er zeigt da seine schönen Real-Time-Visualisierung von Compileroptimierungen. Wer so etwas interessiert, der mag da vielleicht gerne hingehen.
Wir sind noch zwei Roboternamen eingefallen. Spammy und der andere, der andere noch viel besser und viel passender, Fischy.
Wie viel Spam kriegst du über Instant-Messaging? Über Jabber? Null.
Ich auch.
Wie viel Spam wird man über Wave kriegen?
Kommt drauf an.
Kommt drauf an, aber ist eine ganz andere Geschichte, eine ganz andere Art der Authentifizierung, eine ganz andere Art und Weise der Kommunikation. Ist opt in und nicht opt out. Na ja, ist halt irgendwie deine Kontaktliste sozusagen.
Wenn mich einer anschreiben will, der mich noch nie angeschrieben hat.
Dann geht das sicherlich auch irgendwie.
Es wird Spam geben, also es wird nicht null sein, aber ich meine, so unglaublich viel Spam, wie es per E-Mail im Augenblick gibt, kann es. Also das muss erst mal eine zweite Plattform hinkriegen. Bei Wave würde vorher das Internet zusammenbrechen, bevor da 98 Prozent Spam sind.
Ja, auf jeden Fall kann man da sehr viel feiner reinschauen. Keine Ahnung, darüber will ich jetzt auch gar keine Mutmaßung machen. Ich hab zwar so den Eindruck, es könnte sich da was ändern. Auf jeden Fall schreibt Wave von vornherein halt, es ist TLS-Kommunikation vor und so weiter. Also wenn du da überhaupt irgendwie erstmal an den Server ran willst, dann ist das verschlüsselt sozusagen. Also bei Default sind Wave-Verbindungen verschlüsselt. Also wie es bei Java ist, ist es ja an sich noch optional. Das ist dann bei Wave sozusagen, da machen sie einfach dich. Das steht gleich am Anfang in ihrem Protokoll mit drin. Wir machen hier TLS und gib ihm. Das heißt, du hast auf jeden Fall erstmal bei dieser Übermittelungsebene eine Zertifizierung des Ursprungs. Und das ist ja schon mal ein Problem bei Spam, bei E-Mail-Spam. Das kommt halt von irgendwo her. Du hast keine Ahnung, von wem, wie was. Und sollte halt wirklich jetzt jemand Wave-Spam schicken, dann ist er halt in dem Moment auch eindeutig identifizierbar. Und dann ist das irgendwie im nächsten Moment auch abgedreht der Haar. Also von daher sehe ich da eine ganze Menge Potenzial für Spambefreiung. Das könnte natürlich auch den Dienst enorm pushen. Ich meine, sie haben da wirklich alles eingebracht. Ich meine, ich hab mir wirklich bei dieser Veranstaltungsplanung, die ich jetzt über Jahre gemacht habe, hatte ich einfach immer genau dieses Problem. Permanent hatte ich irgendwie andere Leute, die ich mit einbinden musste. Ich musste Leute vor allem auch immer wieder in bestimmte Prozesse nachträglich mit reinbringen. Leute fallen raus, neue Leute sollen die ersetzen. Die ganze Kommunikation transparent zu machen, extrem schwierig. Per E-Mail ein riesiger manueller Aufwand, das kennen wir alle. Dann hab ich irgendwie mit Wikis versucht, diese Dokumenten erarbeitet zu machen. Und das war ein riesiger Vorteil, dass man da eben die Historie hatte und so weiter. Aber es war halt wieder ein anderes System. Request Tracker eingesetzt. Auch das wäre etwas, was man mit Google Wave sehr interessant machen kann, dass halt einfach Request, die von außen kommen, halt gleich übernommen werden. Und du kannst ja vor allem auch Waves innerhalb von Wave zu Wave linken. Mit Drag und Drop kannst du sozusagen auf komplett andere Kommunikationsstränge verweisen. Das heißt, alles ist verlinkbar. Es ist ein einziges riesiges Web von Hin- und Herkommunikationen und geänderten Dokumenten. Es ist halt multimedial, dass du eben alle Datentypen dort mit drin haben kannst. I'm sold. Ich sag's euch. Ich find das richtig geil. Und ich glaub, Google ist da an was ganz Dicken dran. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, naja, jetzt gibt's auch noch Google Reader oder so. Ja, sondern ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, wenn sie das nicht nachhaltig verkacken, dass das schon zumindest ein signifikanter Vorschlag ist für die Zukunft der Kommunikation im Internet. Also dass das wirklich das Potenzial hat, das Ding zu sein, was vielleicht nicht alles ablöst, das ist ein sehr langer Prozess, aber wo zumindest sich viele darauf stürzen werden, anstatt auf irgendwas anderes zu gehen. So, jetzt machen wir mal die Kasten zu. Da gibt es bestimmt noch eine ganze Menge zu erzählen. Aber wer sich dafür interessiert, der soll sich auch einfach mal diesen...
Aber ich habe noch eine kleine Google-Frage. Und zwar war mir so, als wenn ich letztens gelesen habe, dass der Browser von denen, der Chrome, für Mac jetzt irgendwie...
Der kommt voran.
Kommt voran oder ist verfügbar? Mir war es, als wenn ich auf der anderen Seite was runterladen wollte und da war nichts.
Nee, es gibt doch keine finale Version. Aber man kann sich natürlich immer die Nightly-Bills quasi runterladen. Und die wären zusehends benutzbarer. Also ich mach das dann wieder mal, guck mir dann mal wieder eine neue Chrome-Version an, wie es im Augenblick so aussieht.
Also die gibt es schon irgendwo.
Ja, such einfach mal nach Chrome, Mac, Nightly oder irgendwie sowas. Dann kommst du auf den entsprechenden Strang, wo du das runterladen kannst.
Ok, ok, Chrome hourly builds for Mac hier, alles klar.
Genau. Und da holt man sich einfach die neuesten runter.
Und alles ist super.
Und Flash geht noch nicht, also Plugins gehen noch nicht. Aber ansonsten macht das durchaus schon.
Wo du gerade bei Chrome bist, es gab im Chromium-Block, also das Block, was sich sozusagen um den Open Source-Aspekt da kümmert, haben sie sich irgendwie geäußert zum Thema Sandboxing und Mac OS X?
Habe ich leider nicht gesehen. Sollte einfach gut super gehen?
Im Kern haben sie gesagt, na ja, wir wollten mal sagen, wie das auf Mac ist. Und während das bei Windows und Linux alles ein bisschen Schmerz im Arsch ist, ist das bei Mac OS X ja total einfach, weil da sagst du Sandbox in it und los geht's. Sie benutzen also einfach das Sandboxing von Mac OS X. Das Chrome wird wahrscheinlich zu 10.5 und aufwärts sein. Das wird für Tiger nicht mehr angeboten werden. Das ist auch absolut nachvollziehbar.
Auch mal vorbei mit Tiger, wenn er 10.6 kommt, wenn es denn mal kommt.
Genau, aber sie machen halt ansonsten das gleiche Prinzip, dass sie halt einen Prozess haben pro Tab, aber sie schmeißen den dann halt in diese Sandbox, machen das Ding halt komplett dicht und kommunizieren dann einfach nur über Sockets mit dem Hauptprozess und haben da irgendwie ihr eigenes Protokoll, mit dem sie das Ganze machen.
Und die kann man auch schön sehen, da sieht man auch hier in der Aktivitätsanzeige, sieht man schön, wenn man drei Tops-Affen hat, hat man vier Prozesse. Einer für wahrscheinlich die Jigkei und drei für die entsprechenden Tabs.
Ja, das ist halt der Bereich, der mich so interessiert, wie mit diesem Multisraling, aber wir haben ja nun mal irgendwie auf dem Laptop Dual Core die dicken Rechner inzwischen vier oder acht Kerne demnächst dann noch mehr. Also da ist halt Apps, die auch ein bisschen mehr Power brauchen und der Browser gehört ja mit dem ganzen Schnick-Knack schon auch zu den Großverbrauchern auf so einem Rechner, wie das halt so performt. Ok, habe ich jetzt installiert, weiß ich Bescheid. Wollte ich mal so wissen, können ja viele andere auch mal machen.
Ja, was jetzt noch ganz gut dazu passt, zumal ja auch hier HTML5 bei Google Wave große Rolle gespielt hat, nicht wahr? Also sie haben ja auch, das wird glaube ich ja auch erstmal das sein, was sozusagen vieles ausbremst. Sie sagen einfach, das ist jetzt eine HTML5 Anwendung. Das heißt, du wirst es mit Internet Explorer auf absehbare Zeit nicht benutzen können. Und, sondern es wird halt nur mit Safari, Firefox und Chrome gehen. Wobei das nur ist so eine Sache. Ich hab mir mal die Statistiken angeschaut, die aktuellen. Es geht weiter, wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal drüber berichtet hier. Ich war diese Market-Share-Analyse von NetApplication. Der Niedergang von Internet Explorer.
Bisher ist es doch ein Niedergang auf sehr, sehr hohem Niveau weiterhin, aber...
Es sind 0,7% pro Monat. Also es ist einfach mal signifikant. 65% ist der Internet Explorer jetzt.
Aber was da auch stand, ist, dass der... Wie soll man sagen? Also der Firefox, der nimmt ja immer mehr Marktanteil ein.
Safari auch.
Der Safari auch. Aber...
Chrome auch.
Der Firefox nimmt mehr... Also der wächst noch schneller als der Safari. Also der Abstand war mal zwischen den beiden bei 8% und ist jetzt inzwischen bei 11%.
Ja, wundert mich nicht. Der Grund ist einfach der, dass er diesen Marktanteil natürlich vor allem auf Windows gut macht. Und da ist halt einfach Firefox das bessere Angebot als Safari. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, inwieweit jetzt das neue Safari 4, wenn es dann mal kommt, mit irgendwie... Du kannst mich jetzt auch im Windows-Look angucken und ich muss jetzt nicht mehr so applich...
Das sieht jetzt unter Windows wesentlich...
Das könnte da sozusagen nochmal was bewegen. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch gut so. Weil ich glaube, wenn alles nur noch WebKit wäre, dann ist es auch blöd, weil dann würden wir halt nicht HTML5 mehr sehen auf der Welt, sondern nur noch WebKit. Aber es zeigt sich halt, dass Microsoft irgendwie nicht mehr mithalten kann.
Aber ich glaube, sie haben es nicht verstanden.
Weiß ich echt nicht. Ich glaube, sie sind einfach derzeit nicht in der Lage. Ob es nur daran liegt, dass sie nicht willens sind oder so. Aber irgendwie sind sie nicht in der Lage, mental oder von ihren Fähigkeiten her, keine Ahnung.
Habt ihr das?
HTML5, Moment, ich wollte ja noch was dazu sagen. HTML5, wir haben ja schon mal darüber geredet. Das ist echt ein fettes Teil. Weil es gibt jetzt erste Demoseiten von YouTube. youtube.com/html5. Wenn du da mit irgendwie Safari drauf gehst, dann siehst du halt YouTube, aber kein Flash.
Ich glaube, Sevenload gibt es auch schon so eine Demoseite für.
Wirklich? Dailymotion hat sowas auch.
Nee, dann war es Dailymotion, dann war es nicht Sevenload. Ich verwechsel die immer.
Unterschied, Dailymotion setzt tatsächlich auf Okteora.
Ach so, das als Dateiformat.
Genau, als Filmformat. Genau, während YouTube auf H264 setzt. Und das ist ja eigentlich die große ungeklärte Komponente in diesem ganzen HTML5-Poker. Nokia hat es glaube ich irgendwie, wahrscheinlich viele andere auch, fast alle haben wir ja irgendwie gegen Teora. Womit sich aber jetzt ganz interessante Fronten öffnen. Also kurz gesagt, die Diskussion ist halt immer die alte. Teora ist halt frei, in Anführungsstrichen. Wobei die kommerzielle Welt halt einerseits sieht, dass eben Teora nicht so gut ist wie H264. Die machen jetzt auch Fortschritte, aber trotzdem. Und es ist halt im Wesentlichen eine Patentfrage, nicht wahr? Das Argument des OK-Lagers ist natürlich nachvollziehbar. Das ist halt frei im Sinne von frei. Und da sind keine Patente drauf. Und das andere Lager sagt, naja, hat bloß noch keiner gegengeklagt.
Ja, für H264 werden ja auch offiziell zumindest noch in zwei Jahren oder so was Lizenzgebühren fertig. Zumindest fürs Encoding. Und dann wird das nochmal ein neuer Spaß, wenn es dann plötzlich keine kostenlosen Encoder mehr gibt.
Ja, ich glaub, das mit den Encodern, das ist in dem Sinne ja nichts Neues. Das ist aber bei MP3 heute auch schon so.
Na ja, MP3 kannst du kostenlos encoden. Du kriegst bloß die... Ah, jetzt lehne ich mich mal ein bisschen aus dem Fenster. Ich bilde mir ein, dass das...
Definitiv das Encoding. Das Encoding war schon immer der Ort, wo sie abgefischt haben. Auch bei GIF.
Ja, sie haben beim Encoding abgefischt. Aber auch der Encoder, ich bilde mir ein, dass es so war, dass auch bei MP3 der Encoder selbst frei war, quasi oder kostenlos war, aber gute Encoding-Settings einfach Geld kosteten.
Encoding ist das, wo du eine Lizenz brauchst. Und auch die freien Dinger, die haben halt, also freie nehmen halt entweder die Referenzimplementierung von Fraunhofer und bauen die irgendwie ein, oder sie haben halt irgendjemand, der diese Lizenzgebühren zahlt. Das ist auch bei H264 genauso auch. Dieses X264 Open Source Projekt, was halt im Prinzip eine Lizenz braucht, kriegt diese, weil es halt Firmen gibt, die das bezahlen für dieses Open Source Projekt. So, und insofern ist das ja auch ein alles vollkommen nachvollziehbares Argument, dass Teora halt frei ist. Bloß die Firmen sagen halt, wenn wir jetzt anfangen würden, Teora zu verwenden, dann wüssten wir ja nicht, ob nicht irgendjemand noch ein Patent auspackt. Weil das mit dem ist patentfrei, ist zunächst einmal eine Behauptung. Es ist halt nur so, dass die Firma, die ursprünglich mal diesen Codec gesponsert hat, die IP, also die Intellectual Property Rechte, die Patente, die theoretischen, die sie daran halten, eben mitgespendet haben. Das heißt, von dem eigentlichen Ersteller dieses Codecs droht nichts los. Das heißt ja nicht, dass nicht diese Algorithmen irgendwann nochmal angefochten werden von irgendjemanden, der irgendeinen Patent hält. Und das ist halt genau das, was ich eben die Industrie vom Hals halten will. Deswegen haben die sich auf MPEG 4 und vor allem auf H264 geeinigt und gesagt, das ist jetzt das, was wir machen wollen. Da wissen wir wenigstens, woran wir sind.
Ist das denn so hundertprozentig klar, dass es bei H264 nicht auch noch irgendwo jemanden Patent aus der Tasche holt von Mitte der 90er und sagt, jetzt will ich auch nochmal zusätzlich hier gewöhnen haben?
Ach, nichts ist unmöglich, aber ich halte das vielleicht sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil da hätte er wahrscheinlich schon längst schreien müssen.
Mit dem Knie. Mit HM5 könnte man sich so einen Wolfenstein 3D machen hier. Ich kann gerade durch so ein Labyrinth laufen und der rennt das hier so rum.
Das ist einfach per Canvas.
Das ist diese O3D-Geschichte. Nein, nein, du verwechselst es auf die YouTube-Seite.
Canvas-Gap steht da unten.
Da ist noch was anderes.
Das wird einfach...
Wie auch immer. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Kenne ich jetzt nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist HTML5 kommt. Es zeigt sich schon, dass Flash ein Auslaufmodell ist. Wird zwar noch eine Weile dauern, es wird auch noch eine ganze Weile benutzt werden, aber auf dem iPhone werden wir auch HTML5-Video sehen.
Ja.
Wobei, so sicher...
Adobe ist ja auch nicht doof.
Die kämpfen ja schon im Augenblick dafür, dass Flash auf jedes Gerät nach Möglichkeit kommt.
Das hat schon seinen Grund.
Die haben ja gerade... Sie wollen es noch verbreiten, falls es nicht überall ist. Nein, wieso soll es? Zum Beispiel, was ja, ob es uns gefällt oder nicht, was natürlich noch eine extrem wichtige Sache ist für die entsprechenden Anbieter, die Rechteinhaber, wie sie immer so schön heißen, dass das Ganze nach Möglichkeit auch ein bisschen DRM-Schutz hat. Das behauptet Flash ja im Augenblick noch von sich, dass es geschützt sei. Und sie sind gerade dabei, dafür zu sorgen.
Was, was, was?
Na, wenn du so einen Film hast auf YouTube, dann kann ich den mir einfach runterladen. Und wenn er im HTML5 ist, dann ist es noch einfacher, den runterzuladen. Für Flash gibt es aber eine Lösung, mit der ich Daten daran hindern kann, zumindest so einfach runtergeladen zu werden. Und die haben so einen Streaming-Server, und der hat so ein Mindestmaß an Verschlüsselung. Die ist relativ einfach, es gibt es.
Also bei Click to Flash, da klick ich drauf und dann kommt es immer als QuickTime und dann ist Ruhe.
Ja, aber das ist nicht die einzige Möglichkeit, wie Flash Film abspielen kann. Es gibt auch echte Live-Streaming-Lösungen. Du kannst auch einen Flash-Streaming-Server dahinter stellen. Und der über kurz oder lang, wie gesagt, im Augenblick ist es ein relativ lahmes DRM, was leicht zu hacken ist, sind sogar am Streiten, ob es überhaupt ein DRM ist. Aber über kurz oder lang wird er nur mit zertifizierten Clients kommunizieren.
Ja, das kann ja sein, dass HTML5 nicht alles kann, was Flash kann. Das ist bestimmt so, aber Flash ist trotzdem ein bisschen komisch.
Das mag ja ein bisschen komisch sein, aber das wird ein wichtiges Argument für viele sein.
Das ist so ein Browser im Browser irgendwie.
Wir benutzen das.
Na zum Beispiel hier in Amerika, also wenn ich zum Beispiel die Daily Show mir angucke im Netz, dann, ach so, dieses Verschüssungsformat? Dann mach mal die Daily Show auf, zum Beispiel.
Das ist e-Streaming.
Da geht überhaupt nichts runter.
Den Streit hatten wir schon mal.
Ja, aber der wird verschlüsselt.
Der wird notdürftig verschlüsselt. Und damit, und da kann HTM L5 im Augenblick nicht mithalten.
Das soll unhackbar sein oder was?
Es ist gehackt.
Es ist gehackt. Aber sie werden halt hinterher sein, dass es...
Ich sehe da keinen nennenswerten Markt, der jetzt irgendwie dazu führt, dass das irgendwie aufs iPhone kommt oder so und was nicht aufs iPhone kommt, das wird sich eh interessieren.
Naja, aber es wird auf... Sie sind gerade dabei, dass es auf Netbooks vernünftig schnell endlich mal läuft, dass auch da HD-Filme laufen können. Das heißt, sie wollen auch auf Embedded-Plattform runter, das ist auf deinem Fernseher, dass du da Flash drauf laufen hast.
Ja, aber wovon reden wir? Reden wir von Video oder reden wir von Flash? Flash braucht keiner. Und Video ist eh 264, auch bei Flash. Und von daher hat da Adobe eigentlich gar nicht mehr so sehr viel zum Leben.
Na, wie gesagt, das ist nicht in jedem Fall. Sie haben auch einen Streaming-Server, mit dem sie auch streamen können. Und dann mag es als Format innen drinne halt 264 sein, aber du hast noch ein Transporter-Format außen drum.
Das hast du aber auch ohne Flash.
Mit dem es gestreamt wird und damit kannst du es schützen gegen einfaches Runterkopieren. Und ich finde, das ist schon ein gewichtiges Argument. Und dann muss man auch sagen, ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass Flash, wenn man in Flash entwickelt und man weiß, man hat einen Flash Player 10 überall, dann sieht das auch in jedem Flash Player 10 genauso aus.
Ruckelt auch überall genauso.
Ruckelt auch überall genauso. Ich meine, man hat die gleiche Verfügbarkeit. Ich bin kein großer Freund von Flash, aber das ist auch seine Vorteile gegenüber von HTML. Da sollte man trotzdem, deswegen trotzdem nicht kleinreden.
Naja, also ich finde es hat dermaßen viele Nachteile gegenüber einer standardbasierten Lösung. Das ist halt einfach wie auch immer. Wir werden jetzt sehen, neue Web-Apps werden ausgerollt werden auf Basis von HTML5. Und wenn das auch nicht alle machen, auf jeden Fall macht das erstmal Google. Das ist jetzt ganz offensichtlich nach dieser Web-Ankündigung. Und ich denke, Apple ist da auch relativ weit. Naja.
So, vielleicht fällt mir noch was ein. Da war letztens auf Slashdot ein Artikel, wo sie berichtet haben, dass so ein Programmierer bei Flash dafür zuständig ist, den Flashplayer für Linux zu schreiben. Und die wollen halt auch irgendwie Audio haben. Und dann hat er ein bisschen rumgelästert, dass es unter Linux 1000 verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt, um irgendwie Audio zu machen. Zumal gibt es jetzt OSS und dann gibt es ALSA. Und ALSA kann OSS und OSS kann ALSA, weil die alle miteinander kompatibel sein sollen und so Emulation-Layers anbieten. Und dann ging es in den Kommentaren ab. Ich bin ein bisschen reingeklickt. Und in den Kommentaren haben sie mir gleich vorgeschlagen, naja, du könntest doch auch G-Streamer benutzen. Und der nächste meinte, nee, wieso? Aber du kannst doch Folgendes benutzen, das ist doch viel besser für deinen Fall. Und dann haben sie noch mehr aufgelistet, obwohl der meinte, es gibt eigentlich zu viele, haben sie ihm gleich noch mehr vorgeschlagen, die noch besser wären für seine Anwendung. Und da kann man mal sehen, was das Dilemma unter Linux ist. Also auch GUI-mäßig hat sich auch irgendwie beschwert, dass es kein einheitliches Human Interface, also so ein Design Guide, wie heißt das?
Jemand Interfest Design Guide. Jemand Interfest Guidelines, das ist ja mal.
Whatever. Jedenfalls gibt es irgendwie alles gar nicht da und das ist alles so zusammengeschustet und macht irgendwie nicht so richtig Spaß.
Ja.
KDE, gerade von GUI sollst du dich mal flaschen, wenn du mir nicht weit aus dem Fenster lehnungst und was es da alles gibt.
Das war schon immer ein einziges Durcheinander. Da gibt es nicht den Mut zu richtigen Frameworks. Aber vielleicht kriegen wir ja bald mal ein Framework, was wir sehen. Den Namen verdient. Wie hier? Na, wir hier, wir sind doch hier der Apple Podcast. Also dann können wir ja bei dem Thema auch bleiben. Worldwide Developers Konferenz, wollen wir mal so ein bisschen ausblicken, ist nächste Woche. Wir werden hier in einer Woche sitzen und dann ist die Keynote gelaufen.
Eine weitere Fillnote. Die ersten Ankündigungen kommen ja schon, das ist ja vor kurzem. Also für Developer gibt es das ja schon länger. Und jetzt gibt es auch für alle, ist vorgestern rausgekommen glaube ich, ist iTunes 8.2. Da ist ja schon der Support für das iPhone OS 3.0 drin.
Also ich behaupte mal, dass wir nächste Woche werden wir alles schon mit iPhone OS 3.0 hier rum spielen.
Das glaube ich nicht, das Problem war, dass einfach die ganzen Developer gekotzt haben, weil sie irgendwie die ganze Zeit schon dieses 8.2 gebraucht haben, was nur irgendwie Beta-Versionen da war. Und es war einfach der große Hesse und sie mussten das jetzt einfach mal raushauen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Das hat man installiert und es lief und es war schick. Und für mich gab es jetzt auch keine neue Version. Also das letzte Developer-Ding war wohl das gleiche wie das, was die Normalsterblichen jetzt auch runterladen durften.
Ja, na gut.
Also ich glaube, das war nicht der Grund. Ich glaube, die wollen jetzt schon ausrollen, damit halt demnächst die User, wenn es 3.0 dann kommt, alle schon ihr iTunes bis dahin haben. Und das ist halt eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit. Ich glaube, was die vermeiden wollen, ist, dass so ein User, wenn ein iPhone 3.0 kommt, dass er dann auch zusätzlich erstmal noch iTunes installieren muss. Sondern die wollen das schon ein bisschen vorher ausrollen und haben es die meisten schon.
Eine Woche ist nicht so viel.
Der Rechner sagt ja mal Bescheid so.
Meint er nicht ernsthaft, dass wir nächste Woche schon irgendwie das iPhone 3.0 irgendwie...
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Es gab lange keine Betas mehr.
Das stimmt allerdings. Am Letzten kam am 9.5.
oder was?
Also ich glaube, dass das erst rauskommt, wenn das neue iPhone rauskommt.
Nein, das haben sie beim letzten Mal gemacht. Das ging ein bisschen in die Hose. Was ging in die Hose? Naja, ich meine, das war doch der Start vom iPhone 2.0 und der Software und dem iPhone 3G. Und Mobile Mi war ja nun alles andere als entspannt.
Na gut, dann lassen sie halt das Mobile Mi diesmal weg, was auch immer es sein mag. Aber ich kann dir sagen, warum sie nicht das iPhone 3.0 vorher raushauen werden. Weil dann irgendwie alle zwei Wochen, drei Wochen lang davon berichten werden, wie toll das alte iPhone jetzt ist und es hat all die Features und sie werden wochenlang darüber berichten.
Auch schon auf dem Grund eher andersrum.
Und sie stehlen ihrem neuen Gerät komplett die Show. Sie werden es anders machen, sie werden das neue Telefon rausbringen und sie werden es so spinnen, dass alle nur darüber berichten, was das neue Telefon für tolle Features hat, die zu 80 Prozent alle schon irgendwie bekannt sind, mehr oder weniger, weil angekündigt. Aber das ist halt dann der Consumer Roundup und nicht der Developer Roundup. Viele Leute werden gar nicht begreifen, dass auch die alten Telefone einen Großteil dieser Features haben werden. Natürlich wird das alles nochmal überstrahlt werden von den zusätzlichen Features, die eben wirklich nur das neue iPhone hat. Als da wären schnell, Video, tollere Kamera, Video schneiden, Video hochladen. Na das kriegen ja auch die anderen, aber was denn sozusagen? Die Unique Features, mehr Rahmen, mehr Platz, größere Flashrahmen, ne?
Wollen wir mal gucken, was wir das neue so haben wird, vermutlich? Mal in die Glasgow gucken. Ich hab hier so ein schönes Bild vom TRG-Blog. Gibt's so ein Bild, wo alle Gerüchte, die im Moment im Umsatz, im Umlauf sind, eingebaut sind auf einem iPhone-Bild.
Lies mal schnell vor, aber schnell durchgegangen. Wir sagen immer, glaube ich oder glaube ich nicht?
Genau, die haben ja noch die Very Likely, Somewhat Likely und Unlikely.
Dann mach erst mal die Very Likely.
Mach mal erst mal die Very Likely, also die Grünen. Ability to send recorded videos, also das man... Klar, das wird mit MMS schon allein gehen. Nike Plus Support.
Also es wird aber auch Upload sein zu YouTube und Upload zu Mobamex.
Upload zu YouTube wird auf jeden Fall drin sein. Es sind ja schon die entsprechenden Dialoge gesehen worden, wo man sich einloggen kann und warum sollte man sich bei YouTube einloggen, wenn nicht um Videos zu gucken. Improved battery life and percentage battery indicator.
Achso, da ist oben im Display die Prozentzahl steht. Das kann natürlich sein, das ist ja nur ein Software-Change. Improved battery, wäre ich mir gar nicht mal so unbedingt sicher. Wenn das Ding ein bisschen schneller ist oder mehr rammert, brauchst du auch ein bisschen mehr Power. Ich denke mal, das ist gleich.
Ich sag 50% mehr battery life. Echt?
Sehr mutig.
Und auch auf einem alten Telefon wird man wahrscheinlich einen kleinen Vorteil haben. Ich mach das mal gegen die Uhrzeit gesehen. Digitaler Kompass und Applikation.
Very, very likely.
Die haben ja schon den Chip gelistet, der das macht.
Man hat ja sogar schon Screenshots gesehen, Fotos.
Von dem Bild mit dem Kompass, ja. Und es ist ganz klar, welchen Chip sie benutzen.
32 GB Speicher.
Ja, das ist das Topmodell dann wahrscheinlich.
Da hat man ja was gesehen, dass es...
Und es wird keine 4 GB Version geben.
Ich glaube auch nicht an eine 4 GB Version. Also da gab es irgendwelche Screenshots, von irgendeinem kanadischen Anbieter, wo sie jetzt schon seit Jahren 8 GB haben. Na ja, also ich kann es mir insofern vorstellen, dass sie wollen vielleicht auch ein bisschen... Es werden billige Android-Telefone kommen, und es werden so nach unten hin wollen sie...
Nee.
Gibt es ja eine Grenze.
Und es ist doch für Apple überhaupt keine Grenze.
Ich hab einen... Sie brauchen einen Marktanteil.
Ich halte voll richtig die Zahl.
Ist egal, mach einfach weiter.
Setz irgendwas und ich biete das doch bitte.
Ich will es nicht komplett ausschließen.
Improved RAM and Performance. Ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher.
Da bin ich mir absolut... also das ist der iPod...
Voll sicher, sie werden auf jeden Fall auf die neue ARM Cortex-Generation gehen.
Also der iPod Touch der zweiten Generation hat ja schon einen etwas schnelleren Prozessor als das iPhone 3G.
Das ist schneller getaktet, das ist der gleiche Prozessor.
Wenn sogar der Palm Pre schon eine Generation weiter ist. Du willst mir noch nicht erzählen, dass Apple nicht auf die letzte verfügbare, greifbare... Von Samsung gibt es den Stein in einer neuen Generation und den bauen die da einfach ein. Der hat 50% mehr Takt und das Ding wummt. Und wenn sie da noch ein bisschen schnelleres RAM reinbauen, würde mich das auch überhaupt nicht wundern.
199 und 299 Dollar.
Ja, in was auch immer sich das dann hier in Deutschland wieder versetzt.
Das ist eine neue Ansage.
17. Juli, wie gesagt, 18.6. behaupte ich.
Ich glaube, das wird's werden.
Juli.
Juli? Also, ein Hinweis ab 15.6. hat die Telekom Urlaubstopp.
Ja, hat sie letztes Jahr auch und war trotzdem erst drei Wochen später rausgekommen, das Telefon.
Verbesserte Kamera, mindestens 3,2 Megapixel.
150 Prozent.
Wird endlich fertig und damit wird auch Videoaufnahme und Videoschnitt.
Hat wohl beim ersten Punkt eigentlich schon.
Naja, stimmt, das sind die aufgezeichneten, aber dass man auch so ein bisschen editieren kann, wird auch auf jeden Fall kommen.
Das war jetzt very likely. Aber das sind schon auch alles Feature, wo wir immer Ja, Ja sagen, weil wir es natürlich auch gerne hätten. Ob das dann wirklich alles immer kommt, ist nur eine Frage.
Ich glaube an alles. Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Naja, da bin ich einfach voll in voller Erwartung. Wenn da irgendwas von nicht kommt, dann bin ich echt überrascht.
So, somewhat likely. 3G, Enhanced 3G und China Network Support, also dass es drei verschiedene Varianten geben wird.
Dieser neuere Chip von Infineon da, der...
Ja, sie machen da einfach 7,2 Megabit RSTPA Downloads.
Kann sein, ist halt der neuere Chip drin.
Also dass es sozusagen unterschiedliche Geräte für unterschiedliche Länder geben wird?
Das ist so ein Gerücht, da bin ich mir nun nicht so sicher, weil das Gerücht hat ja im Prinzip gesagt, es gibt ein normales, also quasi wie bisher, UMTS, dann noch mit irgendwie besserem Chip und dann noch ein Mainland China.
Genau.
Das ist ja die Variante, die hier drinsteht. Also dass es drei verschiedene iPhone-Varianten mit unterschiedlichen Chips gibt, aber man im jeweiligen Land immer nur sein iPhone kaufen kann, was die Sachen unterstützt.
Also was ich wirklich Zweifel habe, ist, dass sie zwei verschiedene UMTS-Varianten machen mal. Da würde ich mich wirklich wundern, was sie dazu zwingen soll. Diese Sache mit Mainland China, was dahinter steckt, ist ja im Prinzip, da haben wir auch schon mal drüber geredet, dass China Telecom, also das deutsche Telecom von China, keinen UMTS benutzt. Das heißt, dieses Gerücht zielt im Prinzip darauf ab, dass sie halt mit China Telecom gehen. Und ich rechne ehrlich gesagt nach wie vor damit, dass sie mit, wie heißt die andere Bude, Unicom, China Unicom, die viel kleiner sind, aber die halt ein UMTS-Netz haben. Sie machen jetzt schon so lange aggressiven Verkauf von, also Direktverkauf von Unlocked Phones in Hongkong. Ja, das machen sie schon so lange. Und es ist, also klar, der chinesische Markt, der mag ja groß sein, aber für Apple gibt es eigentlich nur einen Markt und das ist der World Wide Markt. Und ich glaube, dass sie, wenn, ich habe ja keine Ahnung, wie gut dieses Netz ist von China Unicom. Und es mag ja sein, dass sie nicht so viele Subscriber haben wie China Telecom, aber wir wissen auch, wenn man sich mal die Geschäftszahlen von AT&T anschaut, was ist der große Bonus von Apple? Der große Bonus von Apple ist der, wenn die mit einem Provider gehen, dann werden die Leute den Provider wechseln, damit sie das iPhone kriegen. Und das ist das, wo Apple seine guten Konditionen rausholt. Während sie von China Telecom, mit China Telecom eigentlich wenig davon haben. Erstmal der Stress, dass sie ein anderes Gerät bauen müssten. Und dann das Problem, dass sie schon so viele Subscriber haben, dass die einfach gar nicht viel weitere Subscriber dazu gewinnen können. Von daher wäre der kleinere Provider, so er denn eine ordentliche Netzdeckung und ein ordentliches Datennetz und korrekte Tarife anbietet, eigentlich viel interessanter. Weil die natürlich ein Megainteresse daran haben, China Telecom Milliarden von Kunden abzunehmen.
Also was definitiv einer großen Vorteile...
Also mit anderen Worten, ich bezweifle dieses Gerücht. Ich glaube, es wird ein iPhone sein und es wird nach wie vor UMTS sein. Und es wird einfach die Schnelle-HS-DPR machen.
Auf jeden Fall werden wir es vermutlich nicht auf der WWDC erfahren, weil so eine Details werden sie wahrscheinlich eher nicht erwähnen. So, auf jeden Fall würde ich auch sagen, einer der großen Vorteile für Apple beim iPhone ist, sie können ein und dasselbe Gerät weltweit verkloppen. Eigentlich ist der einzige Unterschied, den sie dazu packen, ist sozusagen dieser kleine Stromadapter, den sie immer noch reinlegen müssen in die einzelne Box.
Und selbst das ist ja schon ein Modul von dem eigentlichen Netzteil.
Genau, das haben alle anderen nicht. Die müssen bei ihren Tastaturen dann immer anpassen und so.
Allein, wenn die jetzt noch ein anderes Netz-Kram machen, dann müssen sie sich diesen ganzen Scheiß auch noch an die Backe binden. Ja, komplett anderes Netz, was irgendwie auch echt keine Zukunft hat.
Wobei es sind unglaublich viele Leute, die es nutzen. Das ist, also ich meine, das ist...
Na, who cares?
Es ist ein großer Markt, der nicht zu vernachlässigen ist.
Ja, ein großer Markt von Kunden, die halt schon bei dem richtigen Provider sind. Also, ich fass nicht.
So, relocated speaker, also dass der Lautsprecher so ein bisschen...
Aber okay, das ist das Bild von einem alten Telefon.
Das ist die Vorderseite des alten Telefons. Es gab ja dieses Bild von dem... Da hat doch irgendjemand...
Welcher Speaker? Der mir ins Ohr...
Genau, den du hier oben hältst und zwar...
Dass der weiter oben ist.
Dass der weit... Also es gibt ja dieses...
Dass der weiter oben ist, dass das Telefon dadurch weiter runter kann. Na ja, kann man noch so ein bisschen optimieren, stimmt schon, aber...
Na wir haben ja... Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich gelesen, dieses Ding, wo dann irgendjemand geschrieben hat, an einen chinesischen Hersteller von iPhone-Teilen, weil er irgendeinen Ersatzteil haben wollte und das dann direkt gerne aus China zugeschickt haben wollte. Und er wollte dann fürs iPhone 3G einen Ersatzteil haben. Und die haben dann... Wahrscheinlich haben sie ihn einfach falsch verstanden. Ja, wir haben für das neue iPhone der dritten Generation Ersatzteile und haben ihm Fotos geschickt von diesen Ersatzteilen, die sie ihm jetzt schon liefern würden gerne. Auf dem Bild war dieser Chromrahmen sozusagen so ein bisschen von hinten zu sehen. Und da war oben auf der Oberseite eine kleine Einbuchtung zu sehen, die ungefähr die Breite von diesem Lautsprecherteil hat.
Also was da so eine chinesische kleine Zubehörstinkeprude da mit dem iPhone zu tun haben soll, ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein Witz.
Dass diese kleine, stinke Bude im Augenblick schon diesen Rahmen für das alte iPhone baut.
Ich glaube, nachdem sie diese Sachen gemacht haben, bauen die den schon nicht mehr. Vermutlich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich lebt der CEO gar nicht mehr. Der treibt schon irgendwie in so einem vergifteten chemischen Fluss.
Auf jeden Fall müssen die Dinge bereits jetzt produziert werden.
Glaube ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, wo das Loch ist.
Das ist eine coole User-Idee, weil die Idee ist ja nicht schlecht, das bisschen höher zu machen, weil dadurch das Telefon insgesamt wieder ein bisschen mehr in Richtung Mund wandern kann. Aber ich glaube, das ist halt eine User-Idee und nicht umgesetzt von Apple Films. Die nächsten Generationen, weil sie es aufschlafen.
Was sie jetzt somewhat likely halten, ist Recorded Video Uploading to YouTube.
Ja, ist ja eine Songgeschichte, was immer kommt.
100 pro.
Wi-Fi-Movie-TV-Downloads.
Da gibt's doch schon, oder? Haben die schon erlaubt, jetzt?
Nee, gab's aber diesen, wo einer versehentlich in einem Tweetie oder in Twitterfunk auf den Banger geklickt hat.
Es gab da irgendwelche Screenshots oder irgendwelche Store-Geschichten. Ja, klar, ich meine, sie machen sowieso bei der Bandbreite auf. Podcast-Download-Beschränkungen gibt's auch nicht mehr. Irgendwie scheinen sie sich da jetzt ausreichend geeinigt zu haben. Und jetzt hauen sie irgendwie raus.
Na, und über Wi-Fi geht's ja sowieso.
Ja, über Wi-Fi ist eh kein Thema, da sehe ich auch wenig Gründe. Und ich denke, ihre ganze Strategie, denke ich, also das glaube ich auch etwas, was ich vermute, was sie an der WWDC oder später ankündigen, also mit dem iPhone ankündigen, sie werden diverse Maßnahmen ergreifen, um das iPhone von iTunes zu entkoppeln. Um einfach in Märkte zu gehen, wo du nicht davon ausgehen kannst, dass die Leute einen Computer haben.
Na, das geht ja jetzt schon los, dass man mit iPhone 3.0, mit der Software, wenn man die installiert, kann man ja auch einen iTunes-Account anlegen.
Genau, aber es kommt ja noch mehr dazu. Es ist ja auch das ganze Syncing, Mobile Me und so weiter. Im Prinzip alles, was dein iTunes derzeit auf das Telefon spielt, wird in zunehmendem Maße auch das iPhone sich aus einer Wolke holen können.
Heißt das etwa, dass mein iPhone in der Lage sein wird, eines Tages Podcasts auch nachts über Wi-Fi runterzuladen, ohne Oversea Air Syncing zu machen? Sollte dieser Traum tatsächlich noch mal in Erfüllung gehen?
Ja, na das ist glaube ich auch eine sichere Sache, dass sie jetzt, also das, also Webdata ist ja drin.
Ok, machen wir weiter.
So, HD Video Support.
Warte mal kurz, äh, warte mal, was wollte ich gerade sagen? Wo waren wir?
Wir waren gerade bei einem Movie Downloads, Podcast Downloads, Oversea Air Sync.
Genau, und diesem, genau, und dieses Ding, dass man sozusagen, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass mit dem neuen iPhone es einfach möglich ist, dass du dir das einfach kaufst und du brauchst keinen Computer mehr. Also, dass du das iPhone in Betrieb nehmen kannst, wie ein normales Telefon, auch ohne es an einem Computer.
War das nicht schon so, dass du dir das im Shop irgendwie gleich registrieren und aktivieren und zack, fertig? Das war doch schon so.
Na, aber dass du das Ding mit in einer geschlossenen Box nach Hause nehmen kannst.
Wo kriegst du dann dein Apple-Account her?
Das machen die dir im Shop.
Na ja, aber das ist ja, also...
Da gab's irgendwas, weil das genau der Grund war, dass die Leute halt eben gleich damit loslegen können und keinen Rechner brauchen. Das hatten die schon. Das war bei dem letzten iPhone schon so. Oder die haben dann auch wieder zur Store's umgestellt.
Nee, aber ich meine, das ist doch ein Unterschied, ob du das Ding originalverpackt aus der Packung holst und dir einen Account einrichten kannst oder ob jemand anders für dich netterweise quasi einen Account einrichtet. Wobei, das war ja tatsächlich wohl so ein Ding. Beim iPhone hab ich mal gehört, ich weiß nicht, wie viel dran ist, dass es auch in Amerika gerne mal durchaus nicht nur von irgendwelchen reichen Technik-Nerds gekauft wird, sondern durchaus auch von ärmeren Bevölkerungsschichten, die sich nämlich keinen Computer leisten wollen oder können. Und dann sagen, naja, das bisschen rumsurfen, was ich so brauche, das kann ich auch mit dem iPhone. Und das kostet 200 Dollar und ich hab einen Vertrag, den ich sowieso brauche. Weil telefonieren will man ja schon mit. Und für diese Bevölkerungsgruppen ist es natürlich auch noch ideal. Oder für diese Leute.
Das glaub ich ja nicht so richtig. Der ist ja schon teurer als ohne Datenzeugs und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, aber du brauchst ja heutzutage einen Computer irgendwo für. Du brauchst doch einen Internetanschluss manchmal.
Ja, aber der so was ist doch, kostet doch nix.
Ein Internetanschluss kostet doch, was kostet sich ein Internetanschluss? 20 Euro im Monat hier in Deutschland? Was kostet sowas in Amerika? Wo die Fläche noch ein bisschen größer ist, ich glaube, da ist das alles noch einen Zacken teurer. Und einen Computer, was kostet ein Computer?
Also in Indien haben sie auf jeden Fall ein Problem, mit dem Computer zu haben. Es gibt einfach Länder, Schwellenländer, da ist es einfach nicht normal, einen Computer zu haben, aber vollkommen normal, ein Telefon zu haben. Und auch wenn das jetzt erst mal nicht so ihr erster Stoßmarkt war bisher, da geht es einfach hin. Und ich denke, sie werden das jetzt verbessern. Und dieses irgendwie mehrere Accounts haben, und irgendwie erstellen können und so weiter. Das sind alles so Schritte in diese Richtung.
Aber es gibt auch in Europa und in Amerika Bevölkerungsschichten, die kein Computer haben, aber sich trotzdem ein iPhone kaufen wollen. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Und die wollen sie auch mitnehmen. Gut.
Das digitale Prekariat.
Sozusagen.
HD-Videosupport. Hat irgendjemand von euch schon mal das iPhone an ein Fernseher angeschlossen? Es gibt ja dafür...
Was meinen Sie denn mit HD-Videosupport?
Na, dass du das denkst, dass du......an ein HD-Fernseher anschließen kannst?...
dass du es an ein HD-Fernseher anschließen kannst.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn da wirklich ein neuere Chip drin ist und der wirklich HD-Video abspielen kann...
Dann müssten sie ja das Dock ändern, dann müssten sie da HDMI reinbauen.
Na, geht das nicht auch mit...
Warum solltest du das machen? Also, dieses Feature...
Das ist auch wieder so ein Feature, dass man das Telefon ohne Computer benutzen kann.
Ja, gut, aber das ging ja auch beim iPod schon immer. Aber dass das wirklich jetzt so ein großes Ding war, dass man sein iPod an ein Fernseher anschließen kann, das hab ich nicht gesehen. Das ging zwar und ich fand das cool, aber dass das jetzt wirklich das ist, wo alle schreiend über die Straße gelaufen sind, deswegen hab ich es nicht gesehen.
Guckst du den Film und dann ruft einer an.
Na, es ist jetzt auch nicht, es ist wirklich... Wieso, wenn du einen Film siehst, dann willst du ja sowieso den Film unterbrechen.
Ja, trotzdem musst du noch was rausnehmen und so.
Warte mal, wie ist denn das? Was kommt denn derzeit raus aus dem Dock-Connector? Da kam... Kommt da Y-UV raus?
LS-Video.
Kommt nur LS-Video. Sicher? Nee, es gibt doch jetzt dieses neue Kabel. Jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt. Was meint denn der Chat? Der Chat ist doch immer so klar. Glaubst du nicht auch einen Komponentenkabel? Genau, gibt's. Das ist nämlich Y-UV. Das ist HD. Da kriegst du 27p drüber. Von daher ist das überhaupt keine News. Die Frage ist halt nur, ob du dann ein HD-Video abspielen kannst.
Wenn da ein neuer Stein drin ist, der 50% mehr powert.
Aber warum solltest du auf dein iPhone solche riesigen Files draufballern?
Nein, aber in dem Moment... Irgendwann wird's mal... Also erstens muss man über Y-UV ja nicht zwangsläufig, sondern auflösungsscheuchen.
Nein, aber nur da drüber kannst du sie so scheuchen. Kannst du bei S-Video...
Jaja, klar.
Kannst auch den Aspekt-Ratio nicht einstellen. Y-UV kannst du halt klar rüber kommunizieren. Hier kommt jetzt 16 zu 9.
Nee, aber ich weiß nicht, welche Auflösung kommt da im Augenblick drüber?
Das ist analog. Da kommt gar keine Auflösung rüber.
S-Video.
Du packst doch irgendwas...
S-Video-Parl hast du schon fertig definiert.
Nein, langsam. Das sind alles ganz andere Sachen. Also, S-Video ist halt die Verbesserung von Video.
Ja, und das ist jetzt als PAL oder als NTSC? Stellst du noch einen im iPhone?
Ja, aber Y-Zone UV ist halt einfach eine andere Komponente.
Ist schon klar, ist was ganz anderes, ja.
Wie auch immer, es ist alles analog und aus welcher Auflösung das zusammengerechnet wird, ist dem Fernseher schmutzpiepegal, weil da gehen keine Pixel rüber, sondern es ist analog.
Na gut, aber du kannst ein höher qualitativ höherwertiges Analogsignal schicken.
Genau, aber aus welcher Pixelmasse sich das ergibt, ob du da einen Full HD oder einen 27p nimmst, das spielt keine Rolle. Das ist eine andere Frage. Wenn dieses Gerücht stimmt, kann HD abspielen? Dann soll das ja heißen HD-Movie-Formate. Das kann halt nur sein 27p oder halt 1080p. Was halt riesige Files sind, was auf so einem iPhone überhaupt keinen Sinn macht, das da drauf zu simmen?
Na ja, erstens mit 32 GB wird es schon mal interessanter, zum zweiten irgendwann ist halt immer die Frage, wieso kann es eigentlich nicht HD?
Ja, aber wozu?
Zum Fotos angucken, wenn du einen kurzen Clip hast.
Du hast doch hier nur 320 x 480.
Zum an den Fernseher anschließen.
Ja, aber ist das wirklich der Markt?
Nee, aber das kann das halt. Der kann halt jetzt dickere...
Also sagen wir, der Grafikstein wäre in der Lage, die Dinge abzuspielen, die CPU auch.
Und kann sie zum Fernseher rausschicken und dann kannst du zumindest schon mal gucken und kannst die Filme, die du so kaufst und auf dem Apple-TV kuckst, auch mit deinem iPhone gucken.
Okay, ist kein tolles Feature, aber vielleicht ist es dran.
Gut, nächstes könnte eher ein tolles Feature sein. Hoffe ich ein bisschen drauf. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es ausgesprochen wird. Matte, Made, Rubber-Backing. Also das ist das...
Nicht mehr eine glänzende Rückseite, sondern so eine angeraute Rückseite. Bin ich mir nicht so sicher, würde ich aber cool finden, weil dieses glatte Plastik finde ich aber ein bisschen komisch.
Ich würde es auch ein bisschen... Das ist so rissig, das sieht man bei dem Schwarzen, sieht man es nicht so, aber bei dem Weißen ist es auffällig, das reißt ein ohne Ende. Diese Plastik-Rückseite ist...
Wenn es nicht so glitschig in der Hand liegt, ist doch was geworden.
Die Rückseite ist echt scheiße.
Die Fotos, die ich gesehen habe, sahen ehrlich gesagt extrem glaubwürdig aus.
Naja, aber es kann auch sein, dass sich irgendjemand selber eine Rückseite gebastelt hat und die auf sein altes iPhone 3G draufgepappt hat.
Sah für mich nicht so aus, aber ich sag, wird stattfinden.
Ich hab meinen Mann gesehen, der sich für sein Netbook ein eigenes Gehäuse aus... aus was? Aus Carbon oder sowas? Absurd. Und dann haben wir noch ein somewhat likely und zwar Limited Background Up-Support.
Glaub ich nicht.
Won't happen.
Kommt erst in 3.1.
Ja doch. Ist keine Eigenschaft des neuen Telefons.
Ich glaube, es kommt sozusagen als hinterhergeschoben. Nicht in der 3.0, aber auch nicht in der 4.0, sondern dazwischen. 3.1 oder 3.5, wie auch immer die es nennen.
Ja, erstmal wollen sie jetzt wahrscheinlich, also mit 3.0 wird es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen, weil sie erstmal alle darauf scheuchen, sie wollen noch diese Notification-Dienste zu nutzen. Und dann kriegt man erstmal mit, Moment mal, damit kann man doch schon ein bisschen was reißen. Und dann wird es erst losgehen, dass dann einige Programme noch zusätzlicher Berechtigung bekommen für Weisenthorpe.
Das heißt jetzt schon alles? Nee, jetzt kommen noch die unlikely.
Jetzt kommen noch die unlikely Sachen. Front-facing-Kamera mit einem zusätzlichen Sensor, also dass eine Kamera an die Vorderseite rauskommt.
Zu teuer.
Zu teuer?
Klar.
Kostet halt zwei, drei Dollar.
Jedes fucking UMTS-Telefon seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, außer dem iPhone, hat zwei Kameras drinne.
Alles, was du einbaust, kostet Geld.
Es kostet ein bisschen Geld.
Die haben immer ganz viele in ihren Telefon, aber glaubt es keiner.
Ja, aber die haben auch nicht die Margen, die Apple hat. Apple verdient richtig viel Geld mit ihrem Scheiß.
Ja, dann können sie auch mal als 20 Cent für eine zweite Kamera reinpappen.
Also ich sag nicht, dass es kommen wird, also Front-facing-Kamera, das ist im Prinzip dieses, sag mal, diese iChat-Gerücht, ne?
Genau.
Darum geht's ja. Und ehrlich gesagt, dieses Bildtelefonieren, warum so ein Mobiltelefon, was soll das?
Also ich, also ich halt auch, Videotelefonie, das ist jetzt schon so oft zur großen nächsten Sache erklärt worden und es ist nie gewesen, glaube ich auch nicht. Wozu auch?
Da haben wir nicht.
Aber MMS ist auch drinne, obwohl man es nicht braucht.
Doch, Bilder verschicken ist manchmal okay, weil die hatten halt keinen E-Mail auf ihrem Telefon, da ging es ja noch mal nicht anders. Das kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen.
Aber MMS auf ein iPhone wird auch kommen. Obwohl es keiner braucht.
So Leute schickst du, die kein iPhone haben, was weiß ich, aber so mit Bild sehe ich nicht so.
Also ich finde es manchmal ganz nervig. Zwei, dreimal hatte ich den Fall, dass ich mit dem iPhone gerne, dass jemand anders mit meinem Videotelefon machen wollte und das ging dann halt nicht.
Ja, aber Porn-Hotline kannst du auch anders kriegen. Es ging darum, dass...
Okay. Das erklärt auch die besser abwischbare Rückseite.
Aber da will ich doch nur diese, die muss... Aber das Gegenteil ist doch nicht besser abwischbar, sondern schlechter. Diese Sendung ist erst auf 18.
Im App Store würden wir damit nicht reinkommen.
Naja, es gibt jetzt Parental Controls. Vielleicht gibt es sie ja auch bald für Podcasts.
Black Metallic Lining.
Also es hat so einen silbernen Metallring, so einen schwarzen, glaube ich, auch nicht. Übrigens gibt es ja ganz viele Leute, die sagen, dass das alte schicker ist als das neue iPhone.
Ja klar, unter anderem ich zum Beispiel.
Ich finde das neue besser.
Echt?
Ja, immer besser.
Vom Schönheitsfaktor her fände ich schon.
Immer hört sich an, wie seit dem Krieg. Das gibt es erst seit einem Jahr.
Das heißt Headphone Jack, sag ich nur.
Da gibt es Adapter für. Ja, aber ich finde die Alu-Rückseite echt schicker.
Egal, es geht ums neue Phone.
OLED-Screen? Du wüsst jetzt gar nicht, warum das so extrem unwahrscheinlich sein sollte.
Naja, weil...
Kostet halt auch Geld.
Ja, keine Ahnung, weil es unklar ist, wie du das halt verfügbar hast, wie gut die wirklich aussehen.
Was ist denn an denen jetzt so viel besser als an den normalen Stromspanern?
Wir sind Hänner und Stromspaner.
Was könnte... also ich halte das durchaus für vorstellbar, hab aber eigentlich keine Ahnung von diesem Markt, sodass ich einschätzen könnte, wie es da jetzt... also jemand, der da Plan hat, weiß wahrscheinlich eh schon, wie es kommen wird. So nach dem Motto ja, bestellt eh keiner was anderes mehr oder das hat noch nie funktioniert.
Zum Thema OLED nur mal ganz kurz zwischendurch eingeschoben, habe ich bei Heise neulich einen Artikel gelesen, ich weiß nicht mehr, welcher Hersteller es war, hat es jetzt geschafft, die können OLED-Displays per Tinten-Strahldrucker drucken. Das wird, wenn das in die Massenproduktion geht, dann werden wir Bildschirme überall haben.
Ja, das müssen wir mal sehen. Also OLED hör ich jetzt auch schon seit 6, 7 Jahren.
Nee, bisher konnte das Zeug nur im Reihenraum entwickelt werden und alles furchtbar kompliziert und hohe Ausschussraten, aber in dem Moment, in dem du das aus dem Tinten-Strahldrucker rausklopst.
Du kannst ja noch einen Tinten-Strahldrucker in dieses Telefon einbauen, das wäre auch mal gut.
Bild-NFN-Transmitter wird auf keinen Fall kommen.
Transmitter? Also nicht ein Radio, sondern halt mein Transmitter fürs Auto, glaube ich nicht. Kriegen sie weltweit, haben sie Schwierigkeiten mit der Zulassung.
Wenn ich das Gerücht richtig interpretiert habe, ist das eine Eigenschaft des Steins. Also der Stein, der halt, genau, das ist dieser...
Infineon.
Nein, nicht das Bassband. Also nicht...
Doch, das war doch irgendwie, das war so ein Chip, der WLAN, UMTS und dieses Radiozeug macht. Aber war das nicht Receiving?
Tja, so viel zu gut vorbereitet sein. Ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht, aber wir können einfach mal beides durchspielen. Transmitter würde halt insofern sinnvoll sein, als dass sie für Autos ohne Adapter-Möglichkeit sozusagen eine Wireless-Lösung hätten.
Na ja, jeder der mal probiert hat.
Navigationssoftware, sie bauen jetzt Navi ein. Da ist das durchaus eine Sache, so was zu koppeln.
Also jeder der mal probiert hat, in einem halbwegs modernen Auto so einen FM-Transmitter tatsächlich zu benutzen und festgestellt hat, das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Weil es jetzt auch gar keine Radios mehr gibt, die Antennenempfang haben, weil gibt's überhaupt noch Radio per Antenne. Ja doch, gibt's noch Fernsehen, ist abgeschnitten.
Alle Autos haben Radio mit Antennenempfang.
Jedes Kabelanschluss ist da noch nicht erfunden. Es gibt ja auch schon per DVB-T Radio und all sowas. Das wird doch, also analog als Fernseher wird da auch irgendwann eingestellt oder nicht?
FM wird ewig bleiben noch.
Ich glaub auch, dass das Glock hier dann auch nicht klingelt.
Also da hast du schon die übernächste iPhone-Generation, bevor das kommt. Aber es ist einfach so, ich hab mal so einen FM-Transmitter fürs iPhone gehabt, den man so unten aufstecken konnte von Griffin. Und es gibt einfach nur unglaublich wenige Autos, wo du tatsächlich einen vernünftigen Empfang darüber hast. Weil du sitzt vorne oder sitzt auf dem Fahrersitz mit deinem iPhone, stellst den Sender ein für die Musik und wo ist die Antenne? Die ist hinten irgendwo auf dem Dach. Die ist ja nicht mehr so, wie sie früher war, neben dem Außenspiegel quasi. Und dann hast du diese modernen Schirmungen da vorne auf der Frontscheibe drauf, die gegen Sonnenlicht...
Du sitzt ja sozusagen in so einem fahrerdeichen Käfig.
Du sitzt im fahrerdeichen Käfig und draußen kommt nichts an. Du musst schon quasi das Telefon aufs Dach legen. Und FM-Receiver?
Das ist auch so eine Kacklösung, die würde Apple nicht machen.
FM-Receiver?
FM-Receiver macht eher Internetradio, Leute.
Das ist eh klar.
Wozu, wozu?
Das ist ja auch eben deswegen bei sehr unlikely.
Ich meine, Sie haben das als Produkt?
Und?
Na, in so einem Kabel halt.
Das ist so Remote-Things.
Ja.
Funktioniert ja auch am iPhone nicht mehr, das Kabel.
Ja, vielleicht bauen Sie es halt ein, weil Sie einfach doch eine gewisse Nachfrage sehen, dass für Leute das schon auch ein Argument ist. Und dann bauen Sie es halt einfach mit ein optional. Also, bin ich mir auch nicht...
Eher eine Frontkamera, als der Chip genutzt wird.
Jetzt machen wir einen nächsten Punkt.
So, der nächste Punkt ist, da sind wir uns jetzt wirklich mal einig, Adobe Flash Support.
Nee, wir sind dazwischen.
Ach so, da sind wir noch, genau. 802.11n Wi-Fi Support.
Jetzt muss man auch wieder den Chip nochmal vor sich haben, ob der das kann oder nicht. Wenn er das kann, machen Sie es. Wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Kommt.
Wird kommen. Und zwar nicht mal sehr wegen der höheren Geschwindigkeit, sondern einfach, um mit den entsprechenden Basisstationen kommunizieren zu können.
Total sicher. Ich hoffe ja, dass jetzt irgendjemand mal mitgeschrieben hat, was wir einzelne Voraussagen gemacht haben.
Wir nehmen es auf, du kannst es nochmal anhören.
Wir hören uns das nicht nochmal an. Adobe Flash Support.
Total unlikely.
Sind wir uns alle einig, das würde ich kaum sagen.
Total super, Null Prozent Chance.
Leuchten das Apple-Logo.
Very unlikely.
Dann aber nur in Gold mit Kettchen dran.
Die Gold-Kettchen-Edition. Das wär doch mal was. Also ein Prekariats-iPhone.
Pimp my iPhone.
Ja, so mit bunten LEDs, die auch noch so aufblinken, wenn es klingelt und so.
Wobei, ich würd's ja schon cool finden, was mir halt immer noch fehlt, ist, während das Ding aus ist. Also ich muss immer klicken, ob ich eine SMS hab, ich muss klicken, ob ich ein Anno verpasst hab und ich muss irgendwie klicken, um zu sehen, ob die Batterie noch hält. Irgendwann so ein Indicator, ohne dass ich das Display einschalten muss, also ohne dass ich das Telefon berühren muss, würde ich schon cool finden.
Ja, so eine kleine LED, eine Taschenlampe.
Na, hatte da nicht mal...
Dann bräuchte man die ganzen Taschenlampen-Applikationen nicht mehr. Dann hätte man einfach mal eine scheiß Taschenlampe in dem Telefon. Ich meine, wie cool wäre das, wenn du in deinem iPhone einfach noch mal eine LED drin hast, die einfach mal amtlich strahlt.
So ein Flashlight, wie es auch andere Telefone haben.
Ja, so ein Flashlight, als im Flashlight.
Genau, auch mit App dann natürlich.
Ich meine, 90 Prozent ist extra Umsatz. Es geht über Flashlight-Applikationen.
Man muss dann erst mal das Flashlight-Tool runterladen, damit man sie einschalten kann, damit sie noch mal Geld verdienen. Ja, so Features nachkaufen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie eine LED einbauen, aber ich würde es auch nicht schade finden, wenn sie es machen.
Ich bin ernsthaft, nicht ernsthaft, ich bin am Überlegen, auch noch ein Flashlight-Programm zu schreiben, einfach nur um die Beschreibung im App-Store eingeben zu können. Licht, Basis jeden Lebens, Grundlage der Welt. Sie können jetzt hier käuflich erwerben.
Licht ist die Basis des Lebens?
Licht, ja klar ist Licht.
Energie für Pflanzen, damit die wachsen können.
Da lebt doch auch was.
Photosynthese ohne Licht?
Es gibt auch Bakterien, die leben in Vulkanen, 20.000 Kilometer unter der See.
Woher hat sein Vulkan seine ganze Energie?
Die brauchen ja trotzdem Wärme, ist am Ende auch nichts anderes als Licht.
Einfach nur um den Text zu schreiben. Sollte auch nur ein kurzer Gags werden.
Wir sind ja alle nicht aus der Wissenschaft.
Wir sind aber übrigens auch durch mit unserer Liste. Gibt es jetzt noch irgendwas, was im iPhone kommt, was da nicht stand? Zum Beispiel so ein Battery-Indicator, so eine LED, die irgendwo blinken kann.
Da gab es ja mal eine hübsche Variante, die ich Apple durchaus zutrauen würde. Und zwar, dass man so ein paar Icons noch hinter das Display legt. Also, dass man wirklich eine LED hinter dem Display macht.
Das gab es noch in Apple-Patent.
Genau. Und die wäre natürlich eine knuffige Kombination aus diesem, das Apple-Logo leuchtet. Sodass da irgendjemand, hey, da hat, ich hab im Werk gesehen, wie da auf der Rückseite eine LED eingebaut worden ist hinter dem Display. Wieso soll hinter dem Display noch eine LED eingebaut? Dass das vielleicht genau diese Technik ist, dass man das darüber sehen kann. Weil, ich hab ja...
Könnte sein, sie haben dieses Patent, kommt halt darauf an, wie lange sie brauchen, bis sie es umsetzen.
Genau, und ob sie es jemals umsetzen.
Aber ich würd's schon cool finden, wenn jetzt hier so noch unter dem Display so was leuchtet und dadurch eigen so maskenlässig...
Genau, aber nicht so eine hässliche LED, die irgendwie so rumblimpert alle paar Sekunden oder so was.
Wie sonst?
Na ja, eben, also ich mein, guck mal, ich hab hier dieses...
Also was einfach nicht blinkt, sondern was einfach anders.
Ja, also nicht, guck mal, nicht so wie das Teil hier.
Ich find das jetzt, okay, ist jetzt nicht so schick.
Schick mal, wie das Teil hier.
Wir sind hier in einem Audio-Podcast.
Der hat hier schon wieder Konkurrenzprodukte. Da müssen wir aber gleich nochmal drüber ablösen.
Hier im Chat wird korrekt darauf hingewiesen, dass man ja vielleicht auch nochmal die iPhone-Features, also Fernbedienung, Lautstärke, Kontrolle über Kabel, denke immer, das ist auch sicher, ne?
Das, was das iPod-Taststelle ist, sagt es ja schon. Also mich ärgert es ja immer noch, dass selbst auch mit der 3.0er Software, ich kann immer noch mein Apple Remote, das mit dem Radio heilt, für ein iPod kann ich immer noch nicht anschließen, dass es nicht supportet. Das find ich ja ein bisschen blöd. Also, Connector unten ist Connector. Wenn sie da schon Standard haben, dann sollten sie auch alles immer unterstützen.
Wisst ihr, was ich ja ganz lustig finde? Ich find ja dieses Remote-Programm auf dem iPhone, das find ich ja mittlerweile richtig schick, mit dem man seinen iTunes und vor allen Dingen jetzt, mit dem ich nachher meinen Apple TV steuern kann. Und ich find's mittlerweile richtig scheiße, dass es fürs iTunes oder für Mac nicht so ne Software gibt, mit der ich meinen Apple TV fernsteuern kann. Vom Mac aus.
Und ich würde gerne mit meinem iPhone die Musik von meinem iTunes hören können. Aber hier drauf halt, dass ich nachts im Bett liege und die Musik von meinem Rechner, der sonst irgendwo steht, irgendwie anhören kann.
Das gibt's ja. Ja, da gibt's ja eine Lösung. Ja voll.
Hier drauf?
Gibt's jetzt auch fürs iPhone.
Ihr macht mal weiter, ich hab zu tun.
Kostet aber.
Ich mach das ja mit meinem iPhone.
Kostet Geld. Dennis.
Dennis.
Ja, aber ich hab wirklich bei Click&Buy, weil ich bin ja jetzt bei Click&Buy, weil ich hab ja keine Kreditkarte.
Ich auch nicht.
Hab ich ja irgendwie mir meinen Account verdröselt, weil ich irgendwie dreimal mein Geburtsdatum falsch eingegeben hab, weil ich's ihnen nicht verraten wollte und ich dachte, die hätten's noch nicht. Aber dabei hatten sie's schon und dann haben sie mich gesperrt. Und dann muss ich da anrufen. Da war eine ganz nette Dame und dann hat sie mich abgefragt und so weiter. Und dann stimmt dann alles und 1.6. Und dann, ja, dann schalten wir's wieder frei. Gar kein Problem. Ding! Und dann war's wieder freigeschaltet. Total nett.
Was, hast du das zurückgebucht oder was?
Nein, ich hab den Account wieder freischalten lassen.
Und click and buy ist eine Kaufoption im App Store?
Genau, wenn man keine Visitenkarte, wenn man keine Kreditkarte hat, dann kann man halt so ein click and buy Kontosservice benutzen und die buchen dann ab.
Verstehe.
Und die waren total entspannt.
So kauf ich ja auch eine.
Und ich muss sagen, ich hab ja eigentlich immer mit Telefon-Hotlines schlechte Erfahrungen und was man immer so hört, ist ja total schrecklich und so. Aber die bei click and buy, die waren total nett. Das war kein Student, sondern es war irgendwie wirklich ein reales Wesen. Nee, ich glaube bei click and buy, glaube ich, war es sogar ein Typ. Aber er war total höflich, hat irgendwie gleich alles gemacht, hat irgendwie auch alles verstanden und irgendwie gemacht und getan und click und fertig. Und bei eBay habe ich ja auch schon mal irgendwie meinen fünf Jahre lang benutzten Account irgendwie reaktivieren lassen. Und da war auch irgendwie, das war eine Frau und die war auch total höflich, total nett und hat alles gemacht und getan, also richtig, habe in letzter Zeit richtig.
War wahrscheinlich dieselbe Telefonagentur, nur einen Platz weiter. Ich meine, das machen die Firmen ja heute gar nicht mehr selber.
Bei click und buy?
Ja, das war, die saß wahrscheinlich in Indien, da hat sich nebenbei noch die Telefonagentur gefallen.
Ich weiß noch, wo ich Telefonsupport hatte, wo alles total super war. Und zwar habe ich bei der Postbank angerufen, weil ich mich beschweren wollte, dass ich da noch so eine Buchung in der Schwebe habe, obwohl die eigentliche Buchung schon abgebucht wurde. Und die hat mir dann richtig erklärt, sie guckt da mal nach. Und das ist eigentlich die gleiche Buchung und ich soll das mal ignorieren und so weiter. Und ich dachte, na ja, aber es ist ja schon ein bisschen komisch, dass sie da zweimal angezeigt wird. Aber es gibt so Buchungen in Schwebe, die werden dann so gehalten, in so einem Temp-Cache, wie auch immer die das da so machen. Und dann meinte sie, na ja, mit einem Mausklick könnte sie die Buchung entfernen. Und dann hat sie die weggemacht. Also das kann ja gar kein Studie- oder sonst wie billig Arbeitskraft sein, weil die konnte da in meinem Konto rumspielen. Das kann ja echt nicht so jeder machen. Das können ja auch nicht outsourcen.
Nein, ist auch nicht so wichtig. Der Chet meint, es wäre ein Wavebot gewesen.
Dann war aber die Sprachemulation ziemlich cool. So, was haben wir noch als Themen?
Ja, WWDC, iPhone. Man könnte ja auch vermuten, dass Sachen zum Macintosh angekündigt werden. Beziehungsweise vielleicht noch vorher, weil es besser passt, Snow Leopard. Jetzt gab es ja eine ganze Reihe von geleakten Videos. Das sind sozusagen die Features, wo man mal drüber reden darf. Habt ihr da irgendwas gesehen?
Ich darf über alles reden, da hab ich nichts unterschrieben. Signiert mein ich.
Nee, ich meine, habt ihr diese Videos gesehen?
Der QuickTime-Clair ist sehr schick.
Ja, also das neue QuickTime X ist für mich ja immer noch die große Fragestellung, ob das nun wirklich den erwünschten...
Das ist ein cooles Feature, weil das ist dieses Trimming. Da kann man echt prima sehen, also der macht von jedem... Du hast einen Film, der irgendwie eine Stunde dauert und dein Fenster ist so groß, dass unten 20 Previews reinpassen. Dann... 20 war jetzt schlecht. Nee doch, dann macht er alle drei Minuten die Momentaufnahme von dem, was in dem Video passiert ist und zeichnet dir unten so an, dann kannst du genau auch hinsliden und kannst dadurch super dein Video trimmen.
Mit Antworten exakt so wie in iMovie.
Ich hab iMovie mir jetzt nicht angeguckt.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schick gemacht.
Ja, und das kann dieses QuickTime X da jetzt irgendwie auch. Den Screen Recording hab ich noch nicht probiert.
Ich find ja für den Player dieses HUD-Lose, also dieses hat dieses, dass es keinen Rahmen mehr hat.
Dass der Rahmen weggeht und so weiter.
Dass der Play direkt eingebaut ist, das find ich sehr schick.
Ja, das ist schon verbraucht eindeutig weniger, wie sagt man, Screen Real Estate Space. Das ist schon nicht schlecht, ja.
Und ich meine, wie lange gibt's jetzt quasi schon dieses aktuelle QuickTime User Interface, also mit leichten Anwandlungen, schon seit Mac OS 8, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, oder? Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als es noch dieses kleine Drehrädchen hatte, der QuickTime Player? Da sah das schon fast genauso aus. Für die Lautstärke. Und dann dieses Brushed Metal Galore. Das sah so ganz furchtbar aus.
Wer brütet denn hier? Dennis?
Ich wollt jetzt mal ein bisschen aktueller sein hier.
Naja, also ich hab ja ein bisschen Angst vor diesem QuickTime X-Release. Weil ich weiß nicht seit wieviel Jahrhunderten ich schon davon träume, dass mal dieses QuickTime erneuert wird. Das ist ja nun wirklich älteste Scheiße. Das ist ja wie alt?
System 7 irgendwann oder System 7.1?
1994, 95. Hab ich QuickTime 1.0 irgendwie auch.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Noch bevor es Multihedien gab.
Da hab ich ja schon 7.5 auf meinem Power-PC gehabt. Da gab es doch vorher schon QuickTime. Aber hallo, das ist viel älter. Ja, aber viel älter.
Wann ist denn das released worden?
Na, weiss nicht, 88 oder so was?
Doch.
Geschichte. 25. Juni 1990.
Ja, siehst du, 95.
90?
90.
Über Ostas alt.
Ja, genau.
Der Beginn von Multimedia.
Irgendwas war 94 anders. Irgendwie gab es einen QuickTime Release, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau.
1994 guckte ich Tim Brütte auf sein erstes QuickTime-Video an.
Kann das sein, dass sie da Capturing eingeführt haben? Irgendwas war 94, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau.
Die haben es ja auch ein paar Mal zwischendurch umgedreht.
Wie auch immer, da hat sich halt nicht viel drin getan. Sie haben da zwar kräftig herumgezuppelt, aber ihr kennt das Elend mit iTunes und so weiter. Es ruckelt, es ist langsam, es verbraucht irgendwie CPU, es nutzt die Kurs nicht ordentlich, es ist einfach mies. Und vor allem, wenn man mal mit Developern redet, die versuchen irgendwie QuickTime-Code zu schreiben, das war der einzige Elend.
Ich hab das ja gemacht für meinen DVD-Rip an diesem Diva. Und ich bin daran gescheitert, schon die Einstellung für QuickTime ordentlich vorzunehmen. Das hat dann irgendwann ein anderer Typi geschrieben, damit das irgendwie okay ist. Also es war nicht schön.
Die Einstellung von was?
Na, wie halt der Film jetzt entcoded werden soll, der die Codex irgendwie anzeigt und dann das einstellen kannst, du willst es irgendwie so groß haben und so weiter und so fort. Das hab ich nicht gepeilt, was die da machen. Das war mir ein Stück. Ich glaub, das war noch mit Pascal Frings und all so ein Scheiß.
Also ich erwarte nichts anderes als vollständig mega ruckelfreies, super smoothes Playback unter allen Bedingungen. Vollständige Nutzung aller nur in irgendeiner Form zur Verfügung stehenden Hardware-Optimierungsmöglichkeiten und überhaupt General Awesomeness. Und wenn sie da irgendwie nicht...
General Awesomeness.
So nennen wir den Podcast, oder? Ja, da kann irgendwie, da kann einfach Steve, da kann er auch irgendwie, da braucht er gar nicht auf die Bühnen zu kommen.
Kommt er auch nicht.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher. Vielleicht ist er ja, vielleicht sagt Phyllis Schiller am Schluss, in There's One More Thing. Nee, so ne Torte.
Phil Schiller würde sagen, der Imperator kommt persönlich.
Vielleicht spricht er ja aus irgendeiner komischen Papptorte oder so was.
Larry Page, ich bin dein Vater.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht. Aber könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass er ernsthaft auf einer WWDC nicht dabei ist? Ich meine nicht nur auf der Bühne, sondern der sitzt auch irgendwo hinten im Raum und so.
Bestimmt oder so, weil dann, wenn es ihm nicht gut geht oder was auch immer noch ist, oder er doch irgendwie plötzlich einen Arzttermin hat, er dann halt nicht hinter der Bühne sein muss. Aber wenn sie sagen, er macht die Kino, dann muss er sie ja auch wirklich machen.
Die haben ja bestimmt so eine super mega Whip-Area irgendwie.
Klar ist der irgendwie auch irgendwie dabei.
Wo schon so die fertig gestopften Bongs und irgendwie die LSD-Kekse rumliegen und so.
In der Sniper-Position, falls was schief geht. Phil, sag nichts Falsches.
So hat er, so ist er halt nicht verpflichtet, das zu machen. Vielleicht sind wir ja per Videokonferenz dazu, oder irgendwie so.
Ja, so was, so Altchat auf dem Telefon.
Ah, per Videokonferenz, das weg doch.
Oder er sitzt einfach vorne in der ersten Reihe.
So Althaus-mäßig?
Wenn er sagt, er ruft jetzt mal seinen Kumpel an und dann machen sie da Video-Chat oder was auch immer für ein Chat.
Nein, Video-Chat würde total Gerüchteküche anheizen, dass es ihm schlecht geht.
Der sitzt dann im gleichen Raum.
Ach so, der sitzt dann im gleichen Raum.
Ja, vorne in der ersten Reihe. Ich glaube, offiziell ist es so, Phil Schiller wird diese Rede halten und wenn Stevie kommt, dann bauen sie es vielleicht kurzfristig als Gag noch ein, wenn er dann kann, aber so halten sie sich halt frei, falls er irgendwie doch nicht kann.
Und dann stellt er irgendwie das neue Tablett vor, was irgendwie in Diamantfassungen daherkommt.
Also ganz ehrlich gesagt, entweder er macht die Keynote zumindest teilweise oder es wird nicht anwesend sein, behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, das...
Weil Personenkult war Apple, also ich meine...
Ich glaube, er nimmt das ja auch raus und ich glaube, der will das auch raus. Der will jetzt einfach nicht mehr, dass Apple so primär über ihn wahrgenommen wird, weil das ist ihm an der Stelle dann auch echt ziemlich egal.
Genau, und das würde doch, wenn dann plötzlich irgendwo so ein Mann rum sitzt, der mal kurz in die Kamera winkt, um zu zeigen, dass er noch lebt, das ist doch... Ist doch gerade erstmal schön ruhig geworden um seine Krankheit, warum soll man das künstlich wieder aufgeben lassen?
Ich denke auch, die werden jetzt so ein bisschen dran arbeiten, dass halt irgendwie der Laden noch ein bisschen mehr ohne Steve läuft.
Steve zieht das Tablett aus der Hose, stelle ich mir gerade... Je nachdem, wie groß das Tablett ist, stelle ich mir das gerade bildhaft ganz lustig vor.
Ach so wie Gamma oder was? So wie Gamma.
Gamma, Gamma.
Da gibt es diese Figur Gamma, die taucht nur in so wenigen Figuren.
Gamma?
Ja, das ist so ein kleines Alien, was irgendwie nur mit einem Lendenschutz daherkommt und der zieht so komplette Hubschrauber immer aus seiner Hose raus.
Das ist, du meinst die kleine Lampe von Daniel Düsentrieb?
Nee, das ist...
Das muss ich googeln, das geht ja gar nicht.
Das ist eine Helferline.
Ich glaube, zum Thema...
Da gibt es auch bestimmt einen irgendwie Charakter...
G-A-M-M-A, ja?
Also in den deutschen Büchern. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie der im englischen Original hieß.
Gamma Ray Announes Massive Donald Duck Free Live Pack.
Du musst das schon in der Wikipedia nachschlagen.
Also ich schlage halt in Google nach und die schlagen mir Wikipedia vor.
Aber ist hier irgendwie nicht...
Bevor wir es jetzt vergessen, WWDC, was bleibt da noch zu sagen? Ach so, neue MacBooks?
Eine Figur aus dem Mickey Mouse-Konzept. Hier, Bewohner von Entenhausen. Gamma und Atömchen, genau. Gamma, auf Englisch Igabiva. Und Atömchen sind zwei Wesen aus der vierten Dimension, die Mickey... Ach, ein Mickey Mouse, Entschuldigung. Gelegentlich bei einem Fall helfen.
Aha, Mickey Mouse hab ich nie gelesen.
Ja, Gamma, ein 88,88 Zentimeter großer Mensch der Zukunft mit Spaghettiarm, Naftalinkugeln, ist allergisch gegen Papiergeld und zieht auch mal eine ganze Wohnungseinrichtung aus seinen Shorts. Genau, und dann gibt's noch diesen Hund und Atömchen und so. Ah Gott, konsolida, meine Generation C64 kommt irgendwie auf einmal wieder von hinten. Anyway, WWDC, Macintosh, gibt's neue Macs?
Ja, es wird neue MacBooks geben und zwar einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich mir gerade ein neues gekauft habe. Das führt immer dazu, dass es zwangsläufig, egal in welchem Zustand Apple gerade ist, zwei Wochen später neue Macs eingeführt werden.
Hier, der da?
Ja, das ist Gamma. Genau, der mit der kleinen Nasen.
Der hat total viel in der Hose.
Ja, der ganze Hubschrauber. Rummeln im Arsch, Hubschrauber in der Hose.
Mit WMTS. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt auf das WMTS. Wenn, dann kommst du mit dem MacBook eher als erstes.
Das kann sein. Das wär auch ein echter Grund, sich einen R zu kaufen.
Wenn was kommt?
Wenn UMTS kommt, dann im MacBook eher.
Das passt zum Namen.
Eigentlich schon.
Fortbewegungsmittel, er braucht keins.
Wer, Gamma oder Steve Jobs?
Genau, ernährt sich von Mockenkugeln. In seinen ersten Abenteuern jedoch ist er in Essig eingelegte chinesische Mandarinen. Kummquats.
Oh man, das sollten wir jetzt mal als Gerücht irgendwie auf die Gerüchteseiten bringen. Steve Jobs ernährt sich nur noch von Mockenkugeln und zieht das MacBook Air mit UMTS aus seiner Hose. Ich wurde dann auch nochmal von einem Hörer in irgendeinem Kommentar oder Tweet, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so genau, ich glaube sogar in beidem, auf so einen drolligen Artikel hingewiesen, der eigentlich der Erwähnung überhaupt nicht wert ist, auch bei PC World, die ja sich als ausgesprochene Hackintosh-Experten verstehen, die irgendwie meinen, so ja, Apple hätte ja irgendwie seine Chance nicht genutzt.
Welche Chance?
Ich weiß gar nicht, soll ich das überhaupt erwähnen? So ein Blödsinn. Die wiederholen halt diesen ganzen Quatsch mit, Apple hat die Chance verpasst, weil sie keinen Netbook gemacht haben und überhaupt Netbooks und Netbooks und Netbooks und so. Und man würde ja in dieser ganzen Hackintosh-Bewegung würde man ja sehen, wie populär das ist, aber das halte ich alles für Quatsch. Dann schreit er irgendwie nach einem Midrange-Desktop. So nach dem Motto, der iMac wäre ja irgendwie zu groß, zu teuer, was weiß ich, die Leute wollen ja ihren eigenen Bildschirm anschließen und vor allem swap the Videocard. Also da kann ich mich ja irgendwie nicht dran erinnern, warum jetzt irgendjemand, der einen Macintosh hat, mal die Videocarte austauschen will.
Apple, die anfangen, dass man Akkus nicht mehr austauschen kann in Geräten, sondern plötzlich Geräte bauen, weil die eine Videocarte austauschen.
Das ist auch wirklich so daneben, da reden sie nicht mehr dran.
Wollen wir mal über diesen, über diesen, über diesen anderes ärgerliches Thema, über diesen Exploit bei Mac OS X reden? Der immer noch...
Aber der ist doch überhaupt nicht spannend, der Exploit. Guck mal, da geht man hier in seinen Preferences.
Wollen wir erstmal erzählen, was es überhaupt ist?
Geht da auf Advanced, ne auf Security, macht da das Häkchen weg und dann ist Ruhe.
Ich brauch Java.
Echt?
Ich hab so Webseiten, wo so über das Java. Also ich find's erstmal...
Ich nicht, aber...
Die Infrastruktur, wo ich zugreifen muss, die sind jemand von der Sorte.
Wollen wir ganz kurz erwähnen, dass Apple Anfang Dezember darauf hingewiesen worden ist, dass in ihrer Default-Installation ein schwer genuger Bug drin ist, mit dem man durch das bloße Besuch in einer Webseite mal eben den Rechner unter fremder Kontrolle geben kann. Und Apple sich nicht mal genötigt sah, die Öffentlichkeit darüber auch nur zu informieren. Wir schweigen dann das Problem mal langsam zu beseitigen.
Wo ist denn diese Lücke genau?
In der Java VM steckt die drin?
In der VM.
Also es ist eine Aufgabe von Sun.
Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Ja, sie ist aber in Sun schon lange, sie ist aber in Sun-Version schon längst gefixt. Also eigentlich hätte Apple vermutlich nicht viel mehr machen müssen, als einen Security-Patch rausschmeißen.
Naja, was schon eine Art Fehler ist, das ist so ein generischer Fehler, der auf allen Plattformen auftaucht, den man nur kopieren muss.
Neben der Apple-Java-Version ist laut Bericht auch die Java-Portierung Soylatte103 betroffen. Die aktuelle Version von Soylatte enthält den Fehler nicht mehr. Eine genaue Beschreibung der Lücke und wie man sie ausnutzt, hat Julian Tinnis in seinem Blog veröffentlicht.
Und gibt es denn irgendwo so einen Test-Exploit, wo man es testen kann, ob alle Arten auf hat oder nicht?
Wer betreut diesen Code?
Ist mir wurscht, wer den betreut, das Problem muss gelöst werden.
Also ist das Code von Sun?
Von Sun, aber die haben den schon gefixt. Also nur Apple hat die neue Version noch nicht gepublished.
Es heißt Sun hat ihn gefixt und Apple übermittelt? Weiß man das?
Ich weiß es übermittelt.
Was weiß ich, vielleicht ist es ja ein Fehler von Sun.
Ist mir wurscht, was ein Fehler ist.
Na ja, wär mir auch wurscht, aber die Frage ist, ist klar, wer hier schuld ist?
Apple.
Die liefert das ja aus.
Wie gesagt, da ist auch...
Was ich meine, wenn sie kaputtes Python, kaputtes irgendwas ausliefern, müssen sie halt fixen. Machen sie ja auch. Oder sorgen da zumindest dafür, dass eine neue Installation kommt.
Sie entwickeln ja nicht Python.
Nee, die müssen dann schon...
Sun hat die Lücke unter anderem mit Java Update 6, mit Java 6 Update 11. Dezember geschlossen. Also scheint die generell in Java aufzutreten, ist aber schon seit einiger Zeit gelöst. Seit über einem halben Jahr.
Du willst das jetzt beklagen?
Das finde ich wirklich mal beklagenswert, oder?
Aber es gibt so viele tausend andere Sachen, die sie auch nicht fixen und das dauert ewig und pfff.
Ja, aber vielleicht sollte man so von wegen, wir haben hier das sicherste Betriebssystem und wir brauchen keine Vian-Scanner. Und wenn Apple noch weiter Marktanteil gibt...
Was kann der so exploiten? Also was ist die Folge der Ausnutzung?
Also du kannst dir den Code mal ausprobieren bei Heise. Dann klickst du den Link an und der führt direkt dazu, dass er das Programm User Bin Say ausführt. Also er hat eine Shell mit Userrechten. Und insofern kann er machen, was er will.
Jungs, Java ausklicken, wenn er es nicht braucht für irgendwas.
Ich brauch's. Vielleicht bin ich ja bald dran.
Also ich halte die Chance, dass es irgendwie ausgenutzt wird und so für relativ gering. Aber schlicht und ergreifend, weil der User-Anteil von Apple immer noch offensichtlich zu klein ist. Aber ewig können sich solche Scheiße nicht mehr erlauben, glaube ich. Weil da ist Microsoft hin oder her. Aber wenn bei dem Bug auftritt, dann gibt es da erstmal irgendwo einen Eintrag und dann wird zumindest drüber geredet.
Gut, da können wir jetzt, also wir haben das jetzt beklagt.
Wir haben das jetzt beklagt.
Okay, gut, dann können wir jetzt vielleicht wieder zu interessanten Sachen gehen.
Chatmeise sollte einen Klick zu Java geben, das wäre cool.
Das stimmt, das ist eine gute Idee.
Für Firefox gibt es das auch. NoScript heißt das. Von dem sehr, sehr viele schwören. Ich finde es ein bisschen sehr paranoid. Aber das ist eine Erweiterung, die so ziemlich alles, was irgendwie nicht HTML ist, erstmal per Default abschaltet. Und man kann es, das ist auch ganz hübsch, man kann es dann regelbasiert wieder freigeben. Also man kann einer Webseite sagen, ja, du darfst deinen eigenen JavaScript-Code von deiner eigenen Domain ausführen, aber den Google Analytics-Code, den lass mal weiterhin schön ungefasst daliegen. Da kann man relativ, also sehr, sehr fein granuliert Rechte freigeben für die einzelnen Webseites. Aber führt natürlich dazu, dass man auf sehr, sehr vielen Seiten erstmal rauskommt. Es geht erstmal gar nichts.
Ihr habt noch zwei Sachen zur Snow Leopard und Safari. Die hängen so ein bisschen zusammen. Also es ist ja jetzt offensichtlich, dass sich Apple meiner Meinung angeschlossen hat und Call Location in Snow Leopard einbauen will. Wenn ich das richtig diesen Videos entnommen habe, machen sie zusammen die Zeitzone automatisch einstellen.
Da kann man klicken, er soll die Zeitzone von alleine rausfinden. Er findet dann nicht nur die Zeitzone raus, sondern auch gleich die Stadt.
Ja, so wie das zu sein hat. Und sieht ja auch so aus, als ob sie das Geo-Feature dann in Safari unterstützen, sodass man das eben auch in Webseiten hat. Das heißt, JavaScript-Code in meinem Browser kann erfragen, wo ich bin.
Und noch viel spannender, ich weiß auf jeden Fall, auf ein iPhone wird das auch gehen.
Ach so, im Safari.
Im iPhone 3.0, auf ein iPhone kann die Location ermittelt werden.
Du hast da mit diesem Latitude rumgespielt, oder?
Ich hab mit diesem Latitude... Zusammenhang vielleicht mal was anderes erwähnen, ganz kurz ist... Der Abschweifen. Aber wirklich nur ganz kurz, ich hab mir irgendwann eine Software geschrieben, die ich für meine Stundenzettel nutze, und zwar die einfach notiert, wo ich mich gerade aufhalte, in welchem Netzwerk, damit ich dann irgendwann mir eine CSV-Datei generieren kann, die mir sagt, dann und dann war es in dem und dem Büro, und dann wäre ich bei dem schon an dem Zurück gearbeitet.
Für solche Zeitstempelsoftware ist das natürlich auch sehr interessant.
Da hab ich mir dann jetzt, als ich mal wieder eine neue Version oder die Version ein bisschen verbessert habe, hab ich noch dazu geschrieben, eine Funktion hab ich mit diesen, wie heißen die, die das auch für Apple liefern, die entsprechenden Koordinaten. Also diese Triangulation über WLAN machen. Skyhawk. Skyhawk Wireless. Da hab ich mir mal deren SDK runtergeladen. Und da ist ein kleines Shell-Programm dabei, das einem die aktuellen Koordinaten ermittelt. Und jetzt speicher ich noch die Koordinaten mit dazu ab, wo ich mich gerade aufhalte. Also gerade als ich mich hier eingeloggt hat, hat er offensichtlich gefragt, wie heißt denn das Netzwerk, wie willst du das nennen, da heißt es Tim genannt. Und also für mich in meiner Datenbank heißt das ab sofort Tim. Und dann weiß ich, ich war bei dir. Und zusätzlich hat er sich noch die Location abgespeichert. Und das ist, die Daten sind einfach unglaublich gut. Also sie sind auf, was ich bisher gesehen habe, so sage ich mal 20, 30 Meter genau. Das ist schon erstaunlich. Auch das, was rein über WLAN-Netzern mittelt wird. Das macht echt Spaß. Ja, Google Latitude.
Das ist schon cool.
Wollen wir vielleicht ein ganzes, also ich meine, das ist ein ganzes Fass.
Bevor wir auf Latitude gehen, ich habe noch, wo wir gerade bei Safari sind, ich will nicht so viel springen. Safari 4 wird dann wohl auch mal endlich mit kleinen Zeit-Certificates umgehen können. Also dass diese ganze Zertifikat-Management mal ordentlich funktioniert auf dem Mac, da warte ich ja auch schon ganz lange drauf.
Was meinst du damit genau?
Na, dass ich mir ein Zertifikat machen kann. Und ich hoffe ja auch, dass ein zunehmender Maße mehr Identity-Dienste malen mir auch solche generell, so was mal erlauben und dass man sich das auch einfacher für sich selber machen kann.
Dass nicht nur die sich authentifizieren, sondern dass du dich auch so bei denen authentifizieren kannst.
Genau, genau dasselbe Zertifikat, was ich für E-Mail verwende. Also ich rede jetzt von S-Mime, also so ein Standard-Zertifikat halt, nicht GPG oder PGP und so weiter. Und dass ich dasselbe Zertifikat auch in meinem Browser verwenden kann, um mich gegenüber Webseiten zu authentifizieren. Also ich will halt irgendwo hin klicken und mich nicht einloggen.
Also dass man sich authentifizieren kann, ohne dass ein Passwort über die Leitung geschickt wird.
Naja, das gibt's eigentlich schon im Netscape Navigator, war das schon irgendwie drin, nur...
Es hat halt keine Säule aus.
Genau, das war nie irgendwie wirklich nennenswert integriert. Das war einfach... Es ist halt auch der Scheiß, wo du so ein Zertifikat herkommst. Das Problem besteht natürlich nach wie vor. Da gibt's immer mal irgendwie irgendwelche Dienste, aber da beschäftigt man sich mal eine halbe Stunde mit und dann vergisst man das wieder und dann weiß man wieder nicht.
Ist das nicht eigentlich so ein Feature, was dann möglicherweise im nächsten Ausweis drinnen ist?
Okay, was weiß ich? Keine Ahnung. Ist mir auch egal. Ich will, dass es in meinem scheiß Computer drin ist. Ich will einfach die Möglichkeit haben, mich gegenüber meinen Webseiten oder bestimmten Webseiten dadurch zu authentifizieren, dass ich den halt einfach einmal sage, hier, das ist mein Key, lass mich rein. Und ich habe gelesen, dass das halt irgendwie kommen soll. Das wäre einfach ganz cool. Und dann ist noch die Sache mit dem Fishing, weil ich das gehabt habe. Neulich lief auch so eine Scam-Welle, Fishing-Welle durch Facebook. Da sind wohl irgendwie diverse Facebook-Accounts gehackt worden. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das genau gelaufen ist. Tatsache ist, dass ich auch aus meinem Umfeld, also aus meiner Peer-Group Leute, die ich so in meinem Facebook, was ich übrigens kaum benutze, ja, das ist das, also vor sich hin, aber ich habe halt einen und so. Und dann habe ich halt eine E-Mail bekommen von einer Person, die eigentlich auch nicht so die Person war, von der ich das jetzt erwartet hätte, dass sie mir eine Facebook-Nachricht schickt, in dem halt nur so eine URL drin ist. Auch so eine ausgeschriebene URL, die nicht aussah wie eine URL. Blablabla.be und dann habe ich das halt irgendwie angeklickert und dann kam so Facebook-Login. Und dann habe ich irgendwie andere Dinge getan und dann habe ich glaube ich mal meinen Rechner-Reboot oder zumindest mich ausgeloggt oder irgendwas auf jeden Fall meinen Browser runtergefahren, Safari wieder gestartet und dann halt so einen halben Tag später so Load all Windows from last session, Historie-Menü gemacht und auf einmal hatte ich so eine Fishing Warning drin. Das heißt so richtig so ein irgendwie Zensursular-Stopp-Schild vor der Nase, hier böse Webseite nicht benutzen. Da hat man gesehen, wie schnell das gehen kann. Einerseits. Andererseits habe ich es überhaupt erst mal live gesehen.
Das ist also okay, dass die bei Google zensieren.
Das ist eine andere Geschichte. Das sind ja Adressen, die man auch öffentlich machen sollte. Bitte?
Sind sie öffentlich, die von Google, was die also gegen Fishing schützen?
Ja, die sind insofern öffentlich als das.
Doch, der Safari lädt ja runter mal die Listen.
Ja.
Also jeder kann die runterladen.
Man könnte die wohl kriegen.
Nee, haben wir nicht mal gesprochen, wie das Ganze ist? Es wird ein Hashcode berechnet.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Genau.
Der holt nicht die komplette Liste, sondern der prüft sozusagen nur die Domänen, macht ein Hashcode und dann sagt der, ob es irgendwie matcht. So was. Also er zieht es nicht runter.
Erst dann wird im Zweifelsfall der Teil der Liste runtergeladen und nochmal verglichen.
Genau.
Na gut, aber das findet ja auf meinem Computer statt. Das ist ja eine andere Geschichte. Genau.
Und ich kann es überbrücken, wenn ich mag.
Genau. Aber hatte ich so das erste Mal die Grafik, so auf dem auf dem Screen, war mal was Neues. Warning Suspected Fishing Site. Ja, eigentlich ziemlich unspektakuläre Meldungen, ne? So, so viel zu Safari und lalalala. Und jetzt kannst du ja nochmal sagen Google Latitude, dieses treck mich auf meinem Handy-Ding. Wenn man nochmal kurz ein bisschen dazu gleist, dann können wir auch gleich mal über dein Handy reden, ja.
Genau. Ich habe mir nämlich ein neues Telefon gekauft, schon wieder, und zwar das HTC Magic. Das zweite Android-Phone in Deutschland. Zuerst gab es ja dieses G1, an dem ich relativ wenig gute Haare gelassen habe und ja noch weniger. Dieses Knarzen mit der Tastatur. Und jetzt gibt es von Vodafone eins, das ist quasi der direkte Nachfolger. Sieht in, wie ich finde, wesentlich, macht doch ein bisschen Geräusche, stört ein bisschen.
Macht das kein UMTS?
Ich habe da im Augenblick noch eine alte SIM-Karte drinnen, die kein UMTS kann. Ich kriege diese Woche noch eine neue UMTS-Karte.
Also ist das nicht mal in einen Airplane? In einem Podcast-Modus?
Das hat sich ja nicht gestört, insofern Glück gehabt. Dann versetze ich mal kurz in den Airplane-Modus. Und im Gegensatz zur ersten Generation, bin ich davon doch relativ angetan. Also die Software, es ist kein iPhone. Das ist natürlich nach wie vor kein iPhone.
Das ist jetzt Version 1.5, ne?
Das ist Version 1.5, Cupcake. Zeichnet zum Beispiel dadurch aus, dass man endlich auch das Ding einfach drehen kann und dann dreht sich der Display-Inhalt mit. Hat eine virtuelle Tastatur und keine echte mehr.
Ne, der dreht sich nicht mit. Das wird umgeblendet. Da dreht nichts. Weil beim iPhone dreht es wirklich.
Es gibt auch hier, es gibt auch so ein Tweak-Programm, die haben noch so einen zweiten Modus drin, wo sich dann das Bild so dreht und dann so ein bisschen wackelt, nachdem es umgedreht hat. Also ich hab's wieder abgeschaltet, weil ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht.
Kann man das auch ausschalten, den Landscape-Dreh?
Den kann man auch ausschalten.
Global? Das ist ja mal ein Feature. Mich das nervt beim iPhone.
Es ist nicht ganz so...
Nachts, seitwärts im Bett surfen geht er wohl nicht.
Oh, dann dieses Cover-Flow, ey, piss die Wand an, man.
Es ist ein bisschen dicker als ein iPhone, dafür aber nicht ganz so breit und auch nicht ganz so hoch. Also liegt ganz gut in der Tasche. Das Display ist hervorragend. Und es hat einen Haufen Software, die so andere nicht haben.
Also das Display hat ja die gleiche Auflösung wie das iPhone, aber ist halt ein bisschen kleiner und hat dadurch eine höhere DPI-Zahl.
Genau. Was man aber auch negativ... Es hat auch, anders als das erste G1, genauso wie das iPhone, hat es keine eingebaute Tastatur mehr, sondern eine On-Screen-Tastatur.
Das ist doch das Werk des Bösen.
Und da sitzen natürlich dadurch die Tasten ein bisschen enger. Die ist nicht ganz so gut wie bei Apple. Aber es hat ein sehr, sehr schickes Feature drin, was die Apple On-Screen-Tastatur nicht hat. Und zwar, Apple macht ja immer nur genau einen Korrekturvorschlag. Und die haben unten so eine ganze Leiste mit Vorschlägen drin. Und die sind auch so, die schlagen auch mal durchaus längere Wörter für. Also wenn du anfängst Straßenbar-Haltestellen, dann irgendwann macht er dann mal einen Vorschlag und dann kannst du direkt drauf tippen und dann das Wort akzeptieren.
Bei 3.0 ist es aber auch besser geworden mit den iPhone-Vorschlägen. Wenn du da rumiditierst, dann macht er den Vorschlag weg und dann kommt er auch nicht andauernd so penetrant wieder. Der merkt dann gleich alles klar, du hast hier wohl was anderes vor und dann hört er auch gleich auf damit. Das ist schon echt gut.
Was nach wie vor das totale Grauen ist, ist Cursor bewegen. Also das ist einfach rein tippen, hoffen, dass du Glück hast. Wenn du kein Glück hast, dann kannst du mit diesem Trackball quasi den Cursor bewegen. Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Wahrscheinlich hat Apple sich diese Variante einfach patentieren lassen, die sie da haben, weil ansonsten hätten sie bestimmt nachgemacht. Ja und die Programme da ist zum Beispiel dieses Google Latitude drauf. Und mit Google Latitude, wenn man, ich hab vorhin irgendwie getwittert, ich scheiß auf meine Privatsphäre-Art, ist das schon sehr geil. Das übermittelt regelmäßig an Google, wo ich mich aufhalte gerade, die GPS-Funktion. Und an Leute, die ich das freigebe, die können das dann sehen. Und ich kann jetzt also in dem Gerät gucken, wenn ich es jetzt nicht gerade im Flugmodus hätte, wo hält sich zum Beispiel gerade der HALO-Logo auf? Nein, die hat es nicht.
Kannst du mir das mal freischalten? Ich will mal wissen, wo du bist.
Das kann man nur mit dem Gerät beziehen.
Weil dann braucht man demnächst nicht im Anrufen, wenn du wieder zu spät kommst, damit sie dann schon, dass du unterwegs bist.
Ich kann nicht im Browser sehen, wo du bist.
Es gibt keinen Web-Interface dafür.
Du musst halt auch ein Andrieth holen.
Ich brauch auch ein Latitude-Client.
Du brauchst auch ein Latitude-Client.
Und den gibt es nicht fürs iPhone?
Noch nicht. Der kommt jetzt mit iPhone 3.0 fürs iPhone. Und zwar als reine webbasierte Sache bisher.
Wie, die machen da ein Webview auf oder was?
Nee, du gehst auf eine Webseite drauf.
Ach so.
Und diese Webseite wird dann wahrscheinlich von dieser neuen Safari-Funktion Gebrauch machen, dass auch Safari die Position ermitteln kann. Gehe ich doch mal fest von aus. Können wir uns sicher sein.
Ich will auch. Und zwar vorhin hatte ich es auch kurz in der Hand. Und was mir aufgefallen ist, weil das ist das erste Programm, was ich irgendwie so per Zufall erwischt habe, ist, dass Google Maps auf dem Ding die Karten irgendwie viel, viel schneller nachlädt als auf dem iPhone.
Das ist wirklich irre.
Und das ist wirklich viel flotter. Also müssten wir auch gleich nochmal testen. Aber ich glaube, das ist schon wirklich, das ist nicht nur gefühlt, das ist auch wirklich flott. Das kann nicht nur am Netz liegen hier. Und das andere, was mir aufgefallen ist, weil hier gibt es ja auch hier so das Programmfenster. Das ist wie so ein Sheet, was von unten nach oben so reinscrollt. Das alles, was so mit Scrolling auf dem Phone zu tun hat, ist ein bisschen rockeliger als auf dem iPhone. Also auf dem iPhone ist es schon wirklich elegant gelöst. Und die machen ja damit hier NS Animation und so rum auf dem iPhone. Und das nutzt ja wohl, wie ein Kumpel zu mir meinte, schon auch hier dieses OpenGL und das flutscht wie nichts. Also NS Animation ist echt eine tolle Sache.
Ja, also das iPhone ist definitiv nach wie vor das elegantere Telefon. Also es ist so dieses, schon in deinen Listen dieses, dass du, wenn du, dass du eine Liste nach oben weiterscrollen kannst, dass die dann erst mal so rumfedert, wenn sie am oberen Ende ist. Es ist einfach so ein geilen Indikator, kann man...
Das kriegen die bestimmt auch noch hin. Aber da ruckelt es halt noch ein bisschen, weil sie wahrscheinlich so den grundsätzlichen Support noch nicht so schick sauber integriert haben.
Auch da wird es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen an den Patenten scheitern. Was nach wie vor ganz toll ist an dem Teil, ist Google Talk. Also hier Jabba. Ist ganz großartig. Das Over-the-Air-Syncing beeindruckt mich jedes Mal wieder. Also man startet das Telefon, legt seine SIM-Karte rein. Dann verbindet man sich mit dem Wi-Fi, ich in dem Fall, weil ich keinen Netzzugang hatte über die Karte. Und gibt seine Google-Zugangsdaten ein und dann legt er das Adressbuch runter, dann legt er die Kalendereinträge runter. Und dann richtet man ein Mail-Account ein und man kann innerhalb von Sekunden anfangen und das Zeug ist auch sofort oben. Also ich mach irgendwie eine Änderung. Also ich hab auf dem Telefon gesehen, da stimmt was an einem Adressbucheintrag nicht, hatte keine Lust, auf der winzig kleinen Tastatur rumzuditschen, hab das dann kurzerhand im Gmail auf dem Mac gemacht, diese Änderung gehabt, nachgeguckt, war wirklich augenblicklich auf dem Android-Telefon vorhanden. Das ist schon schick. Hintergrundprozesse, also Akkulaufzeit, bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie das wird, weil im Augenblick hab ich noch nicht die finale SIM-Karte, hab darum auch unterwegs keine Datennutzung, was natürlich sich sehr positiv auf die Lebenszeit des Akkus auswirkt. Also werde ich sehen, wie das ist, wenn dann die echte SIM-Karte drin steckt, aber so, dass sich so ein Programm wie Twidroid, also Twitter, im Hintergrund laufen lassen kann, das ist schon, das hat was. Und gerade Google Talk im Hintergrund ist wirklich großartig. Also die ganze Zeit unschatbar zu sein, das macht echt Spaß. Sehr, sehr schönes Telefon.
Ich werde dir gerade korrigiert, was die Sache mit den kleinen Zertifikaten betrifft. Das würde schon ganz gut funktionieren, und zwar auch auf dem iPhone. Dann wäre vielleicht mal ein interessantes Tutorial irgendwie ganz interessant, wo man mal so sehen kann, wie man das für sich sinnvoll erschließen kann. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch eher eine Server-Problematik als eine kleine Problematik.
Wenn man aufklickt, hat man die Tagesansicht. Dann kommt man aber mit dem Back-Button nicht wieder zurück auf die Monatsansicht. Und das ist so, ist jetzt nichts, weswegen ich dieses Telefon nicht kaufen würde. Aber es ist sowas, dass Google offensichtlich bei der Entwicklung erstmal auf andere Dinge die Priorität gesetzt hat, als auf User-Interface Streamlining während der Entwicklung von 1.5, also von diesem Cupcake. Das Zweite, der Browser ist beim iPhone nach wie vor um einiges besser. Und zwar auch aufgrund von so billigen Sachen wie, also beim iPhone hat man ja, wenn man einen Browser startet und eine Webseite aufruft, hat man erstmal die gesamte Webseite als Übersicht. Und kann dann anfangen rein zu zoomen. Und bei dem Google-Phone ist das so, er macht so dieses übliche, wie es jeder Browser auf dem Handy macht, man sieht so diese obere linke Ecke von dem Bild, also von dem Werbebanner, das sich an der Stelle befindet. Und das finde ich tatsächlich mal, ja wir sind im Flugmodus, darum haben wir kein Netz. Und das ist tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das tatsächlich patentiert ist durch Apple. Hey, eine Seite ist erst mal rausgezoomt, wenn ich sie besuche, kann ich mir einfach nur schwer vorstellen. Also da sollten sie auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen nachlegen. Aber ansonsten ein schönes Telefon, was auf jeden Fall, also Apple muss jetzt nicht direkt spanische Angst haben, aber es ist schön zu sehen, dass auch, dass nicht nur das iPhone eine benutzbare Plattform ist, sondern dass da auch noch ein bisschen was anderes kommt.
Ja, ich denke nach wie vor, dass irgendwie iPhone und Android, die werden sich diesen Markt schon irgendwie aufteilen.
Wollen wir noch ganz kurz auf den Palmpre zu sprechen kommen?
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen?
Naja, da ist der Boy Genius Report, die haben offensichtlich ein Gerät in die Finger bekommen, so wie es in den Laden kommen wird, angeblich. Na, sie haben genug Fotos, als dass es wirklich so ist.
Ob es dann wirklich so in den Laden kommt, ist ja noch mal eine andere Frage.
Achso, nee, sie haben das ja von Palm zugeschickt bekommen zum Testen.
Ach, sie wollen das ja jetzt zwei Tage...
Das kommt ja jetzt am sechsten.
Richtig, richtig, richtig, die Zeit schreit voran.
Und die haben das auf Herz und Nieren geprüft. Und die negativen Sachen vorneweg, es fühlt sich so wohl sehr plastikhaft an. Und die Tastatur soll wirklich furchtbar sein, auch für eine Tastatur, die auf einem... Also für eine Hardware-Tastatur. Aber sie waren sehr, sehr beeindruckt von der Software. Also haben natürlich noch nicht sonderlich viele Programme, die sie testen können, weil den App Store für den Palm gibt es natürlich erst, wenn er online ist. Und auch ein Teil der anderen Programme funktionierte noch nicht. Also zum Beispiel der Media Player funktionierte noch nicht, weil der erstmals am Anfang auf eine Webseite zugreifen will, auf eine Hilfeseite bei Palm. Und das kann er im Augenblick noch nicht, weil die noch nicht online ist und darum kann er die Media Player nicht testen. Von den restlichen Programmen sind sie aber offensichtlich relativ beeindruckt. Ist noch kein iPhone, also sie haben es angesiedelt zwischen Android und dem iPhone, was ich für ein 1.0 Release relativ okay finde.
Also besser als Android oder was?
Besser als Android. Sie haben allerdings ein bisschen gezweifelt an einer Sache, die ich auch mal sehr gespannt finde und zwar an einem der Kern, zumindest vom Marketing her, an einem der Kernpunkte des Palm Preys. Und zwar haben sie gesagt, was ja ganz wichtig ist bei dem Ding, ist ja diese Facebook-Integration. Oder die Integration von Webdiensten, also dass sich meine Gmail-Adressdaten, dass die automatisch reingehen, aber dass es nicht wie bei Android ist, nur die Gmail-Adressdaten reingehen.
Dass im Prinzip alle haben können.
Ich kann meinen Facebook-Account damit reinschmeißen und wer hat gesagt, naja ich habe da irgendwie 5000 Kontakte in meinem Facebook-Account, von denen möchte ich aber nicht einfach nicht alle in meinem Adressbuch drin haben. Was irgendwie nachvollziehbar ist auf so einer Art.
5000 Kontakte auf Facebook?
Na ja, ich meine, wie schnell ist man dabei bei Facebook, jeder Anfrage, die kommt, mit ja wegzuklicken. Ich habe da auch noch nicht so die richtige Variante gefunden, wie man das macht. Echt, machst du das? Eine Zeit lang habe ich es gemacht, dann hat es mich wieder gestört, dann habe ich aufgehört.
Ich habe eine Real-Life-Policy.
Ja, diese Real-Life-Policy haben relativ viele Leute. Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte gerne eine Variante, wo ich den Leuten die Möglichkeit geben kann, dass sie ruhig die dreieinhalb Sachen, die ich darauf mache, dass sie die sehen können, aber das ist nicht zwangsläufig jetzt über jeden. Also ich hätte es gerne so twittere, mehr so twittermäßig. Also dass die gerne mit mir befreundet, also dass die anderen mit mir sind.
Ein Follower-Prinzip.
So ein Follower-Prinzip. Weil ich habe ja nichts dagegen, dass die Leute, ich möchte bloß nicht zwangsläufig in meinem Adressbuch sehen.
Also Palm Primates hat einfach zu wenig Auswahlmöglichkeiten.
Im Augenblick bietet das auch die Facebook-App hier noch nicht besser.
Aber da kann ja auch, also für manche Leute mag das aber durchaus hinhauen, dass die Leute, die sie auf Facebook sozusagen als Freunde haben, dann auch wirklich diejenigen sind, die du dann in deinem Adressbuch haben willst. Andererseits willst du auch noch zusätzlich welche haben. Also gut, das mag ja jetzt ein informiertes Review gewesen sein, aber ehrlich gesagt, da warte ich mal jetzt nochmal ab. Auf jeden Fall glaube ich, erstens, der Pri wird einfach so viele Bereiche nicht besetzen kann, dass es eigentlich zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt als iPhone-Konkurrent nicht wirklich auf dem Papier steht. Sondern der Palm muss erstmal was ganz anderes schaffen. Der muss erstmal Palm retten. Klar, also die müssen überhaupt erst mal ihre eigenen Kunden angesprochen bekommen, beziehungsweise so viele neue Käuferschichten erschließen, dass sich das für sie überhaupt noch lohnt und dass sie dem Rubinstein seinen Gehalt zahlen können. Weil das ist jetzt nicht mehr so gesagt.
Aber was man erstmal sagen kann, glaube ich, ist, dass offensichtlich der Hype, der um das Gerät gemacht wird, zumindest für einen gewissen Teil berechtigt ist. Also dass es keine reine Vaporware war, die da gezeigt worden ist.
Die Frage ist natürlich, wie weit kommen Sie jetzt mit Javascript als Development-Plattform?
Na das werden wir als... Es scheint ja zumindest ganz gut zu laufen. Die eingebauten Applikationen scheinen ja gut zu funktionieren. Soweit klar, in Real-World-Einsatz werden wir noch einige kleine Erlebnisse...
Oder die wollen mir nicht erzählen, dass sie ihren Media Player in Javascript programmiert haben.
Den mp3-Teil, warum nicht? Also natürlich nicht den mp3-Abspiel mit Javascript.
Dafür gibt es dann immer Lips, das ist ja bei allen Sprachen so, dass Hardcore-Zeugs ist, ausgelagert und irgendwelche Frames, die sind dann auch in ordentlich.
Und Spiele? Spiele wird eine spannende Frage werden. Aber auch da...
Und das ist der Mann, der ist bei Apple verdient an den Spielen, ja wohl am meisten, ne?
Weiß ich nicht.
Doch, weil das meiste sind wohl Spiele. 80% oder so, wie war das?
Also man kann sich streiten, ob sie am Upstore überhaupt nennenswert Geld verdienen, aber ich glaube, dass Spiele für ihre Plattformstrategie insgesamt eine sehr große Rolle spielen.
Ja, für Apple.
Ob das jetzt für Palm dasselbe ist, als die...
Nee, für Palm gar nicht, weil das Ding ist halt so, einfach mit JavaScript kannst du keine Spielplattform machen. Also vielleicht sind wir irgendwann mal so weit, aber definitiv nicht.
Also ich glaube, die Entwicklung für JavaScripter, die entsprechenden VMs, die werden auch immer schneller. Zum Zweiten kannst du auch da sagen, du packst irgendwelche OpenGL-Elemente. Also ich meine, es gibt ja nun auch...
Ja, aber dein Environment, in dem du poemierst, deswegen heißt es WebOS, ist halt... Web. Also es ist dein Webbrowser-Environment. Wir reden hier wirklich von irgendwie Documentries und tralala, plus irgendwie ein bisschen Framework, was sie dazu gepackt haben. Da müssen sie halt wirklich was liefern, was auch Spiele wirklich unterstützt.
Also ist gut.
Das andere Ding ist, dass das Ding natürlich in der Hardware-Version, die sie jetzt ausliefern, eh kein Konkurrent ist, weil es läuft einfach nicht in denselben Netzen.
Es läuft im Augenblick noch nicht in denselben Netzen. Sie sagen auch explizit, die Hardware ist tendenziell scheiße beim Palm. Und ist bei dem Gerät auch nicht sonderlich doll. Also wie gesagt, es fühlt sich scheiße an. Die Tastatur ist eher nüll und so was in der Richtung. Sie sagen aber, die Software ist so gut, um das auszugleichen.
Sie werden jetzt mit ihrem Announcement auch total überrollt. Ich meine, zwei Tage vor der WWDC irgendwie ein Telefon vorzustellen.
Das ist schon mutig.
Das ist... Also entweder...
Wahrscheinlich haben sie es nicht früher rausbekommen und wollten es nicht erst danach rausbringen. Dass sie zumindest noch ein bisschen zwei Tage Zeit haben, irgendwie, dass man über sie redet.
Oder sie haben verdammt dicke Eier in der Hose. Und denken sich, wir können Apple die Show stellen damit.
Tja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall extrem wünschenswert, dass es weitere Smartphone-Plattformen gibt. Genau, dass es einfach noch andere Contender gibt, die ihr Gewicht in die Wachschale werfen und die dann halt auch Apple vielleicht mal hier und da zeigen, was Sache ist. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube immer noch, dass mit der 3.0, wie sie dann letztendlich ausgeliefert wird, noch ein paar Sachen drin sind, die wir heute noch nicht kennen und dass sie eigentlich so für die meisten Sachen dann auch Antworten haben.
Achso, dann hat Microsoft das würde ich jetzt gerne in zwei Sätzen abhaken. Die haben mir den Soon HD angekündigt, der irgendwann im September kommen soll.
Der HD Radio.
Angekündigt.
Das quasi so eine Art iPod Touch Konkurrenz ist und der hat auch einen Browser drin und ratet mal, welcher Browser da drin ist. Immer noch Internet Explorer. Ja, aber komm, Microsoft, spring über deinen Schatten.
Die können über ihren Schatten so lange springen, wie sie wollen. Sie kriegen da einfach nix anderes portiert auf ihren Kack. Das ist ja alles so miteinander verzahnt.
Die können auch, die können auch. Ich meine, wenn er schon Webgit nicht wollt, dann packt doch da wenigstens ein Gekko drauf oder sowas. Oder lizenziert irgendwas von Opera. Also irgendwas besseres als diesen scheiß veralteten Internet Explorer könnte da doch mal auf euren Geräten... Also ich meine, das ist doch wirklich ein Schuss ins eigene Bein. Das soll ansonsten relativ guter Player sein, der erst mal so ganz schick ist. Ich hab mal ein paar Videos gesehen, wie das User Interface ist. Das sieht aus dem ersten Blick erstmal sehr, sehr geil stylisch aus und sowas.
Ja, völlig unbenutzbar sah das aus.
Ähm, das, das, das würde ich mir erst sagen oder Urteil darüber erlauben, nachdem ich es in der Hand gehalten habe. Aber dann einen Internet Explorer da reinzupacken? Ich glaube, ich hab neulich mal Twitter probiert, mit einem Internet Explorer zu bedienen. Das ging quasi nicht, weil offensichtlich selbst bei Twitter, die Entwickler, das Ding einfach nicht mehr im Internet Explorer testen.
Es ist vorbei.
Und vor allen Dingen ist es keine schnelle Plattform.
Ich kann es nur wiederholen, also ich finde, es ist Microsoft-Thema auch überhaupt nicht mehr interessant. Jetzt haben sie ja auch irgendwie gerade wieder neue Vaporware vorgestellt auf dieser Game-Messe. Jetzt wollen sie ja irgendwie...
Diesen neuen Controller.
Nintendo irgendwie die Stirn bieten mit so einem Humpel-Kamera.
Da fand ich die Variante von Sony wesentlich besser.
Da hab ich nur von... Behört das, die was vorgestellt haben?
Also die haben so eine Mischung aus beiden. Microsoft hat auf der E3, dieser Game-Messe, haben die was vorgestellt. Ab wann soll das verfügbar sein? Also quasi...
Das ist halt das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte. Sie haben es halt angekündigt.
Ja, aber Sony hat es auch noch angekündigt. Sony will es im Frühjahr 2010 raushaben.
Und was haben sie angekündigt?
Microsoft setzt oben eine Kamera drauf.
Also oben auf die Xbox?
Auf den Fernseher. Du packst eine Kamera obendrauf, die auf dich gerichtet ist und damit wirst du abgefilmt. Und...
Erkennt alles.
Und die erkennt dann deine Bewegung. Und die haben dann so ein paar Demo-Applikationen gezeigt, also dass du quasi mit ausgestreckten Armen, indem du so tust, als ob du ein Lenkrad in der Luft halten würdest, Auto fahren kannst und ein anderes Variante, die sie hatten, wo sie dann so mit virtuellen Eimern, also du tust, als würdest du ein Eimer in der Luft halten und dem gegen eine Leinwand schmeißen und dann siehst du die Farbspritze, wie sie sich auf dieser Leinwand herausbilden. Dass er soweit, also wenn es so funktioniert, wäre das eine ganz neckische Variante. Die nächst schönere Variante hat aber Sony gebracht. Und zwar die haben eine Mischung aus diesem Wii, Nintendo Wii, wo man ja den Stick in der Hand hat, der das Motion Sensing macht. Und dieser Microsoft-Variante mit der Kamera gemacht. Und zwar, du hast was in der Hand, und wesentlich eine Lampe. So eine kleine Taschenlampe quasi. Und die Kamera ermittelt die Position dieser Taschenlampe.
Also du hast einen Infrarotsender in der Hand.
In dem Fall hat es sogar noch geleuchtet. Also es war nicht infrarot, sondern es war rot. Rot und blau. Die beiden verschiedenen Sticks. Und das kann man natürlich relativ leicht rausrechnen. Wahrscheinlich noch, ich weiß nicht, wie sie Entfernung hinkriegen.
Aber Abstände von...
Stimmt, genau. Irgendwie so was in der Richtung. Und erst mal hast du ein Werkzeug in der Hand. Also ich meine bei allen Spielen, wenn man mit einem Schwert rumspielt oder auch bei dem Eimerbeispiel von Microsoft hast du ja was in der Hand. Zum zweiten glaube ich da viel eher, dass man das gut ermitteln kann, wo sich das gerade aufhält in der Luft. Und die haben wirklich ein paar Demos gehabt. Also du hast so quasi mit virtuellen Ninja-Sternen, wie heißen die Dinger? Die die Ninja immer irgendwo reinschmeißen. Oder mit Pfeil und Bogen. Also du hast zwei Sticks in der Hand und du ziehst sie so gegeneinander auf. Dann gehst du in Zielmodus und lässt los. Hast du noch eine Taste drinnen in den Teilen, dass du auch so ein paar Buttons hast oder für Waffen oder sowas. Das sah schon alles sehr großartig aus. Und die haben eine Steuerung damit gemacht, mit der du Objekte haargenau im Raum positionieren kannst auch. Also du hast vor dir ein virtuelles Spielfeld und du kannst dann mit deinen Sticks wirklich positionieren innerhalb dieses Spielfelds. Und dadurch, dass es eine Kamera ist und nicht wieder weil der V eben einfach nur ein Stick, können sie das Bild auch umdrehen und können sogar noch Augmented Reality reinpacken. Und was hat Nintendo vorgestellt? Hast du mitbekommen, was Nintendo vorgestellt hat?
Also, auch nur so am Rande.
Einen Blutdruckmesser.
Naja, die gehen so voll in dieses Senioren-Ding rein.
Einen Blutdruckmesser. Steuere Spiele mit deinem Puls. Das könnte ein Fake sein, oder? Die haben einen Blutdruckmesser. Wahrscheinlich, damit man sich beim, damit es warnt, wenn man sich zu viel bewegt beim Spielen.
Nö, das sind einfach so Fitness-Messer sozusagen.
Ja, aber wenn entweder Sony oder Microsoft tatsächlich das auf die Reihe kriegen, was sie auf der E3 versprochen haben, dann...
Ich bin ja nicht so sicher, ob das mit diesen Kameras wirklich so gut funktioniert, aber das werden wir mal sehen.
Also mit diesem Stick im Raum, da hast du eine eindeutige, wenn du ein eindeutig ausreichend eindeutiges Signal abgeben kannst, kriegst du das hin. Das kriegt man sogar mit relativ geringem Aufwand hin. Da gibt es ja schon zehn Zeiler für, wie heißt diese Entwicklungsumgebung gleich hier auf dem Mac auch? Processing.
Ja, weil dieses Ding mit Gesichterkennung und erkennt dich wieder und so.
Gesichterkennung, das war halt Microsoft behauptet.
Ja, ja, das haben die halt behauptet.
Stimmt, die hatten ja auch das mit dem Skateboard, oder dass man sein eigenes Skateboard so vor die Kamera halten kann und dass er das dann einscannt.
Ja, geile Demo. Dann hat er so sein Skateboard dahingehalten, aber hatte so seine Flossen drauf und auf dem Foto war es halt nicht drauf. Also es war halt einfach mal voll gefaked von vorne bis hinten und ich glaube, dass das Produkt auch aussieht.
Also bei Sony war es die Demo, dass sie wirklich eine echte Demo da hatten, also dass eine Person, die live dasteht, das Ganze ausprobiert hat. Das lässt sich schon mal nicht ganz so leicht zurechtfaken. Okay, die werden sicherlich relativ ideale Lichtbedingungen da auf der Bühne geschaffen haben, damit das alles so super funktioniert. Aber das sah mir durchaus nach was aus, würde man sagen können, in einem Dreivierteljahr haben sie daraus wirklich ein gutes Produkt gemacht und da kann ich mir wirklich tausend geile Anmeldungen vorstellen für.
Ja, fast forward. Ich hab ja auch ein bisschen an meiner Hardware hier getunt. Da wollte ich auch nochmal erzählen.
Ach stimmt, du hast irgendwie deinen Rechner leise gekriegt?
Ja, also zumindest meistens ist er leiser. Jetzt in diesem Moment gerade nicht, weil wenn er was zu tun hat, ist er noch genauso laut wie sonst, aber ich hatte halt den Fall, dass er einfach überhaupt nicht mehr aufgehört hat zu blasen. Also zum Hintergrund, ich habe ein schwarzes MacBook und so mit voller Ausbaustufe. An sich mag ich das Gerät ja sehr, aber wenn es halt unter Last ist, dann ist es halt unter Last und dann ist da einfach mal der Lüfter am Start. So ist das halt. Aber es ist halt extrem nervig, wenn das Gerät nichts macht, dass es dann halt trotzdem scheiße heiß wurde. Und der Grund war ganz einfach, kann man ja vorweg nehmen, Lüfter verstopft. Ganz einfach. Da hat sich halt einfach so viel Scheiße angesammelt. Und der Lüfter, der bei dem Gerät in der Mitte hinten am Bildschirm sitzt, der ist halt so ein Spirallüfter, das ist mittlerweile auch normal. Und der schaufelt halt Luft vom Mainboard irgendwie nach draußen. Und vor allem bläst er das durch so eine Art Metallgatter, was halt so ein bisschen so wie die Frontblende von so einer C-Amonica, C-Amonica aussieht, wo dann eben noch die Heatpipe von dem Prozessor und von dem Grafikstein vorbeigeht. Und ist ja klar, wenn da halt irgendwie dicht ist, dann kommt halt einfach die Luft nicht mehr raus, dann wird die Wärme nicht transportiert. Also hab ich mir vom Powerbook-Medic den Auseinanderschraub-Guide für das MacBook runtergeladen. Ausgedruckt. Und der funktioniert auch ganz ordentlich. Wer das mal machen will mit seinem MacBook, also das ist eine etwas längere Prozedur, aber sie ist nicht sehr... Also ich hab's mir... Ich hatte ein bisschen mehr Angst. Das war dann am Ende dann doch alles nicht so schlimm. Man sollte bloß darauf achten, dass man, wenn man die Schrauben Schritt für Schritt auseinanderlegt, so hab ich mir gemacht, ich hab mir einfach eine große Fläche freigeräumt und hab die Schrauben schön, jeden einzelnen Arbeitsschritt, so von links nach rechts die Schrauben, wie ich sie auseinandergebaut habe, so nebeneinander getan. Sodass ich sozusagen erst von links nach rechts mir da so einen Schraubenwald aufgebaut habe und den danach von rechts nach links wieder weggearbeitet habe. Das ist sehr hilfreich, damit man nicht wirklich vergisst, irgendwas reinzubauen, weil die Anzahl Schrauben ist nicht gering und vor allem sind alle sehr, sehr, sehr unterschiedlich. Also lange, kleine, dicke, dünne, alles dabei. Und ich musste das Teil halt wirklich fast komplett auseinander bauen. Also erstmal macht man so außen ab, dann nimmt man den Frontdeckel ab. Dann musste ich das Laufwerk ausbauen und dann also das CD-Laufwerk ausbauen, Platte raus, dann CD-Laufwerk oder DVD-Laufwerk raus und dann den Lüfter ab. Und dann habe ich aber auch noch die Heatpipe vom Prozessor abgemacht als allerletztes und habe da auch nochmal frische Paste drauf geballert. Weil ich mir dachte, wenn ich jetzt eh schon alles auseinander habe, dann mach ich halt auch gleich nochmal frische Paste draus. Keine Ahnung, wie die Paste, die nicht mehr leitet, aussieht, aber so richtig gesund sah mir das alles nicht aus. Habe ich da so zwei kleine Erbsengrößen von dieser Passe drauf gedrückt und dann alles wieder zusammengebaut. Ergebnis, danach bläst er wieder ordentlich und wenn man halt nichts mit ihm macht und da nicht irgendwie CPU-fressende Geschichten im Hintergrund rumlungern, dann geht er halt in der Temperatur runter und dann geht halt auch der Lüfter mal wieder runter.
Besser als vorher also?
Definitiv besser als vorher. Unter Volllast ist jetzt so kein Unterschied, aber unter normaler Last ist ein großer Unterschied.
Volllast hört halt auf bei mir bei 6000 Drehungen, bei dir dann wahrscheinlich auch, aber ist wahrscheinlich da bei kühler.
6200, naja ich hab jetzt 74 Grad.
Ich glaub 250.
Tja, so ein großes MacBook hat mehr Platz.
Dabei steht da ja schon so günstig hier, dass er hier besser rausdenken kann.
Optimal ist das alles nicht. Aber ich kann jeden da nur ermutigen, das zu machen. Das ist also definitiv ein beherrschbarer Prozess. Man braucht halt ordentliches Equipment, also kleine Elektronikschraubenzieher, Kreuzschlitz in verschiedenen Größen.
Also ich hab hier gerade gelesen, das kommt im Chat, dass vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang an zu der Hinweiswirk bei ifixit.com gibt's Vordrucke, wo man die Schrauben mit draufkleben kann.
Wo man die ausgebauten Schrauben auf dem Blattpapier wahrscheinlich gleich...
Und die sind dann auch durchnummeriert, die einzelnen Punkte, und da wo man die Schraube her hat, da steht dann auch, passt dann zur Anleitung dazu. Weil ich muss nämlich sagen, ich hab einmal probiert, ein iBook zu reparieren selber, das ist komplett in die Hose gegangen.
Ja horrible, hab ich auch mal gemacht, mach ich nie wieder.
Und ich hab ein Powerbook, damals noch ein Teilbook, also ein Titanium, hab ich mal zerlegt und wieder zusammengeschraubt und ein neues Display eingebaut. Es hat danach funktioniert, aber nur zwei Wochen lang. Also ich bin davon mittlerweile abgegangen, meine Apple-Rechner, meine Laptops noch selberhand anzulegen. Das hab ich bei Desktop-Rechnern sehr gerne gemacht, aber so einen Laptop zu zerlegen, hab ich doch sehr viel Respekt vor. Würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit dem Baby hier machen.
Hatt ich auch, zumal als ich alles wieder zusammengebaut habe, ging er dann nicht mehr. Das war aber nur, weil ich das Rahmen irgendwie nicht richtig reingedrückt hab.
Ah, okay, also genau der Schwachpunkt.
Obwohl ich das Rahmen noch gar nicht mal hätte ausbauen müssen, das hatte ich nur irgendwie so, weiß ich auch nicht, hab ich einfach so automatisch irgendwie gemacht, weil ich glaube ich mal draufdrücken wollte.
Und du hattest irgendwie, also mit einem Staubsauger hat es nicht funktioniert?
Ach so, die Staubsauger-Geschichte, ja. Ein Freund von mir meinte so, naja, bevor du es auseinanderbaust, kannst du einfach einen Staubsauger ranhalten, dann kommt es auch raus. Das habe ich dann so getwittert und wurde dann irgendwie retweetet, retweetet, retweetet, bis dann irgendjemand mal anmerkte, das könnte auch dein Lüfter über beanspruchen.
Ach, im laufenden Betrieb quasi, oder?
Nein, nein. Aber auch wenn du da jetzt einen Staubsauger ranhältst, was wird passieren? Der Lüfter wird sich drehen. Und irgendjemand hatte wohl auch mal die Erfahrung gemacht, dass durch den großen Sog der Lüfter Schaden nimmt. So, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt wirklich erzeugter wahrscheinlich ist.
Also wenn dein Staubsauger den Lüfter dreht, dann ist es ja dynamo, wie es erzeugt, ja dann glatt Strom, oder? Der dann in die andere Richtung fließt.
Kann man den Akku damit laden?
Ich laden, aber das ist halt Strom, in die falsche Richtung auszusuchen.
Ich hab meine Empfehlung dann erstmal wieder zurückgenommen. Keine Ahnung, ob das jemand zur Kenntnis genommen hat, aber ich wollte dann echt nicht schuld sein. Also das Auseinanderbauen hat noch andere Vorteile, weil man kriegt dann halt einfach mal die Scheiße wirklich richtig sauber. Das ist ja auch nicht nur so, da ist nicht nur so Staub drin, sondern da ist auch so öliger Schleim so ein bisschen mit dabei. Ich hab wirklich Alkohol benutzt, also hier so in der Apotheke, Kurvenkant oder Drogerie wahrscheinlich auch einfach so reinigungsnormaler Alkohol. Und halt so Wattestäbchen.
Wattestäbchen, sind die dafür gut?
Naja klar, tauchst du in den Alkohol rein und dann hab ich da irgendwie...
Weil Watt ja sogar noch mal irgendwo kleben bleibt.
Ach, da kleben so viele Haare drin, irgendwie das wird nur besser. Ja, die Scheiße bleibt dann ganz gut in diesem Wattestäbchen kleben. Also damit kann man schon ganz gut arbeiten. Gibt sicherlich auch noch andere Methoden, aber die hat jetzt für mich ganz gut funktioniert. Und dann wirst du halt auch diesen ganzen Süff los. Das heißt, du hast dann in dem Moment auch den Vorteil, dass du eben dieses Grill dann auch eben wirklich richtig sauber kriegst, sodass eben auch der ganze Schleim weg ist, sodass nicht der Staub auch gleich wieder dran kleben kann.
Aber ja, also kann sogar was schaden. Kann ich ja noch mal kurz ein Status-Update geben, weil ich hab mir vor zwei Wochen ein neues MacBook Pro gekauft. Nein, also vor der letzten Sendung direkt. Vor drei Wochen war das dann. Genau, da kann ich jetzt mal ein kleines Update geben. Das ist ein sehr schönes Gerät, es hat aber auch seine kleinen Macken. Also was ich sehr, sehr nervig finde, ist diese Macke hier. Das Display geht zu, wenn man das Gerät senkrecht quasi hält.
Ach, das hatte ich gehört.
Wie schlimm ist das bei dir? Mach noch mal.
Das ist ja gar nicht bei mir, da geht das.
Das ist, also wenn man im Bett liegt, und dann kann man unter Umständen, die die Beine angewinkelt hat, dann kann man unter Umständen Pech haben.
Das ist ja richtig bekloppt.
Das ist eher doof, also es ist viel zu leicht.
Dann kannst du einfach hier was dazwischen klemmen und dann gehts wieder.
Ja, aber ich will nicht irgendwo was dazwischen klemmen. Das nächste Ding ist die Kante hier vorne.
Die ist ganz schön scharfkantig.
Das ist demnächst von Griffin irgendwie iClub-Gummi-Dreiecke, die du da reindrücken kannst.
Das ist hier vorne relativ scharfkantig. Und so, wenn man es auf dem Schreibtisch stehen hat, dann nicht, da ist es kein Problem. Aber wenn man es auch auf dem Schoß hat, dann sind die Arme bei mir in einem anderen Winkel. Und da hab ich am Anfang schon so irgendwie das hier so, der Arm so ein bisschen, die Hand, die Armunterseite ein bisschen rot war, weil das dann schon ein bisschen auf den Pulsalern rumschippert. Ich hab jetzt keine Angst davor, dass das mir die Pulsalern aufschneiden könnte.
Ich würd sie gleich verklagen.
Aber immerhin kann jetzt hier die Farbe nicht mehr abgehen.
Was jetzt hier noch besonders scharfkantig ist, ist die Stelle direkt unter dem Mauspad.
Die beiden Ecken da, ja?
Die beiden Ecken, wo quasi die Ritze ist.
Ist ja richtig scharf. Krass!
Wo die...
Kannst du noch wegfeilen? Auch hier, das kannst du noch entgraten.
Wegfeilen...
Mit der Fräse einfach...
Das müsste man so als Service anbieten.
An der Ecke bin ich jetzt noch nicht hängen geblieben, muss ich sagen. Also damit hab ich überhaupt keine Probleme. Aber das sollte man vielleicht vorher mal im Laden ausprobieren.
Mit der Nagelfeile einfach so ein bisschen...
Was mir positiv aufgefallen ist, im Gegensatz zu vorher, früher hab ich, also mein letztes MacBook hatte schon eine Tastaturhintergrundbeleuchtung, die ich nie genutzt habe, weil ich es eher nervig fand. Beim neuen finde ich die echt schick.
Schick inwiefern, als dass man es entziffern kann.
Dass man es dadurch viel besser entziffern kann.
Ich finde die Software-Einstellung, wie man es an- und ausmacht, ist nervig. Vor allem, dass es bei mir, bei der neuen Tastatur ist es anders. Aber wenn du nichts siehst, ist es eh dunkel.
In so einem Twilight hast du das Problem, dass die Beschriftung genauso hell macht, wie die Taste ist. Und dann siehst du halt nichts mehr.
Genau, und das ist bei dem hier deutlich besser geworden. Es gibt so dieses Zwischenlicht, in dem man die Tastatur plötzlich gar nicht mehr erkennen kann, obwohl die Hintergrundbeleuchtung an ist. Der ist nicht mehr so stark aus, also wesentlich kleiner geworden. Es gibt diesen Punkt noch, aber er ist besser geworden. Ansonsten find ich süß, dass man bei iChats einfach seine iPhone Kopfhörer reinstecken kann und das Mikro nutzen kann. Die Taste weiß ich nicht, weil die Taste an meinem iPhone Mikro ist kaputt, an meinem Headset.
Doch die Taste soll funktionieren für iTunes, glaub ich.
Genau, ansonsten bin ich glücklich mit dem Ding. Achso, und ich hab das Gefühl, das ist im Sleep-Modus nicht, dass der Akku mich irgendwie nicht ganz so sehr mag.
Das SMC-Update, das gerade kam, ist ja für dein Gerät nicht, ne?
Genau, das ist für mein Gerät nicht. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass es also gar nicht so im laufenden Betrieb der Akku das Problem ist, sondern im Sleep-Modus. Und vielleicht, weil der RAM ist ja deutlich schneller getaktet als beim alten. Der ist ja jetzt irgendwie mit 1066 MHz statt beim alten noch 666.
Ja, kann schon sein. Kannst du da aber einstellen, diesen PM-Set, kannst du da sagen, dass er gleich irgendwie to disk irgendwie speichert und dann noch ausgeht? Oder geht das nicht?
Ja, aber ich will keinen, ich möchte ja den Sleep-Modus haben. Und das ist so, also ich hab das Gefühl, dass er nicht, zumindest war ich jetzt nicht positiv überrascht von der Akkulaufzeit. Vielleicht pendelt sich das noch ein bisschen ein. Akkus muss ich ja auch so ein bisschen erstmal eingewöhnen, aber da hatte ich schon auf mehr gehofft. Gerade weil ich auch immer nur diese so unglaublich energiesparende On-Board-Grafik nutze und nicht die dedizierte Grafikkarte. Und der man sehr gut arbeiten kann.
Ich kauf mir das Ding, als wenn da oben ein TS drin ist.
Ach so, aber was wirklich schick ist, sind die Gesten. Also ich brauch ne Weile, um mich dran zu gewöhnen. Also zwei Fingerscrolling kennen wir, lieben wir seit Jahren. Mit drei Fingern kann man, also man kann in einigen Programmen, zum Beispiel in Preview, kann man damit zoomen, indem man so wie auf ein iPhone die Finger so aufzieht. Nutze ich exakt gar nicht. In Safari kann man mit drei Fingern vor- oder zurückgehen. Das ich ja viel sinnvoller finden würde, wenn man da mit den Tad wechseln könnte. Aber in Tweety kann man mit drei Fingern eine Backfunktion nutzen. Und mit vier Fingern kann man auf den Desktop zugreifen oder das Dashboard starten. Nie Quatsch, in diesen allgemeinen Fensterüberblickmodus gehen. Und das macht echt Laune. Also das gewöhnt man sich. Also das ist jetzt nicht ein Feature, das ich am ersten Tag angenutzt habe, weil es sind ja doch schon einige neue Funktionen. Aber mittlerweile...
Wenn man mal druf ist, ist man druf.
Wenn man druf ist, ist man druf.
Verstehe.
Das schon. Aber hat seine Macken das MacBook Pro. Leider, leider. Und gerade das mit dem Display, das finde ich... Kann natürlich auch sein, dass das von Gerät zu Gerät unterschiedlich ist, dass das eine Produktionsvariante ist und dass der meins besonders schlimm ist.
Und besonders scharf ist.
Und besonders scharfkantig.
Ich habe übrigens noch eine Hausaufgabe für unsere Hörer. Und zwar bin ich ja so in so einer Stromspar-Spezie geworden zu Hause. Und mein altes Apple Cinema 23 Zoll Display verbraucht, wenn ich es ganz dunkel habe, 25 Watt. Und wenn ich auf volle Helligkeit hochschraube, dann glaube ich 70 oder so. Und mich würde jetzt mal interessieren, wie viel das neue Display verbraucht, das war glaube ich ein 24 Zoll, aber das macht jetzt nicht so doll den riesen Unterschied. Aber es hat ja eine LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung und da würde mich mal interessieren, wie viel Strom das verbraucht, bei einmal voller Helligkeit und einmal bei minimal Helligkeit.
Du meinst, falls jemand ein Strommessgerät zu Hause hat?
Genau, mal anschließen und dann mal die Wattzahl ermitteln. Und zwar aber dann achten, dass sie nicht gerade auch ihr Laptop darüber laden oder so. Weil es geht ja dann bei den Dingern.
So, jetzt werden wir schon langsam ein bisschen unkonzentriert, wir sind auch schon ganz schön wieder lange dabei.
Da wollte übrigens ein Typi mir Schokolade schicken. Willst du deine Adresse dafür rausrücken, dann lassen wir uns die hierher schicken.
Schoki?
Weil ich sagte, Abdaug getwittert, dass ich in Aachen wieder bei einem Lindwerk Schoko gekauft hab.
Ja, soll man eine Mail schreiben.
Wenn ich eine richtige Schoki will, dann soll er mal die Adresse rausrücken, und dann schickt er Schweizer Schokolade. Da sind wir doch dafür, oder?
Da sind wir dafür.
Ja, Schweizer Schokolade ist immer gut.
Sehr gut.
Soll er eine Mail an... Gibt's dann die Mail, die steht auf der Seite und so, ne?
Ja, genau. Soll er eine Mail schreiben.
Ja, das wär total toll. Wir berichten dann live, ob die gut schmeckt. Wir essen die live, genau.
So, was haben wir denn noch wirklich, wirklich, wirklich Wichtiges? Ich hab mir hier noch so ein paar... ich hab noch so Kleinigkeiten, aber ich bau auch langsam ab.
Also, eine Kleinigkeit hab ich noch, die mich irgendwie ein bisschen ratlos hat stehen lassen, und zwar, dass Apple offensichtlich eine gigantische Serverfarm hochziehen will irgendwo in North Carolina.
Ja, da gab's so einen Bericht, dass die da irgendwie irgendwelche Gesetze ändern, damit die da irgendwie voll die Text-Reducings kriegen irgendwie.
Die sind jetzt durch?
Ja, und jetzt muss Apple nur noch sagen, dass sie wirklich da für die nächsten Jahre irgendwie da eine Milliarde Dollar investieren. Das ist aber auch nicht auf einen Schlag, sondern wirklich auch über längeren Zeitraum.
Wofür will Apple massenhaft eine riesige Serverfarm hochziehen?
Na, weil so Google Wave halt richtig Rechenpower braucht.
Du meinst, die kaufen Google auf? Na, was weiß ich?
Nee, aufkaufen bestimmt nicht, geht ja auch gar nicht.
Jetzt hat sie ihr eigenes Google Wave.
Das wollen sie nicht, aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass für sie das auch ein Thema ist.
Klar, wobei ich da nicht verstehe, warum man sowas in North Carolina macht. Ist da nicht warm? Ist das nicht ein warmer Start? Will man sowas nicht gleich in einem kühlen Start machen, wo man dann ordentlich Kühlkosten spart? Also es macht doch Sinn, oder nicht?
North Carolina? Das ist ein warmer Start.
Weiß ich nicht. Hört sich so nach Südstart an.
Das ist doch mal die richtige Frage für Wolfram Alpha.
Allerdings, Wolfram Alpha, übrigens ja. Ich hab mal bei Wolfram Alpha, ich wollte es mal testen und ich wollte schon immer mal wissen, wie der Abstand von hier nach Frankfurt ist. Und da hab ich eigentlich im Distance between Berlin and Frankfurt. Und dann kam da wirklich mit der Distanz und wie lange Licht bis dahin braucht und so. Also in Fiber auch, falls man irgendwie und so weiter. Und also das war richtig schick. Der hat richtig konkret auf diese Frage geantwortet, so wie ich es haben wollte. Da dachte ich auch, ui.
Ich hab das ehrlich gesagt noch nie wirklich benutzt.
Im Augenblick sind da gerade 32 Grad Celsius. Über welchen Zeitraum ist das denn? Ach, Woche.
Na 32 ist nicht, das ist die Mean Temperature.
Oder? Nee, nee, das ist die aktuelle Temperatur.
Stimmt, Average 23. Krass.
Gleich auch hier so mit Grafen und so, wie die Temperatur so... Das ist schon schick, oder?
Mit Prediktion für die nächsten Tage und so. Fucking hell.
Können wir mal ein bisschen rumdiskutieren über Wolf von Afer beim nächsten Mal.
Also ich fand das schick. Auch mit der Distanz, mach mal mit der Distanz. Das kommt auch gleich so in Schick. Auch gleich mit einer Karte, wo sie gleich so die Linie zeigen. Von hier nach da, so siehst du gleich. Mach mal.
Kann ich auch sofort Pritzlauer Berg nach Fritzsheim machen?
Bestimmt.
Frankfurt, Hesse to Berlin.
Light in fiber 1,98 Millisekunden. Falls du halt deine Glasfaserstrecke von hier nach Frankfurt hast.
Krass.
Schon schick, oder?
Das ist echt wütend. Dieses Wolfram-Alpha, das ist wirklich so, das macht echt Angst. Da haben sie immer alle Angst.
Stell dir mal ein paar andere Fragen.
Der kann echt nicht alles, also du willst ihn keine Sachen fragen, wo er sozusagen das Netz kennen muss. Du willst ihn wirklich Sachen fragen, wo man was wissen muss.
Können wir mal gucken, was er zum Thema WWDC sucht.
Und jetzt kommt er so mit Statistiken, die letzten waren da und dann, die nächste müsste in drei Wochen sein. Kann man ja hochskalieren, so hochrechnen, ne?
Alpha isn't sure what to do with your input. Next inputs to try, next revolution. Anklicken, next revolution.
Kommen beim Mobile Next den einzigen Podcast, bei dem ihr live zuhören könnt, wie die zwei Leute das erste Mal hier leben.
Ich hab auch eine neue Suchmaschine von Microsoft, dieses Bing. Hab ich mal benutzt, die war gar nicht so schlecht. Der hat gleich lauter Links gezeigt, wo ich gesehen hab, dass ich die alle schonmal angeklickt hab, weil ich das gleiche ja schonmal mit Google gesucht hab. Und der war gut mit seinen Hits, also es war okay. Ich fand das nicht schlecht. Hat mich ein bisschen erstaunt sozusagen.
Tja, naja gut, das wird natürlich nicht reichen, ne?
Ne, also Bing mag sein, dass das eine okaye Suchmaschine ist, aber warum soll ich von da weggehen?
Gibt da eine schöne Webseite und zwar www.blackdog.ie Ach, kann man den eigentlich, wonach könnte man bei Live nicht suchen?
Da gab's so einen Haufen Suchbegriffe, die gesperrt waren, so abstrusische Sachen, Darmstromfotos, glaube ich.
Poste dir mal kurz eine URL in deine Webbrause. www.blackdog.ie slash google-bing slash search.html.php Ganz modernes PHP. Das ist eine Webseite, wo du Google und Bing gleichzeitig dasselbe suchen lassen kannst und dir zwei Frames angucken lassen kannst, was da der eine und was der andere rausschmeißt.
Ja, aber es gab doch mal, Moment mal, es gab bei Microsoft Live-Suchmaschinen, die die können auch bestimmte Suchbegriffe, können die einfach nicht finden. Ich glaube Frauen.
Damit der Suchmaschine keine Frauen finden?
Ach, das, wie, habt ihr die Live-Suche abgeschafft?
Keine Ahnung. Strumpf.
Ja, ja, es gab absurde viele, ach ja, guck mal, wenn man bei Bing nach Strumpfhose sucht, bekommt man einen Hinweis, der Suchbegriff Strumpfhose führt möglicherweise zu sexuell eindeutigen Inhalten. Ändern sie ihre Suchbegriffe, um Ergebnisse zu erhalten. Das ist nicht, sind sie über 18, sind sie über 12, haben sie schon mal ein menschliches Wesen gesehen und können mit dem Thema Strumpfhose umgehen, sondern du darfst nach Begriffen wie Strumpfhose bei Bing einfach nicht suchen. Und wir sprechen von einer guten Suchmaschine.
Bei Bing, also wenn ich das hier eingehe, kommt da durchaus was.
Achso, ihr seid auf Englisch gerade, oder?
Naja, das Bing funktioniert ja derzeit nur in den USA. Nee, es gibt ja auch eine deutsche Vision. Nee, gibt es nicht, sondern das ist noch das alte MSN Search.
Achso, das sieht einfach nur so aus.
Genau, das ist auch geiles Marketing, oder? Ja, sie haben das nur, wenn du auf USA umschaltest, hast du wirklich das neue Bing.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, warum die ganze Scheiße nicht geht. Die total toll ange... Du kannst da ziemlich nix suchen bei der Suchmaschine.
Jungs, auf Twitter haben verschiedene Leute angekündigt, dass sie jetzt bei Mobamex einschlafen wollen. Das müssen wir verhindern. Also... Ja, weiß nicht, ich kann jetzt hier noch zwei, drei Sachen abhacken. Habt ihr mitbekommen, dass es jetzt gelbe Seiten auf iPhone als Applikation gibt?
Oh, endlich.
Also gibt's jetzt als App? Kann man auch Sachen angepasste mit gelben Seiten verstehen?
Ja, habe ich gesehen, die waren ja ganz oben in der Top-Dinge. Tragisch.
Na ja, ich hab jetzt nicht so viel Bedarf, die ganze Zeit zu suchen, aber es ist in der Lage, mir da, wo ich bin, um mich herum Änderungen schnell rein anzuzeigen. Das halte ich schon mal für was Wertvolles, weil das findet man jetzt mit diesen ganzen anderen Hippen.
Und kann man ja auch gleich so klicken und sagen, gleich Adressbuch oder so rein?
Ach, du hast es nicht probiert.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht viel Erfahrung damit gesammelt, aber das macht da auf jeden Fall erstmal einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck. Und die andere Applikation, die für mich Wert hatte, die ich jetzt sozusagen benutze, in meinem Runterladen tue ich mir viel, aber wie das immer so ist mit dem Benutzen, ist Soma FM.
Soma FM, wo habe ich das schon mal gehört?
Ja, das sind die, die diese coolen Radiostationen machen, wo immer so die tolle Musik kommt. Ah! Groove Salad und so. Und die haben jetzt einfach eine iPhone App. Das heißt, du hast so eine App und kannst dann schon vorher gucken, was da gerade läuft und dann eben auch gleich den Streamer mit empfangen.
Ist der App Store down oder ist mein iPhone gerade zu dämlich hier mit deinem Internetverbindung? Ach, ich komm jetzt hier erstmal zu www.acor.de, wieso das denn?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Hat nichts mit meinem Internet hier zu tun. Das ist hier nur das dobe Alles, was immer mit einem Podcast den Stream wegschmeißt.
Bin ich hier gerade über irgendwie ein anderes, über irgendeinen anderen WLAN-Hotspotente oder irgendwie so eine Scheiße?
Und, was noch?
Ich bin immer auf nur drin.
Du bist nicht konzentriert.
Ich bin gerade nicht konzentriert, weil man blöd ist.
Ich finde, wir haben jetzt auch genug gesprochen.
Ja, Pamba.
Ich muss kurz noch was nachliefern. Und zwar, wollten irgendwelche Leute wissen, was ich nun genau auf dem Mac für diese Atmel-Boards benutze, wie das SDK 600 und 500. Und zwar gibt es dieses AVR-Dude, gibt es von Objective Development, die auch irgendwie, machen die Loungebar-Events?
Ja, die machen Loungebar.
Die machen Loungebar, von denen gibt es irgendwie so ein Atmel-für-Mac-Paket, irgendwie ganz toll. Und das heißt irgendwie Cross-Pack, weil sie mussten es irgendwie umbenennen, weil vorher hatten sie so einen Namen, der Atmel wohl nicht gefallen hat. Und jetzt heißt AVR-Mac-Pack hieß es vor, und jetzt heißt es Cross-Pack, gibt es bei Objective Development. Und da ist irgendwie neueste AVR-Dude drin und auch der GCC als Dreier und als Vierer und ein Simulator und Zeug und was hast du nicht alles gesehen. Und das ist alles ein Paket, und da muss man das irgendwie nicht so zusammendröseln und dann ist alles ganz schick. Und das kann sogar auch mit dem neuen SDK-600 von Atmel direkt per USB sprechen, dann braucht man eben keine Serial Adapters und so weiter mehr.
Jungs, ich glaub wir sind durch, oder? Also ich bin durch.
Achso, dann gab's noch was.
Wir haben jetzt irgendwie drei Stunden voll.
Da haben ja Leute mir getwittert, dass es jetzt Loadrunner für den Mac gibt. Und ich dachte schon, ok, kannst ja mal gucken.
Wie ist Loadrunner für Mac?
Für ein iPhone, Entschuldigung, fürs iPhone. Und dann sind aber jetzt schon die Kommentare und hier die Reviews von den Leuten, die sind, also da will man das schon gar nicht mehr ausblenden. Das ist so schlecht, ich meine, die Steuerung ist schlecht, die Grafik ist schlecht, das ist scheiße umgesetzt und irgendwie ist totaler Müll. Keine Mühe gegeben, kein Nix. Und das ist auch nicht das Original Loadrunner nachgemacht, sondern irgendwie die Automaten-Version, die so ein bisschen Japan-animäßig irgendwie so gemacht sind. Also die Figur sieht so komisch aus, da ist gar nicht das Original Loadrunner Figurchen.
Verstehe.
Jedenfalls, also ich hab mir das nicht geschoppt, fand ich zu doof.
Was ist denn dein aktueller Twitter? Benutzst du Twitter auf dem iPhone? Kleint?
Ja, ich hab immer noch den alten gelassen. Ich benutze immer noch hier diesen Twitterriffig.
Aber in seiner aktuellen Version.
Ja, klar, ich update ja immer.
Ich bin nach wie vor, ich hab mir Twitter von Pro gekauft.
Einfach, um es auch zu haben.
Im Wesentlichen, aber ich bin nach wie vor Tweety-Anhänger eher.
Na, ich bin immer noch unentschlossen. Ich wechsle hin und her. Twitterphone ist ein bisschen instabil und nimmt permanent Features rein und dann wieder raus in die nächsten Versionen. Das ist alles ein bisschen verstörend.
Was ich bei Twitterphone am nervigsten finde, ist, dass man am Anfang, wenn man startet, dass es erst mal hakt, weil es die ganzen Tweets nachlädt.
Das macht die neueste Version nicht mehr.
Bei mir schon, leider.
Offensichtlich habe ich da irgendwann einen Präf richtig gesetzt, dass er das erst mal nicht automatisch tut. Dann ist es zu vertragen.
Es hat sich verbessert. Gibt es nicht so etwas wie Threads, mit denen man so etwas in den Hintergrund auslagern kann und dann hakt es einfach nicht?
Ja, sicherlich alles irgendwie. Na gut, wie das immer so ist.
So, nachdem wir jetzt schon anfangen über Twitter clients zu sprechen, sollten wir doch einfach bis nächste Woche warten.
Ob sich unsere Voraussagen, eins haben wir aber noch nicht vorausgesagt.
Und zwar?
Na, ob es außer iPhone noch andere Hardware Ankündigungen gibt.
Na MacBooks.
Du meinst ja.
Einfach ist jetzt, was will ich sagen, meine Erfahrung sagt das immer, nachdem ich mir ein MacBook gekauft habe, relativ bald neu gekommen.
Das ist ja mein, da solltest du so eine Webseite machen, wo du dann immer dein Kaufdatum einträgst, dass man dann irgendwie...
Genau, ich werde Börsen-Guru. Ich mach einfach Apple Predictions auf der Basis des...
Das eigenen Kaufwagens.
Dann muss ich so anonym, manimisiert einkaufen gehen und dann steigt oder fällt der Aktienkurs nach dem.
Verstehe. Na gut, das wird sich sicherlich durchsetzen.
Achso, und ein Tablett wird es nicht geben, oder?
So, ich hab jetzt irgendwie heute schon sechs Stunden gepodcast. Ich muss jetzt irgendwie ein Ende finden.
Und die Leute haben bestimmt auch schon lange Podcast gehört heute.
Genau.
Macht doch nochmal Werbung für dein CRE. Welcher war das für den aktuellen mit Zensursolar?
Hab ich doch schon.
Ja, jetzt zum Schluss nochmal für die, die immer noch nicht genug haben können. Wie gesagt, auf jeden Fall die erste Hälfte ist wirklich sehr, sehr erleuchtend und sehr, sehr angenehm.
Und der zweite Teil hat nur Max nicht gefallen.
Und der zweite Teil hat nur mir nichts gefallen. Ich hab nicht gesagt, nicht gefallen, ich hab gesagt, da lässt es ein bisschen.
Da war nicht mehr so spannend.
Da ist es nicht mehr ganz so pulsierend.
Naja, so ist das.
Das ist einfach nur noch, ja.
Ihr meinten, die haben eh schon alle gehört.
Ich werd langsam zum CRE-Fanboy, merkste das?
Sehr gut.
Find ich auch super.
Und, machen wir noch Winkel-Winkel?
Die nächste Ausgabe ist dann auch für dich. Da greif ich ein Thema auf, was wir hier schon mal...
Ich hab's bei Twitter durchgelesen. Ich hab's bei Twitter durchgelesen. Da ist irgendwie mal blablabla, bin gerade wieder vom CRE-Zauber gekommen.
Ja, die haben sozusagen im Vorfeld gepetzt.
Du willst das aber nicht sagen.
Aber wird interessant.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, was mich wirklich interessiert.
Jetzt fangen wir mal an Tschüss zu sagen, oder? Also, das war's von Mobamex. Nächste Woche geht's weiter. Ich hoffe, falls nicht irgendwas will, was dazwischenkommt, und dann berichten wir nicht live und auch nicht in Farbe von den Ergebnissen der Worldwide Developer Conference Keynotes mit Steve.
Aftermath.
Die Aftermath. Tschüss.